So, Leute.
Ich bin mal außerplanbar jetzt hier am Start.
Gucken, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ah, ich muss die Bitrate hochstellen.
Mit der Bitrate kann man nichts spielen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist Massive Debate.
Zeig mal.
Gucken, ob das Vodafone heute mitmacht.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Vodafone, please.
Zeig mal her.
Äh, Stats.
Stats, okay.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Mal gucken.
Also, ich denke mal, dass ich mindestens...
Am besten 8 Mbit machen sollte.
Dass das schön flüssig...
Dass das schön scharf aussieht, alles.
Gucken, ob das Vodafone mitmacht, Alter.
NAA im Incoming.
Mittlerweile geht's.
Es geht halbwegs.
Nachdem ich jetzt 4, 5 Tage wieder gespielt habe,
treffe ich eigentlich wieder ganz okay.
Okay, 8 Mbit.
Mal gucken, ob der Scheiß funktioniert.
Ich bin gespannt.
Das Einzige, was jetzt noch ein bisschen...
Was jetzt noch ein bisschen failen könnte, ist,
dass ich hier auf Window-Modus umgeschaltet habe.
Normalerweise spiele ich Fullscreen.
Mal gucken, ob das einen großen Unterschied macht.
Keine Ahnung.
Theoretisch schon.
Praktisch weiß ich nicht.
Wir werden jetzt einfach...
Oh, oh, oh.
Missed Frames, Leute.
MonkaS.
Naja, anscheinend geht's.
Leaked.
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder leaked?
Laufen des irgendwas leaked?
Ich sag dazu nur...
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob Vodafone mitmacht.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich mach mal eine Vorschau an.
360p, das reicht, dass ich sehe, ob's leaked.
Ja, wir spielen jetzt ein paar Waffen frei.
Ich hab mir überlegt, warum mach ich das nicht eigentlich mal im Stream?
Das haben letztens...
Das gleiche liegt auf.
Fuck, Alter.
Das haben mir letztens im Stream so viele gesagt.
Max, mach das doch im Stream.
Und warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Na, mein Standard-Layout aktuell ist ja...
Links hier, wenn man mal auf Loadouts geht.
Das ist ja so meine Standard-Layout.
Das ist meine Standard-Klasse für...
Na, zu alles M4-Vollausbau...
Oh, vielleicht soll ich die Musik ausmachen fürs Spielen gleich.
Ein Stückchen leiser.
Pepega-Gegner.
Ey, das ist übelst krasse Tryhard-Action am Start.
Das ist so...
Ey, ich hab...
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Overwatch-Ranked ist nix gewesen gegen das rumgetryharde und rumgeschwitzte hier.
Das ist...
Ich hab echt...
Ich hab selten ein Game gesehen, wo das so krass ist.
Hier.
Vor allem, da kommen die Maps dazu, in denen du dich überhaupt nicht bewegen darfst, ohne
dass du dich von irgendeinem Winkel um drei Ecken, wo du nicht richtig siehst, sondern
nur irgendwie zwei Pixel vom Kopf rausgucken.
Ach, vergiss es.
Also, das hier ist so meine 0815-Klasse aktuell für alles.
Das ist ja auch so alles OP-mäßige zusammen, M4.
Und das Ding ist halt...
Das schreddert halt schlechthin, ne?
Oh, Moment.
Ich glaube, ich muss noch Akimbo ausrüsten hier.
Das ist besser.
Ah, haben wir schon.
Excellent.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist die falsche Klasse.
Wieder Braumer.
Ah, Akimbo muss da noch rein.
WTF?
Ja, sonst ist das gar nicht richtig noobsicher für mich.
Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
0 W, größer Kek W.
Was erzählt ihr mir denn da für Dinger?
Das ist hier Fake News, oder?
Okay, wir spielen ein bisschen waffenfrei.
Also, sowas hier.
Ich wollte mir nämlich noch ein zweites Layout machen.
Einmal.
Also, neben meiner 0815.
Warzone M4-Klasse.
Wollte ich mir noch hier einen Setup machen.
Und noch einen...
Für einen zweiten Loadout-Drop mit der Schneider.
Wo habe ich denn meine Schneider?
Klasse.
Wo ist die?
Warum ist die weg?
Leute, meine Frage an euch.
Was für eine Schneider nehmt ihr?
Also, was ist...
Ich bin ja noch unschlüssig.
Weil ich will mal ein zweites Loadout machen,
was ich droppen lassen kann.
Ähm...
Wenn man genug Geld hat.
Also, das Ding oder das Ding?
Ich habe jede Menge Videos gesehen damit jetzt.
In Streams, aber auch damit.
Was die hat?
Kein Kugeltrop.
Das hat doch alles Kugeltrop.
Sogar meine M14 hat Kugeltrop.
Intervention.
Siehst du auch, was haben wir denn hier?
Crazy...
Das ist Stelser-Zeug.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Crazy Knoll.
So, wir spielen erstmal hier das frei.
Schauen wir mal.
Leute, stellt euch drauf ein,
dass...
Übelst abgecampt wird jetzt.
Ich sag's euch.
Was spielen wir?
Domination?
Also, die beste Playlist ist die hier, ne?
Also, die beste...
Moment, das hier.
Die beste Playlist zum Waffen ranken ist die hier.
Passt mal...
Das ist aber absolut Clusterfuck.
Ihr werdet es gleich sehen.
Es ist absolut Clusterfuck, diese Liste, ey.
Passt mal auf, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich richtig gesetzt?
Guck mal gleich.
Absolut Clusterfuck.
Wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich kommt hier...
Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich am Anfang...
Ich mach mal die Musik aus.
Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich am Anfang Rust.
Rust.
Ähm.
Domination.
Rust.
Ich sag's.
Rust-Kill kommt vor.
Nein, Alter.
Das ist das Schlimmste.
Rust-Kill.
Das wird bloß noch...
Das wird bloß noch durch Shipment...
Shipment-Domination getoppt oder so.
Das ist das Schlimmste, Leute.
Wir müssen übrigens mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke passt.
So, ich, ich, ich, ich rushe jetzt mal eine Runde mit meiner MP4 hier rum.
Easy.
In your face.
Was ist das Geile?
Ich sag euch, Leute.
Das ist das übelste Clusterfuck, der ich gerade...
Was?
Das ist so geil.
Ist aber übelst...
Das war's.
Du weißt überhaupt nicht von wo.
Also, wie gesagt, das ist hier kein wahnsinnig krasses 30-30-0-Kill-Gameplan.
Das ist ein...
Das geht hier gar nicht.
Das ist einfach nur...
Waffen-Leveln.
MP7 muss ich auch noch leveln.
Okay, jetzt stellen sie mir mal hier oben ein bisschen rum.
Grau muss ich leveln.
Wow.
Fuck.
Und...
Ähm...
Noch eine Schneiber.
Schneiber muss ich auch noch leveln.
Wow.
Was ist da hinten los?
Oh, den aimen wir jetzt ab.
Rekt.
Das Schöne an Hardcore ist tatsächlich...
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich mal gerne Hardcore spiele.
Es geht einfach...
What the hell?
Es geht einfach schneller.
Ja, ist klar.
Man macht zwar keine krassen Gameplays, aber wenn man Waffen freispielen will,
ist Hardcore tatsächlich viel, viel nicer.
Meine Güte, Alter.
Wo willst du denn hier hin?
Und ich sag euch, die Map ist halt der Clusterfuck schlechter.
Guckt es euch an.
Du weißt überhaupt nicht, wo du hingucken sollst.
Du weißt echt nicht, wo du hingucken sollst.
Aber macht nix.
Geht ja nur...
Übrigens, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, ne?
Fragenmäßig, wie in jedem Stream, einfach...
Einfach reinhauen in den Chat.
Ich guck dann rein.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass...
Guckt es euch an.
Nicht, dass man sich jetzt hier wahnsinnig konzentrieren müsste.
Geht mir ja nur um Unlocks.
Ob da noch einer ist?
Wow.
Wow, MonkaS.
Ich muss hier mal weg.
Ich hab Schiss.
Am besten ist, Ecke stehen bleiben.
Ecke stehen bleiben ist in Modern Warfare das Mittel der Wahl.
Einfach Ecke stehen bleiben.
Oh, da kommt was.
Wie gesagt, es ist so easy.
Einfach Ecke stehen bleiben.
One-on-one-Rust.
Quickscope.
Was?
Ist...
Ist der Dude gerade ernsthaft?
Hinter mir gespawnt?
Oder war das mein Teammate, was da auf mich geschossen hat?
Oh, wir sind Erster.
Beste.
Da bin ich zufrieden.
Solange wir Erster sind, ist alles kein Problem mehr.
Ich glaub, wir brauchen noch 1, 2 für Vitorl.
Wow.
Oh nein.
Ist leer.
Fuck, Alter.
Okay, YOLO.
Was hat man hier?
Übelst reutische Waffen für Hardcore.
Von wo auch immer.
So, beste Posi, Leute, zeige ich euch mal, wenn ihr ein bisschen abschimmeln wollt.
Hier.
Beste Posi.
Da könnt ihr hier rauspiken.
Und dann rennen sie euch ins Fadenkreuz.
Guckt da hier.
Da hinten ist schon einer.
Der weiß nicht, worauf er sich einlässt.
Der krasse Camper-Keks ist am Start, ey.
Guckt's hier.
Sag's euch.
Beste.
Beste Spot.
Wenn man einfach nur sitzen will und campen will auf Rust.
Bester Spot.
Guckt euch mal die high-detaillierte Schraube oben links an.
Beste, beste, beste Sitzspot.
Beste Camps.
Aber ich kann nicht lange campen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich krieg dann, ich krieg echt totale Anfälle, wenn ich sitzen muss.
Oben ist einer drauf.
Gewinnen wir eigentlich?
Ja, wir gewinnen.
Okay, gut.
Wenigstens gewinnen wir.
Da ist links was.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Links hier.
Da war was.
Ich hab's.
Was ist mit dem los?
MonkaS.
War da noch was?
War da noch einer?
Da war noch einer.
Hedgehog.
Noch einer.
Von wegen NA-Aim, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Ich hab die letzten Tage wieder geübt.
Ist kein NA-Aim mehr angesagt.
Aber Skill-Based Matchmaking ist angesagt.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir jetzt gut sind, die Runde,
dann kriegen wir die absoluten Schwitz-Gegner des Off-Doom.
Das nächste Mal.
Oh, fuck, den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Die Schwitz-Gegner-Off-Doom kriegen wir das nächste Mal.
Ist das, weiß, ich weiß es jetzt schon.
Und vor allem das Geile ist ja der Spawn-Off-Rust, ne?
Wie?
Was soll das?
Warum?
Das ist mein Kill gewesen.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Okay, Pegas.
Oh, den hab ich schön veraimt.
Da war, da war's NA-Aim wieder am Start, Leute.
Ich geh, ich geh, ich geh, glaub ich, wieder in meine, in meine, in meine Schimmel-Ecke.
Beste.
Oh.
Oh, Team-Mate, Team-Mate.
Ich geh mal, ich geh in meine Schimmel-Ecke.
Beste hier.
Oh.
Easy.
Easy win.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Guck mal.
Leute, es ist, es ist Rust.
Und noch nicht mal auf Rust bewegt sich was.
Komm, wir gehen jetzt.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, mein Team-Mate.
Wie soll man da, wie soll man das jetzt sehen so schnell?
Da ist er.
Da war er.
Jetzt kommt's von hinten bestimmt gleich.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Von hinten.
Da wird, da wird gesprüht und gebetet.
Jetzt Friendly-Fire, ja, gibt's.
Aber die haben's richtig gut gemacht, das Friendly-Fire, muss ich sagen.
Okay.
Das Friendly-Fire, diesmal bringt dich selber um, wenn du zu offensichtlich Team-Kills machst.
Find, find ich eigentlich ziemlich gut gemacht.
Es gibt ja echt mal ne Sache, die ich loben muss, ne?
Wo, wo war da was?
What the hell?
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft?
Ich weiß, der Chat, sie betet mich, jeder Chat schreibt mir, sie, ja klar, da war er.
Oh ja, krasse C4-Taktik.
Wow, oh.
Ich seh nix.
Okay.
Die müssen, in dem Moment, wo man wegguckt, ne, natürlich, alle haben ihn gesehen, ne, logisch.
In dem Moment, wo, what the, jetzt wird man doch genug zut, ich fass es nicht.
Übrigens, positive KD, also generell, also, das war alles über 1,5, what the fuck.
Alles über 1,5 kannst du in dem Spiel eh vergessen.
Das sorgt dafür, dass du keine, das, das geht nicht.
Kann man vergessen, aber das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Okay.
Es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm, ich muss sagen, wenn man sich damit abfindet, dass Wins mehr zählen, dass Wins mehr zählen als KD, ist es vollkommen in Ordnung.
Man muss sich bloß, und außerdem, ai, ai, ai, außerdem spiel ich das ja eh nicht zum großen, krassen Hyper-Gameplays machen, sondern zum Waffen-Unlocken.
Kommt da einer?
Ah, Fuß geschossen.
Im Battlefield zählen Wins auch mehr.
Ja, ich finde im Battlefield, ja, ja, du hast schon recht.
Ähm, allerdings ist es im Battlefield oftmal so, dass ich sag, mein Team geht mir selber so krass auf den Sack, ähm, dass ich lieber viele Kills mach.
Weil ich hab kein, ich hab kein Bock, Teamplay zu machen im Battlefield.
Wenn mein Team übelst...
Übelst rumsackt.
Weißt du, wenn du Teamplays machen willst, rennst du in die Gegner rein, dein Team lässt dich da vergammeln.
Dann, dann mach ich lieber Kills im Battlefield.
Okay, schön, Achtung, Achtung, schön in die Schimmelnecke.
Easy, man, guck, da wär der Nächste gewesen.
Geh doch.
Aber doch ganz gut platt gemacht.
Ja, war Teamkill, weiß ich.
Ne, das sind Confirms, das sind keine, keine Deaths.
Ich glaub, weiß keiner.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Deaths überhaupt angezeigt werden in dem Spielmodus.
Doch, ja, 37, 21.
Wie gesagt, alles über 1,5er KD ist, ist in dem Game eigentlich auf Dauer gar nicht zu halten.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, jetzt nachdem ich wieder ein bisschen...
Ah, was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Jetzt nachdem ich wieder ein bisschen gespielt hab, ich könnte wetten,
dass die ganzen YouTube-Channels,
die,
so ultrakrasses Gameplay machen,
was nimmt man eigentlich für die Waffe am besten?
Diese ultrakrasses Gameplay machen,
dass das,
ich bin, ich, ich mein, beweisen kann ich's nicht,
aber ich bin mir jetzt sowas von sicher,
dass das Reverse-Boosted ist zum größten Teil.
Ähm,
ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt von jemand,
der hat Solo,
der hat Solo Warsong Trios gespielt.
Solo.
Und die Gegner hatten echt keine Hände.
Die haben ohne Hände gespielt,
die Gegner.
Anders kann ich's mir echt nicht erklären.
Oh, beste Map.
Beste Map.
Oh, natürlich super Ausgangslage.
Drei gegen fünf.
Ja, wenn du die KD sehen willst ingame,
dann kannst du ne...
Ja, schön, von beiden sein.
Äh, wenn du die sehen willst von...
Ja, dann.
What?
Wie schnell hat der mich denn geaimt?
Ah, fairer Spawn.
Fairer Spawn.
Fairer.
Mass...
Massive fairer Spawn.
Okay, der hat mich outplayed.
Ich mag das so.
Kill confirmed ist echt der schlimmste Modus.
Du spawst rein.
Blub, blub, blub.
Moment, der war da noch.
War der noch da hinten eben?
Der Dude ist doch noch hier rumgestellt, oder?
Oh ne, da darf ich nicht hoch.
Das ist Instant Death, wenn man da hoch geht.
Team, move.
Enemy at the junkyard.
Okay, jetzt machen wir Matrix 17.
Wieder ist nix.
What the fuck?
Enemy waiting overhead.
Warum ist da nix?
We...
Wir ist da durchgelaufen?
Kann doch nicht sein, dass da immer was.
Und übrigens, was hier auch...
Was man auch sieht in...
Kill confirmed auf...
auf... auf der...
What the fuck?
Auf der Map ist...
Kill confirmed.
Die Runden...
sind schneller, weil...
Kill confirmed.
...sind schneller.
...sind schneller vorbei, als...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Die Runden sind schneller...
What the fuck, was ist das?
Hat der mich gestuckt mit nem Pfeil?
Die sind schneller vorbei, als es irgendwie...
Die Runden sind schneller vorbei, als es irgendwie...
Zeit... Zeit gibt, ne?
Also diese Zeit läuft ab, bevor die Kills erreicht sind.
Das spricht jetzt halt auf für das Schimmel-Gameplay.
Da kommt gleich noch einer, ich sag's euch.
Oder er kommt da, da hab ich ein Problem.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Meine Güte, könnt ihr jetzt mal rauskommen?
Oh, fuck.
Aber...
Hauptsache, wir gewinnen.
Ich glaub, wir gewinnen gar nicht.
Ups.
Das war ich nicht.
Ey, woher weiß der...
...Dude immer, genau wenn...
...einer um die Ecke kommt?
Was ist mit dem los?
Das ist jetzt schlecht für mich.
Echt, es suckt. Ich muss hier...
...mit dem da weg.
Ede mal.
Hab ich doch.
Ey, what?
Ich sag euch doch, mir war letzte Runde zu gut.
Letzte Runde zu gut.
Das wechselt sich immer ab.
Also mir kann keiner erzählen, dass es hier...
...kein Matchmaking gibt, was das in irgendeiner...
...Art und Weise beschleunigt.
So.
Ey, dieser Dude...
...da unten, was ist denn mit dem los?
Was ist mit dem weißen Typ?
Der ist immer am Start...
...und guckt gleich in die richtige Richtung.
Ah, okay, da hätte ich nicht sprayen sollen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Der kommt gleich rüber.
Ha!
Der wusste schon wieder.
Der wusste schon wieder, ey.
What?
Okay, wir kriegen auf den Sack.
Das ist übrigens die beste Map im Game.
Nur mal so.
Ich hab's schon mal angemerkt.
Beste Map im Spiel.
Ist ohne Scheiß so.
Das ist die ein...
Also jetzt nicht hier auf Hardcore-Kill confirmed, ja.
Aber das ist die einzige Map...
...die legit...
Ey, der weiße...
...Typ, der fuckt mich echt ab.
Das ist die einzige Map, die...
What the fuck?
Guckst du mich an?
...die sinnvolle Wege hat.
Nee, es gibt kein Terminal.
Ey, der Wahnsinn.
Die Rolle ist wirklich voll von Arsch.
Der weiße Dude.
Jawoll.
Okay, da oben war noch einer. Vorhin.
Ey.
Wie, wie, wie krass...
...aimt der mich immer ab?
Ah nee, es gibt zwei...
...weiße Dudes.
Da ist er wieder.
Wow, was habe ich da jetzt aufgenommen?
Okay, gehen wir mal in die Mitte gucken.
Ist das meine Waffe, die ich wieder aufgenommen habe?
Spawnt dahinter einem.
Beste.
Oh, Mitte ist gefährlich. Mitte ist echt gefährlich.
Eigentlich muss man den Pro...
...Pro-Run hier machen.
Ne, den da.
Ja, manchmal...
...geht's gut, aber manchmal ist es halt so krass...
...wie da um dich drum rum gespawnt wird und alles.
Da kannst du...
...nix machen.
Das war klar, dass da einer drin steht.
Und was auch...
...übrigens, die Waffe hier. Ich muss euch die gleich mal mit Akimbo...
...zeigen. Das ist die absolut...
...die absolute Noob-Schredder-Waffe.
Guck mal, ich mach die jetzt mal.
Bam.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell...
...die killt?
Ja, klar.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Hahaha.
Das Ding ist so krass.
Oh, mein.
Überall sitzt einer.
Meine Fresse.
What?
Ich seh...
Ey, voll vergessen.
Okay, okay.
Die pushen bestimmt von hier rein.
Wir machen jetzt die altbewährte...
...ich bleib an der Ecke sitzen und guck Taktik.
Ich kann das...
...ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Achtung.
Was ist jetzt?
Oh, zu hoch. Oh.
Teammate. Grip.
Ja, selber schuld.
Ja.
Der aimt natürlich wieder ab.
Ey.
Also, bei dem Dude...
...ich weiß echt nicht, ey.
Du kommst da wirklich...
...um die Ecke und gehst da...
Scheiß-Kolter, mach das nicht.
Das ist...
...nichts für schwache Nerven, Alter.
Hahaha.
Ich guck da auch nur immer rein...
...ob da nicht irgendwie einer...
...gar so übertriebenes Zeugs...
...postet.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben einen neuen Operator.
Den...
...gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Äh, wenn ich überhaupt wüsste...
...wo der Kram überhaupt funktioniert.
Das ist die Menüführung in dem Spiel.
Hier irgendwie, oder? Ne, ne, ne.
Hm. Ah, Operator. Es gibt sogar...
...einen Knopf für.
Ja, ey.
Geh fort.
Game.
Ey, geh fort mit den Videos.
Ich brauch die Videos von dem Typen nicht.
Oh nein, Rust Domination.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Rust Domination, Leute.
Okay, MP7.
Jetzt wird's wieder schlimm.
Rust Domination, sag's euch.
Last nice, quickscope only.
Links...
Oh fuck, ich bin hängengeblieben.
Ich wollte nämlich grad raus und den Typ holen, der C...
...der C einnehmen wollte.
Wie gesagt, Gewinnen ist das Beste. Gewinnen gibt mehr Bonus.
Was macht der da?
Gewinnen gibt mehr Bonus...
...und mehr Bonus bringt Waffeleveln.
Keck, weh.
Der Dude da, ey.
Huge, huge outplayed.
Wat, wat, wo ist hier was?
Wo ist hier was? Leute, wow.
Hm, der wusst's.
Wohl gemerkt, ich hab Ghosts und Kaltplatter.
Da kann er gar nichts wissen.
Äh, Moment, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Jetzt ist's schwierig.
Hier kommst du eigentlich fast nie raus.
Hier musst du irgendwie durch die Mitte pushen.
In der Hoffnung, es guckt keiner oben runter.
Was ist hängengeblieben?
Ja, dass ich diesen Modus spiel, bin ich hängengeblieben.
Aber richtig massive hängengeblieben.
Aber es ist der beste Modus...
...zum Waffen unlocken.
Ist so.
Comeback, als würd's mich jucken.
What the hell.
Was zum, was ist hier los?
Sind die gerade alle von mir gespawnt?
Moment, der kommt rum, der kommt rum.
Das ist Rust, ja. Wow.
Das ist...
...Rust-Quickscope-Duell gerade.
Oh, da oben war einer.
Jetzt muss ich hier mal durch.
Wo ist denn der andere Typ?
Das Problem ist, du hast keine Ahnung wo.
Jetzt...
Ja.
Der kommt jetzt gleich hier.
Ist er da hochgerannt?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Nee, nee, nee, Kollege, so nicht.
Ah, ich dachte, da liegt einer.
Wow.
What the...
Warum schießt mein Teammate auf mich?
Der Typ da oben, den müssen wir killen.
Der ist mir mega auf den Sack.
So.
Oh, da kommt wer.
Was ist das? Care Package?
War das ein Care Package oder was war das für ein komischer Drop?
Warum schießt du auf deinen Teammate?
Ja, weil er auf mich geschossen hat.
Ich dachte, das ist ein Gegner.
Ah, jetzt schleiden wir hier rein und...
Next.
Oh, oh, ich hab was gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Gegner sind.
Einmal runtergetroppt.
Instant Down.
Hardcore.
Ja, muss ich, weil bester Modus zum Waffen-Unlocken.
Also hier irgendwie krassen Score-Gameplays machst du hier nicht.
Definitiv nicht.
Moment.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der hin ist.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal hier.
Aha.
What?
Wie? Wo ist der hin?
Warum sterben die nicht?
Zorgst du auch noch eine Runde Warzone?
Das Problem, ich würde es machen.
Das Problem, ich habe keinen, mit dem ich zusammenspielen kann gerade.
Und Solos in Warzone ist wirklich Müll.
Glaubt es mir, Leute.
Solos in Warzone wollt ihr nicht spielen.
Kann man hier eigentlich seine Waffe auflegen oder so?
What?
Ey, du siehst die nicht.
Du spielst das nur Solo.
Ernsthaft, wie geht das?
Wie kann man Warzone Solo spielen?
Ich kriege absolut Anfälle.
Was ist denn mit dem da los?
Oh, die Runde.
Ob wir die Runde noch gewinnen?
Das wird schwierig.
Die Gegner drücken ganz schön rein.
Alter.
Ey.
Was ist denn gerade los?
Ich kriege hier gar keinen Kill mehr raus.
Nächste Runde wird aber wieder besser.
Ist immer so.
Nächste Runde wird besser.
Es ist immer so, abwechselnd.
Abwechselnd so, abwechselnd so.
Okay, schauen wir mal kurz hier um die Ecke.
Okay, keine Ahnung was da ist.
Oh, oh.
Ich muss weg.
Ich bleib jetzt mal hier stehen.
Versteck mich in der Hoffnung, ich werde nicht getroffen von der Rakete.
Damn.
Der hat sich jetzt auch gedacht.
WTF, was ist mit dem los?
Ich hab übrigens Panik.
Das fallen ja alle um dich drum herum um.
Campen auf Dächern.
Exakt so ist Warzone.
Also wir können mal eine Runde Warzone Solo spielen.
Aber ich zeige euch dann auch, warum es halt sackt.
Weil ich finde, dass es sackt.
Solo Warzone, wohlgemerkt.
Weil, also ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen,
warum ich der Ansicht bin, dass es sackt.
Und zwar,
du spawnst in Warzone
und sobald du gelootet hast,
du hörst nichts mehr.
Du hörst nicht mehr.
Also wirklich, es geht jeder
ist direkt in der Ecke
und liegt.
Das ist das Schlimmste an Warzone.
Also an Solo Warzone.
Du spawnst und instant...
Loadout grabt die erstbeste Waffe
und dann wird hingelegt in Warzone.
Ja gut, man kann es ja mal wieder probieren mit der Effizienz.
Und das ist
in Trios halt viel besser.
Wir haben heute Morgen eine Runde Trios gespielt,
gleich gewonnen. Easy.
Oh, fuck.
Guckt übrigens, das war jetzt die Teamfire-Geschichte.
Wenn du zu offensichtlich
den Teammate killst...
Wow!
Wenn du zu offensichtlich den Teammate killst,
dann...
stirbst du selbst.
Also ich weiß nicht,
wie wir diese Runde gewinnen,
aber das kann einzig und allein daran liegen...
Was macht denn der Wilson da oben?
Das kann einzig und allein daran liegen,
dass die Gegner sich nicht für Flaggen interessieren.
Was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Man kriegt hier ja nichts.
Auf Scoreboard.
Probieren wir mal hier hoch zu gehen.
Vielleicht kriegen wir da noch was.
Wo ist da was?
Hier ist eine Wand.
Vielleicht hier?
Ist das eine Taktik?
Nein, Taktikeinstieg gibt es ja hier nicht.
Vergiss es.
Gehen wir mal hier hin.
Wo ist er denn?
Ach, spawnen die jetzt da hinten?
Oder wie?
Aimen wir mal kurz?
Ne, jetzt spawnen die halt nix mehr da hinten.
Die sehen übrigens den Schatten.
Das ist ziemlich...
übrigens richtig lowbrain, dass ich da jetzt runter bin.
Das ist eigentlich die beste Posi.
Alter,
move dich, Kollege, move dich, move dich, move dich.
Oh, ich dachte,
ich dachte,
wir können ihn sprayen, brain.
Oh, shit.
Ich dachte, wir können ihn sprayen, brain.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal die Pistols.
Die Pistols sind so krass.
Also, man ist besser in dem Spielmodus
ohne Scheiß mit Pistol only.
Pistol only.
Der Typ macht glaube ich gerade
Crossbow Challenges oder so.
Seht ihr das?
Wie ultra krass diese Pistols sind.
Diese Pistols sind so mega krass.
Ey, die sind der Wahnsinn.
Wir können ja gleich nochmal normalen Spielmodus spielen.
Da müsst ihr euch die Pistols mal angucken.
Ah, nice. Wir haben gewonnen.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Mist, ich habe mein Notepad nicht hier.
Weil ich habe mir für Warzone
habe ich mir so einen...
Ich habe es noch nicht auf einem anderen Rechner gesynct.
Für Warzone
habe ich mir so eine To-Do-Liste gemacht.
Oh, da haben wir reingeschissen.
Ui, ui, ui.
So nach dem Motto.
An welchen Sachen ich immer verrecke.
Und dass ich mir das merke.
How to...
Also was sollte man nicht machen?
Und Solo ist halt das Problem.
Ich rush
viel zu viel raus.
Aber mir macht Solo auch überhaupt keinen Spaß.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, dass die
den Solo-Modus geändert haben.
Weil ich habe auf Reddit was gelesen,
dass wohl auch in Solos
früher
keinen Instant-Respawn gab.
Also da habe ich
noch nicht gespielt.
Wie gesagt, ich spiele ja auch erst wieder seit 5 Tagen.
Wieso die Video-Qualität?
Die Video-Qualität müsste eigentlich recht gut sein.
Aber ich muss mal gucken, ob es irgendwelche
Questions oder Technik-Krams
Fragen im Chat gegeben hat.
Übrigens,
also wenn ich es
beim drüber scrollen sehen soll,
müsst ihr echt AdWobblers dabei schreiben.
Sonst wird das nichts.
Ich muss unbedingt mal
mein Steamlabs aufmachen.
Weil sonst
übersehe ich die ganzen
Subs.
Okay.
Machen wir erst noch ein bisschen mp7.
Was? Schon wieder Rust?
Ne.
Drei Monate
auch sieben Monate gesubt.
Dankeschön.
Pogos.
Was?
Excellent.
Also nochmal Rust spiele ich
jetzt nicht.
Man kann es ja echt übertreiben.
Meinung zu Skill-Based Matchmaking?
Offensichtlich.
Und
wie gesagt,
ich habe es ja am Anfang gesagt,
wenn ich mir
High-Kill-Gameplays auf YouTube angucke,
ich könnte wetten,
die sind Reverse-Boosted.
Nicht unbedingt von den Spielern selbst,
die haben ja mittlerweile Big Brain,
die sehen Sachen ja auch,
in den Statistiken sieht man das,
aber die machen dann quasi einen zweiten Account
und joinen sich.
Anders ist das
No-Hand-Gameplay der Gegner nicht mehr zu erklären
in dem Spiel.
Ich will nicht sagen alle,
ich kenne nicht alle
und ich bin jetzt aber selbst
auch nicht der überkrasse Owner
oder so,
aber es ist schon auffällig,
wenn ich sehe, wie jemand Warzone spielt,
die sich in der Mitte
von Trio-Modellen befindet.
Die sind alle komplett No-Brain,
No-Hand.
Alle, die komplette Runde.
Der spawnt im Warehouse quasi
und
und ownt Trios solo.
Ja, ist klar, ist klar.
Capture and defend the Hardpoint.
When it moves, you follow.
Oh, Hardpoint, bester Modus.
Ok, wie komme ich hier rüber?
In der Mitte geht eh keiner lang.
Die aimen alle wieder ab.
Was machst du da?
Ok.
What the fuck?
Du kannst hier nicht raus.
Jetzt haben wir ihn.
Der kommt jetzt, ey.
Hardpoint.
Ey, ich gehe da nicht rein, Leute.
Ich gehe da nicht rein in den Hardpoint.
Wenn ich in den Hardpoint reingehe,
sind sie drip.
Spawnen die auf der anderen Seite?
Fuck, warum renne ich
in die Granate rein?
Nichts dämlich.
Ok.
Ok, die gehen da hinten.
Da kommt bestimmt einer gleich hoch.
Ich muss erst mal nachladen.
War da einer?
Ey, überall, von allen Seiten.
Du kannst dich in diesem Spiel auf nichts verlassen.
Wow. Du kannst dich in diesem Spiel echt auf nichts verlassen.
Außer, dass gleich einer in deinem Arsch spawnt.
Wenn du nicht richtig drauf achtest.
Und wirklich, wortwörtlich.
Kappa Pride.
Der spawnt dir wirklich direkt hinten drinnen.
Wenn du nicht hinguckst.
Du kannst gar nicht alles checken.
Das geht nicht.
Wenn du alles checkst, bist du tot.
Ok, die kommen von hier nicht.
Wir sind hinten gespawnt.
Wo ist denn der Hardpoint? Ach, da.
Nice.
Ok.
Also, NA-Aim kann mir heute wirklich keiner vorwerfen.
Heute ist kein NA-Aim angesagt.
Die kommen jetzt eh von hinten.
Siehste, war klar.
Aber was willst du machen?
Wenn ich mich umdrehe, kommen sie von vorne.
Woah.
What the hell?
Ok, die sehen meinen Laser.
Das ist ziemliche Kack.
Ich wollte einfach nur Scoreboard checken.
Ah, jetzt gibts hier einen.
Die kommen jetzt hier um die Ecke.
Achtung. Bam.
Oder auch nicht.
Fuck.
Jetzt kommt gleich einer von links.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Sobald hier links frei ist,
dann gehen wir hier um die Ecke.
Oh, fuck.
Manchmal würde ich gerne die Killcam sehen,
wie er das geworfen hat.
Komm hoch.
W.
Alter, wie du hier in jeder Ecke gehittet wirst.
Komm raus.
Achtung.
Ok.
Wo ist denn der Hardpoint?
Ach, da hinten.
Da hinten im Spawn war der.
Wir müssen jetzt mal hinter.
Ey.
Du kannst nicht in alle...
Was geht ab? 31 Kills?
What the fuck?
Ich so nicht mal, dass es so schlecht gelaufen ist bei mir.
Was ist mit den Geg...
Ey.
Und immer guckst du den Fall durch.
Ja, ich hab das MMX300.
Oh, der ist hart.
Der ist hart.
Also der Hardpoint ist wirklich schwierig zu kriegen.
Okay, gehen wir mal hier oben durch.
Ne, der Flap...
Der geht doch hier bestimmt rum jetzt.
Oh, da kommt ein VTOL.
Der hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt.
Der hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt, der VTOL.
Alter, geh mal weg.
Da ist einer.
Weißt du, der VTOL ist down.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Das Pre-Jump da schon ist klar.
Teilweise die Gegner...
Ich sag doch, es ist das schwerste Spiel auf der Welt.
Ne, da gehen wir nicht lang.
Ne.
Wow, kriegt er auf den Sack.
Wie hat der Vion...
What the fuck?
What?
Was?
Was zum Teufel?
Verarschen?
Was war denn das, meine Freude?
Was zum Teufel?
Ach hier ist jetzt nix, oder was?
Jetzt bin ich hier rumgeflankt, aber nix da.
Ja, echt, ey.
WTF?
Ich komm mir verarscht vor von dem Game manchmal, ey.
Echt.
Ah, es zephiert.
Wow, was habe ich...
Ja!
43!
Was geht denn?
Ich glaube, das kannst du run and gun nicht machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Aber ich spiele eh zum Unlocken, also insofern.
Who cares?
Spawn-System ist im Alter.
Also, Multiplayer-technisch ist da noch deutlich mehr...
...noch deutlich mehr im Eimer als das.
Der kommt hier rum.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder doch?
Andere Seite.
Okay, wir...
Oh, nee!
Jetzt bin ich runtergefallen.
Kack-Noob.
Natürlich hinter.
Hinter einem.
Wo sonst?
Aber ich kenne keine Spiele mit so einem krass unpredictable...
...also...
...überhaupt...
What the hell?
Spawn-System.
Das gibt's ja.
Ah, da drüben ist was.
Du bist hier permanent paranoid in dem Spiel.
Hinter mir.
Hinter einem.
Übrigens, wir können gleich mal...
Perfekt, das...
Wir können gleich mal in den normalen Spielmodus spielen.
Da zeige ich euch mal, wie man hier abschimmeln muss, dass das funktioniert.
Der Mega-Abschimmler.
Das ist am Start.
Passt mal auf, Clay.
Gleich ist der Abschimmelmeister da.
Nämlich Silenced MP5.
Warum, Teammate?
Warum?
Ich wollte die Gegner...
Ich bin voll reingejumpt.
Oh, das war NAM.
Das war...
Das lasse ich mir jetzt gefallen als NAM, ja?
Guckt euch das mal an.
51!
Meine Güte!
Was zum...
Was ist da los?
51!
Äh.
Okay, da muss ja noch einer drin sein.
Oder auch nicht.
What?
Von hinten.
Alter.
Du siehst die Gegner nicht.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Aber ich glaube, MP7 haben wir gleich halbwegs frei gelöffelt.
Also ich weiß jetzt echt nicht...
What the...
Fuck, kann ich mal spawnen und 5 Meter geradeaus...
...laufen?
Geht das?
Ist das...
Ist das möglich?
Das ist ja, wenn man in mir steht, geht das.
Da war er.
Wir wurden defeated of doom.
Ja.
Wahnsinn, Alter.
Ähm.
Was gibt's eigentlich heute?
Über was wird denn heute geflamed?
Über was wird denn heute so geflamed?
Keckweggröße.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, wir gucken mal, was als nächstes für einen Spielmodus kommt.
Ich muss da glaube ich dann was anderes spielen, weil...
Hardcore Moshpit, das ist gerade echt zu viel.
Like good old days.
Mit dem Crossbow of Rust.
Das stimmt nicht.
Den Crossbow gab's in Modern Warfare 2 überhaupt nicht.
Kacknoobs.
Müssen wir ihre Facts straight kriegen.
Hardpoint Shipment.
Okay, Leute.
Wenn ihr gedacht habt, Rust geht nicht mehr schlimmer, dann wartet mal ab auf Shipment jetzt.
Old Reddit, New Reddit.
Das ist richtig.
Da hast du voll und ganz recht.
Das müssen wir auch gleich mal machen.
Okay, spielen wir weiter.
Der MP4-Frei.
Ja, MP4 ist hier gut.
Äh, nicht MP4.
Was laber ich?
MP7.
Das ist der Clusterfuck, Leute.
Passt auf, ey.
Es ist der absolute Wahnsinn, dieser Spielmodus.
Passt auf, passt auf.
Das ist krass.
What the...
What?
Shipment.
Shipment ist echt der absolute Wahnsinn.
Ja, das hat er schon abgeaimt.
Ist klar.
Ey, was hab ich für Gegner?
Die jumpen, die Breachotten dich schon fünf Kilometer.
Die...
Jetzt kommt er mit dem Breachotten.
Ich fass es nicht.
Jetzt schon.
Okay.
Guckt euch den Spawn an.
Habt ihr den Spawn gesehen?
Ey.
Was ist das denn?
Du spawnst und bist...
Na gut, es ist Shipment.
Es ist Shipment.
Also, wie gesagt, Shipment ist immer so.
Shipment.
What the fuck?
Guckt euch mal an.
Ein Spawn.
Ein...
What the fuck?
Shipment.
Ey, Shipment ist der Clusterfuck schlechte...
What the...
Ich kann jetzt ja nur hier stehenbleiben oder hinamen.
Shipment, Leute.
Okay.
Da steht einer in der Ecke.
Shipment.
Guckt euch die Gegner an, wie die uns zerstören.
Die fisten uns weg.
Enjoyable Gameplay.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Das ist absolut top.
Und ich frage mich, wer...
Oh.
Ich frage mich, wer auf die chronologische Idee gekommen ist.
Ja.
Wir müssen unbedingt Shipment remaken.
Shipment ist so eine tolle Map.
Vor allem mit diesem Spiel.
Die muss remaked werden.
Ja.
Top.
Guckt euch an.
Also, wenn das nicht Spaß macht, dann weiß ich...
Wenn das nicht Spaß macht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also, Leute.
Ihr habt keine...
Ihr habt schlicht und klar von Gaming keine Ahnung, wenn ihr nicht sehen könnt, wie das Spaß macht.
Ja.
Okay, da habe ich ein bisschen übererregt.
Das tut schon.
Das...
Also, ich finde, das ist...
Also, es ist offensichtlich, dass es Spaß macht, oder?
Also...
Shipment ist super.
Oh, der geht ab, ey.
Wenn du den nicht direkt hittest, bist du im Arsch.
Einfach random Nades.
Oh, was...
Fuck.
Alter, was habe ich denn da jetzt aufgenommen?
Übelste...
Übelste Crap-Waffe dafür.
Und der Typ, der sitzt einfach nur da.
Okay, ich sitze jetzt auch mal nur da.
Aber ich kann hier einfach nur da sitzen.
Kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich einfach nur da sitze?
Guckt hier.
Zack.
Aber, Leute.
Ihr habt wirklich keine Ahnung, wenn ihr das nicht...
Wenn ihr nicht seht, dass das Spaß macht.
Oder?
Also, die Kills habe ich jetzt eindeutig voll verdient.
So fail, Alter.
Der Modus.
Der Modus auf dieser Waffe.
Pass mal auf, für meines Tricks 17.
Nein.
Das ist so fail.
Das ist so krass fail.
Scheiße.
Da liegt er.
Okay, komm.
Holen wir mal jetzt mal die Rinetti raus.
Und Rinetti...
Oh, fuck.
Dein Ping ist hoch.
Echt?
31.
Oh, fuck.
Wieso?
Geht doch.
Gewinnen wir eigentlich...
Wow.
The fuck?
Fuck.
Gewinnen wir?
Nee.
Es ist geil.
Also zum Anlocken ist das wirklich gut.
Der Rest ist...
Der Rest ist einfach nur Cancer pur.
Hier übrigens, das ist die beste Camp-Posi.
Beste Camp-Posi auf Shipman.
Wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, euch zu bewegen,
macht es so.
Stellt euch hier hin.
Easy.
So, ja.
Zack.
Next.
Einfach stehen bleiben.
Und in eine Richtung gucken.
So.
Bestes Gameplay.
High-Octane-Gameplay.
Easy.
So.
So geht's.
Leute, so.
So und nicht anders.
So hat der Typ auch nach drei Sekunden seinen Wilson gekriegt.
Komm, noch besser ist übrigens, wenn man das sich hier aufstützt.
Einfach hier stehen bleiben, geradeaus gucken.
Fertig.
Äh.
Okay.
Und dann am ersten...
Doppelt Airstrike am gleichen ersten...
Alter!
Schippen!
Please!
Please, Schippen!
Geh vorbei!
Geh vorbei, Schippen!
Please!
Wow!
Ich spawne hinter den Gegnern.
Perfekt.
Ah, okay.
Er ist hinter mir gespawnt.
Sehr gut.
Moment, haben die einen Chopper?
Haben die jetzt einen Chopper am...
Oh, gut.
Nicer Spawn.
Einfach mal hier bleiben.
Easy.
Ich geh da nicht raus.
Ich geh...
Guckt es euch an.
Warum soll ich da rausgehen?
Ich werfe da vielleicht ein C4 raus, aber das war's.
Ja, easy.
Next.
Das ist so fail, Alter.
Was haben die sich gedacht bei...
Was haben die sich bei Infinity Ward gedacht?
Oh, ja.
Last Shipment Rebaken.
Oh, wir haben gewonnen.
Wie haben wir das gemacht?
Wie haben wir das gemacht, ja?
Okay.
Wir gucken die nächste Map und wenn nicht, muss ich was anderes spielen.
Ich muss was anderes spielen.
Wir können echt einen Solo Warzone spielen, aber wie gesagt, Solo Warzone ist ziemlicher Crap, finde ich.
Habe ich euch schon meine ultra nicen...
Ich wurde zur Hälfte gekämpft.
Ich habe auch einfach gedreht...
Warzone Stats gezeigt...
Ja, ne, was hier?
Wins.
Genau, guckt euch mal an.
Sechs Wins, elf Top Ten und das Ganze mit nur 91 Kills.
Und 36 Dounds.
Da zeichnet sich...
Cranked off...
Ne, ne, ne.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Wir probieren's nochmal.
Was hältst du vom Warzone Money Mode, hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Ohne Skill-Based Matchmaking.
macht jede zweite Runde Spaß mit
Skill-Based-Matchmaking macht jede zehnte Runde Spaß.
Ja.
Oder sag mal so, mit Skill-Based-Matchmaking macht fast
keine Runde so richtig Spaß.
Kennst du schon die App
Cellmapper? Ne.
Was, du mappst
Mobilfunkmasten? Ist das für die
5G
Hater?
Ja, was haben wir? Cranked.
Oh Gott, Cranked.
We've got enemy inbound. Lock and load.
Die Leute sind teilweise
zu krass.
Der Bree jumpt einen um die Ecke
und hittet.
Teilweise sind die echt zu krass.
Oh, das war ein Teammate.
Sehr gut.
Übrigens, ich hab den Chat aus Versehen ausgeblendet.
Ich muss den Chat mal wieder
einblenden. Oh, Moment.
Chat, ich seh euch nicht.
Der Q-Chat ist weg.
Wo ist denn der Typ?
Wo ist der denn hier oben?
Ei, ei.
Oh, nee.
Nee, nee. Ich hab genug Rust, Leute.
Ich hab genug Rust.
Das reicht mir.
Genug Rust.
Wie die Bree aimt um die Ecke
laufen, Alter.
Wie geht das denn?
Ich mein, woher wissen die das immer?
Ja gut, den hätte ich sehen können.
Aber was kommt nach dem Cranked-Time,
wenn man stirbt?
Wow.
Das hat ernsthaft nicht gereicht.
Okay, ich hab jetzt auch mal versucht,
krasse Pre-Shoot-Action zu machen.
Es hat auch ein bisschen funktioniert.
Oh, oh, oh.
Kack-Posi, Kack-Posi.
Hier kommt man nicht richtig raus, außer durch die Mitte.
Ich seh nix.
War da was?
Wow.
Tatsächlich.
Guck mal mal, die Ecke.
Der ist oben.
Achtung. Oh, ich wollt grad rauf-C4en.
Das wär nice gewesen, hätte ich den um-C4en um.
Ja, es gibt.
Der ist jetzt Cranked, aber auf Rust ist es halt...
Das ist halt Rust.
Und es ist...
Guckt's euch an.
Nee, ich hab keinen Bock auf dieses Rumgesitze, Alter.
Das ist mir grad zu anstrengend.
Ich würd ja gerne...
ähm...
Shoot-House spielen.
Das Problem ist, es gibt keine Shoot-House-Playlist.
Shoot-House ist die beste Map.
Der Rest ist...
weiß nicht, irgendwie doof.
Was ich auch ganz gerne spiel,
ist das da. Problem dabei ist, dass...
es gibt eigentlich kaum gescheite Maps.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hab ich das Richtige gesetzt?
Es gibt eigentlich kaum geschei... also...
Gut. Warum... Ich mein, es gibt in diesem Spiel
fast nicht an gescheiten Maps.
Egal in welchem Spiel, wo das ist, ja?
Äh... So, eigentlich wollte ich ja
gar keine MP7 leveln, sondern
das Ding hier.
Und so blöd's ist, ne?
Die...
Hardcore...
Die Hardcore-Playlist
ist echt die Beste.
Für Waffenleveln.
Leider.
Was richtig... Also, was ich ja echt feiern würde...
Die haben ja schon...
äh...
Wie man das spricht?
Crash.
Und noch irgendeine Map.
Oh ne, hier wird geschlichen.
Ich seh's schon, Leute. Oh, es wird Hardcore-gestelzt.
Es wird Hardcore-gestelzt.
Guckt's euch an, es wird Hardcore-gestelzt.
Das... Das...
Das ist ja noch... Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer.
Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer.
Wie... Wie in das andere Gerasche.
Hier wird Hardcore-gestelzt, ja.
Wow! Dodged.
Da ist er.
Okay. Wo... Wo kommen die jetzt?
Ich hab keinen Schimmer von der Map.
Und in jedem
Fenster sitzt einer.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Was ist das für ein Game? Das ist doch kein Call of Duty
mehr. Ernsthaft, Leute.
Das ist doch nicht... Das ist doch... Das ist doch lächerlich.
So ein krasses Rumgesitze, ey.
Meine Güle.
Wer... Wer hat sich bei Infinity Ward
gedacht? Ja.
Genau so wünschen sich die Leute Call of Duty.
So... So muss das sein. Das ist... So ist das gut.
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen.
Wenn ich hier rausgehe, Leute, dann bin
ich tot. Okay.
Okay, da hätte ich nicht repeaken sollen.
Aber es ist... Ah!
Und außerdem, wenn man in eine Runde
reingeworfen wird, ist auch dumm. Aber trotzdem.
Please.
Guck, eigentlich... Jetzt sind sie hinter
einem, ey. Nee, nee.
Die sind da multiplayer... Moment.
Leute. Ich wollte Sachen unlocken.
Fällt mir gerade ein. Warum spiel ich meine
gute... Meine gute Klasse?
Ich will sagen... Okay.
Wir haben... Wir sind in ein Scheißgame reingejoint.
Das ist quasi so wie
Insurgency. Ja, echt so.
Am besten geht
eigentlich immer noch...
Wir spielen das nochmal.
Das ist... Also...
Ich bin echt hin und her gerissen, welchen Spielmodus
ich am wenigst... Ich weiß, dass ich eine Hammer-Map
erwischt habe. Ich bin immer noch
hin und her gerissen, welchen Spielmodus
ich am wenigstens schlecht finde.
Das heißt schon was, ja.
Captain
Reflex spielt keiner.
Kill confirmed Hardpoint.
Am besten...
Also am meisten Spaß, wenn man eine halbwegs
gescheite Map hat, macht er eigentlich immer noch
Domination. Und das 10v10
finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Ähm...
Solange es eine gescheite Map gibt.
Das Problem ist halt, dass
80% der Maps ziemlicher Dreck sind.
Das ist halt doof, ja.
Und was ich auch nicht verstehe
ist...
Warum kann man
keine Maps voten? Ich meine,
wenn man 80%
Crap-Maps hat
und die könnten ja einfach eine Umfrage machen.
So, was sind eure Lieblings-Maps? Da kommt dann raus
Gunrunner, Shoothouse,
vielleicht Crash oder die alten
Remake-Maps oder so. Also, da gibt's
ja nicht so viele. So, und dann
könnte man sagen, okay, dann lassen wir doch
wenigstens die Leute...
Was war denn das nochmal für eine Map?
Dann, ähm, könnte man wenigstens sagen, okay,
dann lassen wir die Leute voten,
dass sie wenigstens die Maps spielen können, die sie wollen.
Oh, das ist
das Ding. Die Maps sagt übrigens,
dass auch... By the way, wer hätte
das gedacht, ne?
Okay, wir sitzen ein bisschen.
Huge.
Eine nice Camp-Simulation.
Ist da ein VTOL
oben?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Sehr gute, sehr gute Runde wieder.
Wonka, Achtung!
Tja, Kollege.
Huh!
So, wir müssen jetzt in diesem Haus sitzen bleiben, ne?
Weil das Camping, äh,
Camping-Warfare ist.
Man kann sich hier nicht einfach bewegen.
Was meint ihr denn? Was passiert, wenn ich mich hier bewege?
Wenn dir das klappt? Nee.
Ich muss hier sitzen bleiben.
Man muss hier
sitzen bleiben.
Wenn man hier nicht sitzen bleibt... Guck, easy!
Kaum campst du VTOL am Start.
Das ist so lächerlicher
Kram, ey.
So, bleib jetzt hier liegen.
Easy.
Bleib, bleib jetzt hier liegen. Zack.
Next.
Jetzt split.
Triple nuke.
So, easy.
Ich hab übrigens Hand vorne der Tastatur.
Bleib einfach nur hier liegen.
Bam, VTOL.
Gucken wir mal auf den Heartbeat-Sensor.
Da kommt...
Fuck.
Es ist so ein
lächerliches Campspiel.
Es ist so ein abgefucktes Campspiel.
Ah, ich leg mich jetzt hier in die Ecke.
Holen wir noch einen Chopper Gunner.
Es ist...
Jetzt sitzen sie natürlich alle drinnen.
Direkt hit. Direkt hit.
So ein Campspiel, Alter.
Ich lebe noch. Ich lebe noch.
Bleib ich hier liegen. Achtung, easy.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Ah, High-Octane-Gameplay.
So ist das gut, Leute.
Perfekt. Easy.
Das ist super gemütlich, ja?
Ah, Team-Mate.
Das ist ein Krampf, Alter.
Was ein Fail-Spiel, ey.
Der kommt gleich hier rein.
Ich sag's euch. Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
Oh, nee. Nee, der kommt oben.
Nee, der kommt unten.
Nein, nein. Max, nicht bewegen.
Nicht bewegen.
Wer nicht bewegt, ist direkt down wieder.
What's up?
Achtung, Achtung. Gleich der Nächste.
Gleich der Nächste.
Warum?
Warum kriegt man mit so einer bescheuerten Taktik
einen Chopper Gunner?
Warum?
Was ist das?
Das ist so Fail.
Es ist so Fail, das Spiel.
Ich lese sogar Chat nebenbei jetzt.
Nee, Krug, dankeschön.
Oh, Cruise-Missile.
Nee, Kollege, du erwischst mich auch
mit der Cruise-Missile nicht.
Okay, guck mal mal.
Ah, jetzt haben wir repeakt.
Wenn wir repeaken, sterben wir.
Wir campen einfach weiter, easy.
Easy, next!
Das ganze Game in dem Haus drin, perfekt, perfekt!
Ja, haha, du hast gedacht, du kannst mich von hinten flenken!
Zack, easy!
24-1 oder so!
Was für ein Campspiel!
1000 IQ, aber richtig!
Also ich würde sagen, also Leute, ohne Scheiß, ne, also für dieses absolute High-Octane,
High-Skill-Gameplay, könnte es ja schon mal ein paar Prime-Subs geben.
Das war ja nun wirklich absolut bleeding edge, never seen before, beste.
24-0, Leute, in your face, wo habt ihr das schon mal gesehen?
Fast, fast Nuke!
Es ist so, es ist so, ne, ich nehm das gar nicht auf, ich kann das gar nicht hochladen.
Okay, zumindest weiß ich schon, wo ich direkt quitten muss, je nach Map.
Gucken, was für eine Map gleich kommt.
Achso, Chat, ich wollte ja mal gucken, ob ich was übersehen hab.
Habe ich Subs übersehen?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ah, Sibaro für Leute, die wissen wollen, wie gut die Mobilfunkabdeckung ist.
Achso, verstehe.
Gut, ich hab auch nicht gedacht, dass es für die 5G-Verschwörer ist, aber man weiß ja
nicht.
Ich meine, ist ja logisch, ja, Corona kommt aus China und China hat gute 5G-Ausbau, dann
muss das ja logischerweise an 5G liegen, da sind wir uns ja mittlerweile einig, ist ja
allgemein bekannt.
Ähm, da hast du recht, Search and Destroy ist der Modus, der mir noch vom normalen Multiplayer
mit ein paar Leuten am meisten Spaß macht.
Die Map ist übrigens auch übelst reudig, ne, sag ich euch nochmal.
Okay, hier können wir vielleicht die MP7 freispielen.
Hier können wir vielleicht ein bisschen MP7 freispielen.
Bill Gates ist schuld, ne, Bill Gates finanziert bestimmt 5G-Masten in China.
Six Head.
Äh, was haben wir denn jetzt für einen Modus, was ist das?
Ah, Headquarters.
Headquarters.
Die sprechen das immer so geil aus, die, die, die, die Voice Actors.
Die sagen nicht Headquarters, Head, Headquarters.
Ups, äh, ja.
Hier.
Das ist der Inbegriff.
Das ist Modern Warfare Multiplayers.
Leute.
Wow.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Ah, knapp.
Ah, weil es Headquarters ist.
Ich kack nur.
What the hell?
Okay, ich weiß überhaupt nicht woher.
Der Ultra-Skiller.
Oh, das ist Headquarters, Leute.
Das wird spannend.
Kaum hat er sich bewegt, war er tot.
Richtig.
Das ist das Problem beim Multiplayer.
Naja, aber ich muss sagen, wenn man das Spiel zum Waffen leveln, geht das.
Übrigens, das Pro-Movement ist ja der hier.
Hmm.
Giga.
Wow.
Jetzt wäre es mal Hardcore gewesen.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Regt euch ab.
Dein ganzes Triad, geh schnell, ey.
Okay.
meine güte du musst dich ja permanent auf anschlag spielen dass das dass du
was auf die reihe kriegst
kommt hier achtung stets mod activated stets mod stets mod
jetzt warum sind da gerade alle auf einmal verreckt das war ziemlich ziemlich
knapp ziemlich close ok wo kommen die überhaupt ich leute ich habe ich habe
spot gefunden excellent wir können weiter sitzen
weitere weiterer schimmelspot gefunden jetzt kommen sie bestimmt von hinten
wie ist das bei headquarters gibt's
er ein sport auf jede jedes team hat nur ein sport oder wechselt das weil ich
habe echt paranoia in dem game dass du laufend von der seite geheimt wirst
laufen von der seite kriegst irgendwas ab da oben
da hätte ich mich öfters bei übrigens ich habe das ganze 3 auf ganze drei
kills schon geschafft hier immer mal das ist übrigens instant instant death hier
kann er das mal kann er mal sterben vielleicht
denke ich schon GOINGY
auch peak kollege peak
emas
wie soll man dieses spiel spielen okay very lauf ich denn jetzt
wie lauf ich okay oma vor kollegen willst erst erben exzellent
think action euch knten wo sind sie überhaupt
und peak kollege peak?
ok ich nehme mal mit ein entweder sterben oder gegner nicht finden wechsel
ok ich hab da irgendwas gesehen
ok hingeguckt seite weg jawohl
ich glaube der VTOL suckt hier oder wie lau... moment hier geht es gar nicht
fuck alter wie sind die laufwege auf der map... ach nee es ist mir hier oben
ich glaube ich spiele... ich bin... hab keine ahnung von den borders... ich glaube so macht man das nicht oder?
alter... der dude
wo sind denn die geishner
ok aus der hüfte so weit schießen kann man nicht
hat das ge... ja hat es hat es hat es hat nukes
ach hier ist... sind wir im headquarter drin? ok
ok wir machen jetzt big brain play
big brain play
haha was ist big brain play
irgendwie ist die waffe kacke wir probieren mal die andere aus dafür die muss ich eher unlocken
das ist eigentlich der grund warum ich den stream übrigens gestartet habe weil...
weil ich mir die waffe anlocken will
respawn ist able ok
ok wir schimmeln hier oben jetzt easy
easy up camp horn
aaah
richtig big brain ja
meine güte
ist das anstrengend
ich überlege mir gerade wie man headquarters spielt
oh äh das wollte ich gar nicht
by the way das da
steht man eher am headquarter rum
pusht man in die gegner flank
wie headquarters gespielt großartig
und vor allem wo um alles in der welt kommt auf der map hier irgendwas her
what
ok ich blicke
ich blicke legit nicht durch
ich blicke legit nicht durch grade
ok kann man hier irgendwie hoch
wo ist hier was? ich glaube ich bin da zu small brained für
ok die waffe ist aber ohne upgrades echt kacke
ah ich hab stims dann nehme ich mir keine stims
ok pushen wir mal rum hier ist nix mehr oder?
wo kommen die jetzt her? hier? ne hier? hier die seite
oder da? ich blick's nicht ok wir pushen hier anscheinend durch bis
es aussieht poggers
ahhh achtung easy easy easy easy ah ne die sind weiter gepusht
ich wusste dass du von hinten kommst kollegin so
nett
oh n8 richtig n8 habt ihr das gesehen?
pass auf pass auf der kommt hier gleich
nop nop nop nop ein wie toll
oh oh oh oh achtung achtung leute easy easy easy
ha shit ich dachte der wird jetzt wegreden
nettied aber habt ihr das gesehen?
habt ihr das wieder gesehen? was hat zum erfolg geführt?
was hat zum erfolg geführt?
ecken campen hat zum erfolg geführt
ok ich glaube so langsam krieg ich raus über den krams
hq? wo ist das überhaupt? ah hier jetzt ok
oh oh sieht übel aus wie tharkovman ja nur mit dem unterschied
oh oh oh sieht übel aus wie tharkovman ja nur mit dem unterschied
dass es eigentlich ein fast paced shooter immer war und aktuell ist da
irgendwie wenig fast paced.
Achtung! Wow wow wow! Guck mal, mein VTOL ist tot, oder?
Nee, der kommt gerade erst reingeflogen. Okay, ich glaube, das muss man mit dem
Hauptquartier anders machen. Man darf keine übelste Flank-Action machen und man darf
auch nicht direkt auf dem Hauptquartier stehen.
Man muss schauen, dass man irgendwie in der Nähe vom Hauptquartier rumstellt und
dann das übliche macht, wie man halt in Modern Warfare macht, die Sachen abamen.
Achtung!
Achtung, hier! Ach, das ist gar kein Gegner.
Hier! Nice Camp-Action! Easy! Jawoll! Next! Das ist ja ein tolles Spiel!
Oh, wie toll!
Oh, HQ! Nee, Moment, dann gehen wir am besten hier rüber, oder?
Die schnellsten sind wir hier oben durch.
Okay.
Okay, hier ist doch bestimmt irgendwas.
Was?
Zum Geier, ey! Immer aus der anderen Richtung!
Okay, machen wir mal das hier. Mehr, mehr Muni.
Und jetzt habe ich echt keine Ahnung, welche Richtung ich gucken muss. Hier?
Oh, da kommt was.
Ich finde es krass, wie die schon immer abamen, alles.
Na gut, ich habe Repeek. Repeeken ist der Tod in dem Spiel. Das wirst du, muss man sich echt merken.
Repeeken ist der Tod. Wenn die dich schon aimen, ist vorbei.
Oder so.
Aber danach haben wir schöne Aufsätze unlocked.
Wow!
Achtung, Achtung!
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, wo hier was abgeht.
Hier, Head, Head-Glitch.
Head, Head-Glitch. Head-Glitch. Beste.
Head-Glitch-Posi.
Beste Head-Glitch-Posi.
Hier, stehen bleiben. Stehen bleiben.
Oh, nee!
Jetzt spawnen sie auf der anderen Seite.
Spielmodus Small-Brain habe ich dafür. Zu, zu, zu Small-Brain.
Du bist überall abgeaimt, ey.
Wie toll in einer Halle ist High-IQ, ja.
What?
Was zum?
Wo muss man hier schauen?
Ah, nee.
Okay, wir bleiben jetzt mal hier oben sitzen und gucken mal, ob wir irgendwie...
Spielt, by the way, spielt die Waffe jemand im Multiplayer?
Was ist denn da gut des Setups?
Ich wollte den nämlich mal anlocken, weil ich habe irgendein Video gesehen mit einem Loadout-Vorschlag.
Das sah mega nice aus.
Ja, easy.
Oh, zum Klüge ist der Kram vorbei, ey.
Zum Klüge ist der Kram vorbei.
So.
Also, ich wollte ja gucken, wo geflammt wird.
Um die Grau.
Man kriegt den OP-Lauf erst ab 35, das ist kein Problem.
Ich kann Waffen-XP boosten.
Mein aktuelles Setup ist M4 und Renetti und M4 mit dem Monolithic-Suppressor, dem...
Ich kann immer grad reingucken.
Äh, das da.
Monolithic-Suppressor, weil der als einziges Sound-Suppression und Damage-Range hat, was eigentlich ziemlich cool ist.
Und der Rest ist nicht so, nicht so entscheidend.
Den Stock, weil Velocity...
Dann den Laser, weil warum nicht.
Ja.
Besser.
Aiming-Stability ist nie verkehrt.
ADS-Speed-Shot auch nicht.
60 Schuss, weil...
Spray...
Oh, Alter! Der Tainser!
WTF, huge subscription.
Excellent.
Dankeschön.
High-IQ-Subscription.
Ähm...
Und unten drunter hier den Kommando-Grip für...
Besseres Aiming.
Spielt sich eigentlich echt nice.
Habt ihr doch gerade gesehen, wie gut das Setup ist.
24-0 Chopper-Gunner.
Easy.
Bestes Setup, um auf der Treppe zu liegen.
Oh Mist, ich hab vergessen, den XP-Boost zu machen.
Nein.
Oh, wieder die Sucker-Map, Leute.
Wieder die Sucker-Map.
Sucker-Bus.
Sucker-Map.
Ne.
Ne, das machen wir nicht nochmal.
Ich meine so nice ein absolut braindead 24-0 Chopper-Gunner ist, aber das kann ich nichter Canadians machen.
Aber was auch ein ganz gute Pose ist, die ich gesehen habe, wenn ich jetzt hier überlebe durchzukommen, ist hier oben drin.
Ist hier oben drin.
Hier ist auch ganz nice, hier kann man nämlich auch schön gletschen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist klar, ist klar.
Und danach spielen wir echt mal eine Runde Warzone-Solos.
Und können mich
abscheißend sehen in den Solos.
Okay, wir
sliden jetzt hier mal rein.
Wow! Monka!
Oh, wir sind
wieder in unserem Lieblingshaus gelandet.
Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wir sind wieder in unserem Lieblingshaus.
Es ist, ja,
es ist da immer, es ist, es ist, es ist.
Ah, shit.
Ich finde, es ist toll, dass das Game
immersive sein soll. Oh ja,
Immersive Camp Simulator ist es.
Wow!
Okay, ich weiß gar nicht, woher.
Der Immersive,
der Immersive, ich sitze im Fenster und gucke aus dem Fenster
und bewege mich in den Simulator, ist das.
Ey, meine, what the fuck, Alter?
Oh, ist ja gar nicht,
wo du hin sollst.
Was richtig
nice wäre, wenn die eine Playlist
machen mit den
beliebtesten fünf Maps.
Dann könnte man das halbwegs spielen, glaube ich.
Ich, Alter, da oben ist er.
Achtung, mal
mal Hardbeat rausstellen.
So ein Gesitze, Alter, so ein Gesitze.
Okay, flanken wir mal
rechts rum.
Okay, links, rechts, rechts, links.
Oben, unten, wo ist da was?
Man weiß es nicht.
Die Maps sind, sind, du musst, du hast
30 Milliarden mal mehr Winkel als auf CS,
Maps.
Oh, guck mal, da kommt ein Loadout.
Easy, lull.
Mal kurz hier einen abcampen,
ob der da vorbeiläuft.
Oh, nee.
Oh, fuck, da kommen drei Spiele an den Gegner.
Pff, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wie da einfach fünf Gegner vor der Tür
gestanden haben.
Hätte ich mal, hätte ich mal zwei, zwei Sekunden
mit, mit dem C4 gewartet.
Ey.
Wo bin ich denn überhaupt hier?
Ey, du siehst, du siehst hier auch
nix. Guckt's euch mal an.
Ey, man,
what the fuck, Alter?
Okay,
stelzen wir mal den Hardbeat-Sensor.
Ist nix.
Hardbeat-Sensor nochmal stelzen.
Wieder nix.
Okay, Leute,
wir müssen jetzt hier sitzen bleiben, kurz.
Wir müssen kurz hier sitzen bleiben.
Die, die sind ja
hier vorne.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, mein Teammate
pusht dann.
Das ist wie gut das
gehen kann, wenn man weiß, wo die Gegner sind.
Okay, YOLO.
Wow.
Ja, ja, leg dich ab.
Pff, habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich, by the way, nicht.
Oh, ein
Wilson.
Ah, ich bin geflasht.
Checkt.
Ich konnte die Maus
immer bewegen.
Lol, keckt.
W.
Gibt es... Oh, oh.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Achtung.
Bam.
Kack-Noobs.
Endlich mal wieder ein paar Bobs, ey.
Die gebasht werden wollen.
Guckt sie euch an.
Oh. Ah, natürlich.
Von hinten. Von wo sonst?
Mr. Whip, du kannst die Maus nicht schneller
bewegen, wenn du geflasht bist.
Äh, wenn du gestunt bist, nicht wenn du geflasht bist.
Oh, sehr fairer Spawn.
Sehr fairer Spawn-Spiel.
Excellent Spawn.
Direkt hinter dem Gegner.
Sehr fair.
Okay, guck mal mal an die Ecke.
Ah, ne, ja.
Das ist...
Sag mal, geht euch das auch so?
Es achtet keiner auf den Laser.
Das steht zwar so fest da.
Achtung, der Laser, ähm...
Die Gegner sehen den Laser.
Aber keiner interessiert sich für den Laser.
Sind unter mir Gegner?
Sind das Teammates?
Okay, man sieht nix.
Okay, wir pushen mal links rum.
Aber da werden wir wahrscheinlich gebasht jetzt.
Okay.
Heartbeat sagt nix da.
Nächster Heartbeat sagt auch nix da.
Okay.
Ja!
Ja, erst mal Tür zumachen.
What?
Shotgun!
Ah!
Alter!
Er hat eine halbe Stunde geflankt, um die Gegner gute Pose gehabt und dann erst mal
geshotgunnt werden.
So ist das ja geil.
Hi!
Aber echt, Leute!
Echt, äh!
Hi!
Alas, da kann ich's mir nicht erklären.
Okay, wir machen das gleiche nochmal.
Heartbeat-Sensor stellt's.
Nix da.
Okay.
Easy.
Am Fenster ist einer.
Ich hab's aber schießen gehört.
Oder auch nicht?
Okay, wir beeilen uns.
Die Map ist hier hinten so groß wie Komi-Bad.
Die Map ist hinten so groß wie Komi-Blackops.
Eins-Maps insgesammt.
Meine Fuck!
Ach, Tür zu!
Okay.
Modern-Camp-Fair aber hart, hart.
Echt hart.
Okay, jetzt ist hier natürlich nix mehr.
Okay, dann gehen wir raus.
Nehmen wir unsere komische Route wieder auf der rechten Seite.
Und dann gehen wir raus.
der rechten seite von rechts könnte ja was kommen jetzt eigentlich oder da oben
wo sind denn überhaupt gegner was ist für den riesen
ok habe ich feine kill habe ich feine kill ach du hast bin ich mal gespannt
feine kill so richtig schön am slide kein feine kill
time limit erreicht ja überlegt euch mal ein kill confirmed was das time limit
erreicht das ist wirklich ich meine es muss ihnen noch aufgefallen sein dass es
irgendwie nicht zu der normale spielfluss ist wenn kill
confirmed kommt dann kommt es wieder und das ist ja schon ein bisschen
geformt nach zehn minuten keine 75 punkte hat oder
und hat sie hat sich dabei bei infinity ward na gut
infinity ward und blizzard also activision und blizzard die sind ja mittlerweile sind die ja relativ dicke
und blizzard hat ja quasi vorgemacht wie verkacken man es kann mit maps in overwatch
und da hat sich infinity ward gedacht ey blizzard map designer zeigt uns doch mal wie es geht
alter tainzer hast du zu viel geld
was ist mit dir los
zehn stück dankeschön huge sub wer hat denn was gekriegt hier
das ist ja schon hier hyper hyper subscriber
big brain
wer hat was gekriegt
grinders keepers karl virux
oder viro wahrscheinlich weil das ja französisch ist
was spielen wir denn eigentlich für ne map
och ne chovy da
please nicht nicht noch mal
ähm
captain peng
re5 ads
sola von astora
das totale trivau manuel98
rob lm agent starmac
ja dankeschön für die ganzen subs
krasser shit
massive
um nicht zu sagen
hoggers
oh oh oh
was hat mich da ja ist gut
hm
warum steht da hinten einer
was soll das
chat habt ihr dem erlaubt da zu stehen
ich finde der sollte instant geblockt werden
instant ban
was er da gestanden hat
achto
fuck wir hatten die gleiche idee
wir hatten die gleiche idee
aber er war noch hinter nem fals
hahaha
ä 다
Moment, Moment, wo sind wir überhaupt?
Ah, Camp House, perfekt.
Gegner, wo sind die Gegner?
Warum ist das so ein komisch, merkwürdiges Game, wo man nie weiß, wo was ist?
Und meistens sind sie hinter einem.
Ah, Moment, spielen wir...
Ach, wir spielen Headquarter.
Das muss einem ja auch mal einer sagen.
Das muss einem ja auch mal einer sagen, dass wir Headquarter spielen.
Okay, alle Gegner tot.
Wo spawnen die denn jetzt?
Hier hinten?
Get rekt, oh fuck.
Was ein Kackspiel, aber echt.
Also der Multiplayer ist wirklich mega sackig.
Wo kommt man eigentlich hier lang?
Ich war ja noch nicht in jedem Haus auf der Map, das muss ich jetzt hier gerade mal angucken, wie das geht.
Was sind...
Was zum Teufel, wo sind wir denn hier?
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Wow.
Sind wir im Gegnerspawn oder sowas?
Äh, House Layout.
Hier ist auch noch mal eine riesengroße Map.
Yeah, Carl.
Im Multiplayer, deswegen spiele ich ja Multiplayer.
Weil man schnell die Waffen levelt.
Du musst ein bisschen was killen, aber...
Was sich gerade als sehr schwierig rausstellt.
Weil ich nicht weit...
Hä?
So geht's.
Kann man hier aufs Dach irgendwie...
Ich hab dich gesehen, Kollege.
So nicht, so nicht.
Also sollte...
What the hell?
Sollte Headquarters dazu führen, dass man halbwegs predictable spawns kriegt...
Dann werde ich auch ein bisschen mehr Headquarters spielen.
Weil das ist ja das Schlimmste an dem Modus.
Oder beziehungsweise an dem Spiel, dass du bei den Spawns echt permanent denkst, es ist einer hinter dir.
Zwölf Kills.
Wo hat er die denn her?
Fake News.
Ey, ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft?
Also, was ist mit dir verkehrt?
Erstens, was ist das für ein scheiß Waffensetup?
Und zweitens, was machst du da?
Oh Gott.
Meine Güte.
Okay.
Flankerino, Flankerino.
Warum pre-naten die mich da schon?
Kann man hier außen rumflanken oder so?
Jaja.
Ja, das war kein Headshot.
Natürlich nicht.
Hehe.
Lul.
Achtung.
Heartbeat.
Okay, der hat das volle Ghost-Layout, Leute.
Der hat's volle Ghost-Taktik, hat er.
Der hat die Call-Platte-Ghost-Taktik gehabt, der Typ.
Volle Pulle.
Irgendwie bringen die Flank-Routen auch gar nichts.
Moment, das nächste HQ ist da hinten.
Das heißt, die Gegner kommen jetzt hier?
Nee.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ich muss aufhören, ich muss aufhören, das Game zu verändern.
Ich muss versuchen, zu verstehen.
Okay.
Okay, ich geh jetzt hier oben hin.
Die müssen jetzt hier gleich reinpushen.
Und dann gehen wir ans Fenster und bashen sie.
Genau.
Kommen die links?
Ah, genau.
Wo war der jetzt?
Ja, der piekt das richtige Fenster.
War das ein Glück?
Er piekt das richtige Fenster.
Ey, ich krieg Anfälle.
Okay.
Ach, Chat.
Hättest du mal die Waffe freigeschaltet, schon alles.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Wisst ihr, was der Nachteil ist, wenn man so viel spielt in den letzten Tagen?
Ich bin jetzt ja nicht mehr gewillt.
Mir tun meine Ellenbogen weh.
Weil die auf der Armauflage die ganze Zeit hin und her geschoben werden.
Ja.
Wirst du abgeaimt hier.
Bin ich überhaupt nicht mehr gewohnt?
Jetzt passieren da Zugespotten.
Aldo, YOLO.
C4.
Okay, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wo die sind.
Ich hab echt keinen Plan.
Absolut keinen.
Kein Schimmer.
Okay, links sind sie anscheinend.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay, YOLO Sprint.
Jaaaah.
Oh, hier, sieben.
Gut.
Aber guckt euch mal an.
Ich bin die ganze Runde rumgelaufen.
Nur rumgelaufen.
Hab keine Gegner gefunden.
Und der Höchste hat 15.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt ist die ganze Runde über wieder nichts passiert.
Gar nichts.
Du hast dir für deinen Ellenbogen extra Polster geholt.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Typ hier los gerade?
Willst du dich nicht vorwärts bewegen?
Denkst du, wir müssen zu Anfang da rein?
Gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gemacht hast.
Okay?
Ich weiß nicht.
Da ist der beste Rat.
Ach du Hasch?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gemacht hast.
Hör mal kurz auf.
Ja, komm her.
Los, komm her.
Mich Higher.
Das ist wichtig.
Wir müssen das machen.
Ganz schön nett.
Ja.
Was ist das für ein Spiel?
vertrag, oder?
Warte mal.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist das für ein Spiel?
Das ist ein bisschen wie Spiele.
Was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Spiel?
oder so, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wo sie herkommen.
Komm, wir gehen erst mal hier gucken.
Am Mitte ist immer schwierig. Mitte
sackt immer. Das war schon immer so.
Das war ein Gegner.
Shit.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen, dass es ein Gegner war.
Keck W.
Hat er mich hier
gemailt, hat er mich.
Achtung hier.
Ja.
Die Map macht mich echt fettig.
Ich gehe jetzt in unser Camperhaus.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Camperhaus.
Ja, oder so.
Ich.
Oh ne.
Moment, Moment.
Reck.
Ha, turn on.
In your face.
Jetzt spielen wir auch.
Jetzt spielen wir mal richtig eklig, ey.
Jetzt spielen wir mal richtig
eklig.
Jetzt spielen wir mal richtig eklig.
Fuck.
Der hat es gecheckt.
Du bist die erste Person, die ich multipläne mit Herzschlag-Sensor.
Das liegt daran, weil das mein
Warzone-Loadout ist, was ich gerade drin habe.
Normalerweise ist der Herzschlag-Sensor
im Multiplayer ziemlich errotzt.
Oh ja.
Achtung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich aimen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Hier neben, wo ich
geschimmelt habe gerade, soll ich da wieder hin?
Okay.
Okay, jetzt sterben wir gleich, weil wir hier durchflanken.
Nachladen.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gehen wir mal.
Achtung, Achtung.
Wie kommt man hier?
Ah, der Typ.
What?
Der ist hier aber gut ausgerüstet, ey.
Ah, der ist tot.
Okay, Leute.
Easy, easy mode.
Achtung, ich zeige euch easy mode auf der Map.
Okay.
Easy, easy mode.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist Headquarters, da bringt das ja gar nichts.
Das ist ja Headquarters.
Okay, wir aimen jetzt jetzt einfach
drei Stunden ab, bis da irgendwas kommt.
Drei Stunden ab-aimen, bis irgendwas kommt.
Und wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe,
oh, da unten war noch einer, habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich darf hier nicht repeaken.
Wenn ich den repeake, ist rip.
Durch die Wand.
Geball-Bang, so was.
Oh.
Ja, ja.
Regt dich ab.
Die Zeit ist fast fertig.
Guckt euch mal an.
Mein Gott, ist das fail.
Wow, wow, wow.
Was zum...
Wer hat den gekillt?
Äh, okay.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an.
Die Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Was ist das?
Das ist ja viel viel vaker'der für eine map, oder?
So was, hätte es früher nicht gegeben.
Nein, hätte es auch nicht.
Oh, wow, Poggas, alter.
POG.
Huge.
Das ware leis.
Das ware nice.
Das ware cool.
Okay, schauen wir mal, was die nächste Map ist.
Ah, Leute.
Leute, dafür Mist.
Jetzt habe ich es verkackt.
Wisst ihr, was ich eben hätte einspielen können?
Oh mein Gott!
Der hätte gut gepasst.
Get the camera.
So, mal schauen, ob wir Rage quitten müssen, je nach Map.
Sommel, Sommel, was zum Teufel?
Was war noch mal Sommel?
Ach, die.
Ja, die Map sieht fast genauso aus wie die hier.
Nur, dass eine Windmühle in der Mitte ist.
Die Maps wirken eh alle ziemlich copy-pasted.
Mit der Krönung, die Krönung mit der Warzone-Map.
Die ist hier komplett copy-pasted.
Dafür ist Warzone der beste Spielmodus.
Alles andere hältst du auf Dauer nicht aus.
Oh, guck mal, Sabrina ist am Start.
Bestimmt ein hottes Gamer-Grill.
Ja, genau, die ist das.
Guck, die sieht genau aus wie die andere Map, bloß mit einer komischen Windmühle.
So, was spielt man da jetzt?
Eigentlich müsste ich ja Waffen anbieten.
Aber irgendwie, weiß nicht, irgendwie hätte ich dann doch mal ganz gerne halbwegs gute Gameplay.
Das ist schwierig, schwierig, ja.
No joke, das Physik-Grill hieß Sabrina.
Sebaro, vielleicht habt ihr ja Gesprächsstoff.
Okay, wir campen jetzt hier ab.
Wir campen jetzt die Ecke ab hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die von hier kommen, aber was...
Wie, das war kein Kill für mich?
Okay, Moin, Moin, Moin.
Nicht so offensiv, dass es ein sinnlos ist.
Wir sitzen rum, campen.
Hallo?
Camp-Game?
Dementsprechend müssen wir der Sache auch Rechnung tragen.
Und schön sitzen.
Schön schimmeln, schön schimmeln.
So muss das sein, ja.
Schöne Schimmel-Action.
Hoggers.
Ah, shit.
Ver-aimt.
Voll verkackt.
War gerade dabei, die Maus zu resetten, in der Mitte kommt noch die Ecke.
Schön sitzen.
Erst mal hier, Renettis raus.
Haha, da macht sie nix, Alter, da macht sie nix.
Wow!
Achtung, C4-Action.
Bam.
Okay.
Oh, ist das ein Shotgun, Mensch?
Krieg ich heute noch mal Kills oder krieg ich nur Assists?
Okay, das war scheiße gamed.
Ja, ist gut.
Geb ich zu.
So, der denkt jetzt, ich peak links.
Der denkt, ich peak links.
Aber ich peak links.
Aber ich peak rechts.
Und der denkt auch, ich peak links.
Aber jetzt peak ich links.
Big Brain, Outplayed.
Das ist der Leute.
Alter, was ist das für ein Flitzer?
Das kommt mir vor wie so ein nackiger Typ auf dem Fußballfeld.
Was ist mit dem los gewesen?
Kann man eigentlich?
Ah, excellent.
Okay.
Wir haben uns viel zu viel bewegt.
Wir müssen in unsere Schimmelposition übergehen.
Das geht aber gerade nicht.
Okay, hier ist es auch gut.
Auch excellent Schimmelposition.
Excellent Schimm...
Oder auch nicht.
Wow.
Ah.
Nicht geguckt.
Tainser, du hast echt so viel Geld.
Dein Schiff für die 100 Cent.
Für den Euro quasi.
Das sind ja eine Million nordkoreanische Wonnen.
Haben wir letztens gelernt.
Boah, was ein Timing.
Und wie hat der Erste schon wieder 13 Kills?
Es sind 100 Cent.
Ungefähr.
Das kommt ziemlich genau hin.
Okay, Schimmelposition.
Eingenommen.
Nein, das bin ich.
Ey, ich habe meine gute Position doch jetzt hier.
Nee.
Meine Güte.
Wir können MP7 hier freispielen, oder?
Wenn wir da close reinkommen.
Aber da kommen wir nicht close rein.
Erschreck mich nicht, du.
Ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft hinter mir?
Guck mal, da ist Sabrina.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, was Sabrina macht.
What the hell?
Da stirbt keiner, hä?
An der Ecke.
Ja, jetzt stehen sie alle da.
Ich hätte gerne Kills.
Please.
Gebt mir mal ein paar Kills.
Wie toll am Start.
Warte mal, wann kommt man an eine gute Map?
Oh, nee.
Voll verschissen.
Okay, hier aimen wir jetzt mal.
Hier kommt bestimmt einer.
Hier kommt garantiert einer.
Wir legen uns mal auf.
Wir machen den richtigen Schimmelmodus jetzt.
Genau die Ecke.
Ah, okay.
Da war Glück, dass er so nah dran war.
Ey, what the fuck?
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Jetzt können wir Waffen anlocken.
Wir kriegen gerade eh nur auf den Sack.
Dann können wir Waffen anlocken.
Wow.
Warum ist ein Gegner hinter mir?
Okay, wenigstens geht der erste Typ ab.
Kann man...
Ah, ah.
Call of Duty Logik.
Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Okay, kann man hier lang pushen?
Was ist nächstes?
Wie riesig ist die Map?
Oh, oh, oh.
Fuck, Alter.
Wie riesig die Map ist.
Hätte schon mal besser getroffen, ne?
Okay.
Ja, was machen wir denn da jetzt?
Die andere anlocken?
Irgendwie geht da gerade nichts.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Coole ist?
Mich nervt das gar nicht mehr so.
Weil ich kann Waffen anlocken.
So blöd es klingt.
Schönen Schimmel dann eh.
So, so geht das.
Excellent.
So, und jetzt können wir da nicht lang gehen,
weil dann raufen wir voll in das Aim
von den Gegnern rein.
Okay, der flankt.
Oder auch nicht.
Wow, doch.
Ja, von beiden Seiten.
Man sieht, wer sich bewegt, verliert.
Und die kriegen richtig auf den Sack,
die Runde gerade.
Wobei ich ehrlich bin,
ich weiß nicht,
ob ich eine große Hand nicht anders spielen soll.
Außer vielleicht
die ein oder anderen Sachen mehr treffen.
Wow, wow, wow.
NA, NA Aimed.
Alter, wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Ich bin mit meiner Maus gar nicht hinterher gekommen.
Beweg, ey.
Das war richtiges Controller Aim, ja?
Aber krass, Alter.
Wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Ey.
Sag mal, laggt's? Kann das sein, dass ich gerade ein bisschen laggen muss?
Ey, das ist schon wieder,
seht ihr das?
Es ist schon wieder Time Limit.
Der Modus suckt.
Müssen wir was anderes spielen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Hm.
Was geben wir uns denn mal?
Wollen wir mal ein Gun Game spielen?
Hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Aber, nee, Kill Confirmed ist zum größten Teil
hier auch ziemlich blöd.
Ich hätte gerne eine Playlist,
wo ich die Maps auswählen kann.
Ähm.
Das hab ich am Anfang gespielt, da bin ich aber
durchgedreht bei.
Also ich hab ja schon die M4,
die Renettis und zur Hälfte die MP7
gelevelt
auf, ähm,
Dirty Old Boat mit
Hardcore, in Hardcore.
Dann wirst du blöd
im Kopf mit der Zeit. Ich wollte jetzt mal was anderes spielen.
Zwischendurch.
Was hab ich denn eigentlich für eine KD?
Wo sieht man das denn?
Records. Multiplayer.
Wins. Nee.
Kills.
Aber das ist normal
in dem Game.
Ohne Scheiß. Über 1.5 geht nicht.
Und ich spiel ja auch
gar nicht drauf. Aber trotzdem.
Man könnte, glaube ich, eine 2er vielleicht hinkriegen.
Aber nur,
wenn man wirklich Hardcore tryhardet.
Oh, nee. Nee.
Nee. Jetzt nicht, Leute.
Nee. Das ist die schlimmste Map.
Das ist wirklich die schlimmste Map.
So, mal gucken,
wie Gun Game ist.
Ich muss gleich mal aufs Klo.
Ähm, by the way,
wie wär's eigentlich mal mit...
Gun Game ist richtig dumm.
Warum spiel ich Gun Game?
Ich will Waffen freischalten.
Eigentlich Massive, Massive,
Pepega. Dergo Live.
3 Monate, dankeschön. Gibt's noch Free for All?
Ja. Aber Free for All ist auch
Kacke in dem Spiel.
Es gibt nur so ein paar Modi, die
weniger schlimm sind.
Okay, mal gucken, wie Gun Game ist.
Ich hab noch kein einziges Gun Game
gespielt.
Ähm, wobei, stimmt nicht.
Chat.
Ich hab Mist erzählt. Ich hab schon mal Gun Game gespielt.
Okay, mit was für ner Waffe fängt
man an? Ist das Burst?
Nee, das ist Singleschuss.
Wow, ich dachte,
da sind Gegner.
Was ist das? Shotgun!
Das ist ne Shotgun, a fucking Shotgun.
Ich hab ne Shotgun.
Wie soll das damit jetzt funktion...
Okay, den Shotgunnen wir.
Na klar.
Wir schießen beide mit der kleinen Shotgun auf Lande.
Bäm, ich sterbe natürlich.
Fuck. Okay, was haben wir denn jetzt?
Was ist das?
MP5.
Und das ist...
Ist das ne Burstwaffe?
Ich blick's nicht.
What the fuck ist denn das für Waffen?
Okay, der kommt jetzt von hinten gleich.
Oder auch nicht.
Was Waffen?
Was ist das?
Irgendwas mit Thermal?
Thermal Poggers?
Was? Was?
Das war nicht drauf
gerade?
Ach, das ist ne Shotgun.
Oder?
Was ist das für ne Waffe gewesen?
Das ist... Das ist ne Granatwerfer, oder?
Ich kenn die Waffen nicht.
Ey.
Was für Dinger? Ich blick neulich durch.
Übelst lost, Alter. Übelst lost.
Aber das jetzt.
Das ist jetzt ne Raketenwerfer.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich hab geschossen.
Losgelassen oder hat gegen die Wand geknackt.
Ah.
Was ein Modus.
Uiuiui.
Guck mal, wir sind gar nicht so schlecht.
Seht ihr das?
Und warum hat der Feuer an seiner Shotgun?
Hä?
Okay.
Und das ist...
Das ist ne...
Sub-Machine-Gun?
Ja, kein Headshot. Aber das ist ne Sub-Machine-Gun.
Okay, das schau mal gut.
Und das... Was ist das?
Ah.
Unten rechts... Ah, das ist ne Assault Rifle.
Okay, ich muss sagen...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen macht das sogar halbwegs Spaß.
Wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat an die Waffenrotation, ist das glaube ich ganz nice.
Aber das können wir nicht spielen.
Weil...
Man muss sich das angucken, oder wie?
Weil ich will Waffen anlocken.
Leute, wollen wir noch ein Gun-Game spielen und dann Waffen anlocken?
Irgendwie macht das Bock.
Zumal ich... Ich kenne ja 90% der Waffen in dem Spiel gar nicht.
Komm, eins. Eins.
Komm, eins. Eins. Ein Gun-Game spielen wir noch.
Mal schauen wie die Map...
Welche Map kommt.
So, und danach machen wir...
Weapon...
XP rein.
Und dann müssen wir leider, leider...
wieder in die...
wieder in die... in die schlimme Playlist.
Hast du schon ne GPU
mit NV-ENG?
Was, der Stream verpixelt
bei schnellen Bewegungen?
Was? Ernsthaft?
Das Ding hat 8,9 MBit oder so.
Da sollte eigentlich nichts passieren.
Ja, ich habe eine mit NV-ENG. Ja, ich mache aber
CPU-Encoding. Aber das sollte...
Das sollte doch nichts ver...
Wow.
Was ist denn das für ne
Dreckswaffe?
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Warum schießt die nicht, wenn man triggert?
Verpixelt?
Chat, verpixelt ist wirklich hart?
Ich muss mir das gleich mal
selbst angucken.
Okay.
Krasser Hardscope.
Hardscope.
Oh, in den Bauch geschossen.
Reicht nicht.
Ach, das ist ne Autosniper.
Okay, was auch immer.
Was auch immer, ey.
Warum leuchte ich jetzt grün?
Das ist... Ist das ne Sniper?
Alter, was für ne Sniper? What the fuck?
Okay, ich kenn
die Waffen nicht. Das ist scheiße.
What?
Das ist aber Fail, dass das kein Kill war.
Wow, wow, wow.
Fuck, warum hab ich den Melee gedrückt,
Alter?
Oh, Launcher.
Leute, es wird gelauncht.
Ah, shit.
Oh, wie ist der dritte? Poggers.
Poggers.
Die Schritte kamen doch eindeutig
von hinten.
WTF?
Hallo?
Ich hab links geklickt.
Der hat nicht geschossen.
Oh, der wollte mich messern. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Der Messer-Dude.
Oh, nee. Was? Victory?
Ah, nee. Ich bin dritter geworden.
Okay. Ah, man kann nicht leaven.
Ich will raus.
Comstar, ja.
Die Maps sind echt nicht nice.
Okay, wir müssen wieder in die schlimme Playlist rein.
Presk, jetzt sieht's
Wisp aus. Ja, muss so sein.
Ne, was heißt Rage-Quitter?
Ich will mir nicht den Kram angucken.
Warum soll ich jetzt 30 Sekunden rumsitzen und nichts machen?
Wozu?
So, Leute, wir müssen leider, leider müssen wir wieder.
Komm, wir können auch mal die Normale spielen.
Aber ich sag euch, die ist nicht besser.
Die ist nicht besser.
Okay.
Weapon Tokens. Zack.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Jetzt gibt's wenigstens XP.
Für die Waffen.
Und danach spielen wir noch eine Runde Solo Warzone.
Wobei ich sage,
wie gesagt, das ist, da kriege ich Anfälle.
Da muss man so
krass stelzen.
Ach, guck mal, ein Playstation-Spieler mit Maus
und Tastatur.
Vielleicht weiß das einer von euch.
Man kann ja auf der Playstation 4
Crossplay ausschalten.
Wie sieht's denn aus, wenn man
auf der Playstation mit Maus
und Tastatur spielt?
Wenn man auf der Playstation mit Maus und Tastatur spielt,
kann man dann Crossplay ausschalten oder
ist immer automatisch Crossplay?
Dann kommst du im PC sicher, ja?
Und wenn ich mit Leuten
groope,
ist dann automatisch Crossplay an.
Oh, Shipment!
Da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
Wird ja Zeit,
dass wir mal wieder Shipment spielen, ne?
So, wir probieren jetzt mal was,
ob wir oben drauf kommen.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind wir schon down, bevor wir auch
ansatz-, oh Leute, ich muss aufs Klo.
Bevor wir ansatzweise oben drauf sind.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal von wo.
Ey, Shipment, Alter.
Shipment macht mich fertig.
Shipment, hinter mich spawnen, Shipment.
Viel Shipment, please.
Wah, scheiße, meine MP7 ist leer.
Viel Shipment, please, ey.
Was bist du schauend?
Shipment.
Ich bin ein
Voll für den Arsch, aber Waffen leveln sich gut.
Das ist normal.
Das ist normal auf Shipment, aber
da kann ich den Kram auch Hardcore spielen.
Deswegen, Leute, ihr seht, es ist kein Unterschied.
Das einzige, einzige
Unterschied ist, dass du mehr
stirbst in Softcore,
weil du nicht so viele Leute wegrotzen kannst
aus der Hüfte.
Oh, es geht weiter, Hardcore Shipment.
Excellent.
Als hätte man drauf gewartet.
Als hätte man drauf gewartet, nur
einmal Shipment, immer
Shipment.
The enemy.
The enemy took the Hardpoint.
Chopper Gunner.
Den fucking Chopper Gunner umstarten.
Shipment, please.
You got the Hardpoint contestant.
On setting charge.
Warum habe ich diese Dreckswaffe jetzt aufgehoben?
Die wollte ich doch gar nicht.
Shipment, Alter.
Shipment.
Shipment, please.
Hahaha.
What the hell?
Das ist so
kaputt.
Zeit zum Nachladen hat man natürlich nicht.
Ich aim die jetzt hier ab.
Äh.
Oh, fuck.
Teammate.
Fragt mich nicht, was ihr hier gerade seht.
Ihr seht, ähm,
sinnloseste Spielmodus
auf der sinnlos...
Ne, der Spielmodus ist ganz gut.
Ihr seht, Infinity Wars
Incompetence, irgendwie was
sinnvolles zu remaken.
Warum gibt es keine Playlist?
Oldschool Maps?
Oldschool Maps Playlist?
Oh, haha.
What the...
Fuck.
What the hell?
Ey, ist der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt wisst ihr übrigens auch, warum ich
so eine scheiß KD habe.
Weil ich den ganzen Kram gespielt habe zu 90%.
Ist der gerade hinter uns gespawnt?
Der ist hinter uns gespaw...
What? Von wo?
Also 3 vs 3
würde ich sagen, okay.
Das mag noch gehen oder so.
Aber alles andere...
Meine Fresse.
Leute, ich muss noch kurz aufs Klo.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Wir haben eine gescheite Map.
Keck.
Double U.
Cranked.
Oh, das wird wieder was.
Hält hier irgendeiner
die Ecke?
Das ist wieder instant
gefickt. Äh.
Also Run, Gun ist hier echt nicht ohne.
What?
Äußerst fair.
Ey, sag mal. Darf ich mal was töten,
wenn ich treffe?
Ist das... ist das...
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Alter, er schießt nicht auf mich.
Äh, what?
Kann mir irgendeiner erklären, von was ich gerade einen Punkt gekriegt habe?
Oh, veraimt.
Mega veraimt.
Reloading.
Ground, step it up.
Hah, wow.
Ich dachte, den kann ich aus der Hüfte sprayen. Konnte ich nicht.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Oh, ich bin cranked.
Meine Güte.
Warum treffe ich aus der Hüfte mit der Kackwaffe nicht?
Die ist extra gemacht, um aus der Hüfte zu sprayen.
Kokona-Elm.
Ja, hardcore Kokona-Elm.
Aber man muss aus der Hüfte sprayen.
Das ist der einzige Vorteil, den man damit hat.
Auf Range.
Ey, das...
Echt hardcore.
Guck hier, so muss man aus der Hüfte schießen.
Dann toppt es auch was.
Wow.
Foregrip?
Bringt der was für Hit?
Oh Gott.
Wie er in der Ecke steht.
Ne, da gehe ich nicht lang.
Oh.
Anstrengend.
Anstrengende Sache.
What?
Wie krass.
Wie krass hat er das gemacht.
Wo die Ecke geht.
So, es ist heftig.
Teilweise verreckst du 5x in Folge.
Weil du instant geowned wirst.
Oh, da kommt von hinten.
Oder auch nicht.
Easy.
Oh, ich juckte am Auge.
Shit.
Äh, hallo?
Please?
What?
Wir haben schon verloren?
Ja, die Crank-Sachen zählen doppelt.
Du musst mehr in der Ecke schwitzen für mehr Kills.
Das ist korrekt.
Aber da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Führ aus der Hüfte den Merk-Grip drauf.
Echt?
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ah, ich darf hier nichts einstellen.
Übrigens Leute, ich bin fast schon Level 100.
Ich spiele seit 5 Tagen wieder.
Shit, man.
Das ertrage ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Okay, zeigt mal.
Was für ein Grip?
Meinst du hier?
Den da?
Aim Down Sidespeed.
Du meinst, der ist verbuggt und Aim Down Sidespeed
wird nicht effected?
Excellent.
Genauso mag ich das.
Bug-Using. Who cares?
So, 60 Round Mag.
Muss sein. Mehr hat eh schon.
Ah, Aim Down Sidespeed.
Ne, vielleicht auch nicht.
Perks.
Machen wir mal raus.
Bald haben wir das letzte.
Ähm.
Damage Range.
Das machen wir weg.
Aim Down Sidespeed.
Aim Down Sidespeed immer.
Wobei Bullet Velocity
sollte man nicht machen.
Da brauchen wir 50.
Das machen wir noch.
Laser.
Sprint.
Real Grip. Sprint to
Sprint to Fire.
Sehr gut.
No Stock.
Stock ist hier. Ne, das ist Barrel.
Ach hier.
Ah, hast du doch nicht.
Ne, ich hab auch nicht.
Vielleicht lohnt sich's doch.
Dass ich die...
Aber Movement Speed
will ich eigentlich nicht weniger haben.
Slide of Hand ist gut.
Slide of Hand ist gut, ja.
Slide of Hand geht aber nur, nachdem man was gekillt hat.
Also ich mach dann später den Suppressor drauf.
Macht das überhaupt viel aus?
Hier. Der Unterschied.
Zwischen nicht 50
und 60.
Ich mein, die Anzeigen kann man ja eh nicht glauben, was da drin steht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es vollkommen egal.
Spielen wir mal ne Runde
Combination.
Und dann hoffentlich auf ner guten Map.
Die größeren Mags merkst du wirklich.
Okay. Wollen wir die vielleicht mal
raus?
Na gut. Ich mein, es reicht ja, um einen zu killen.
Was wollen wir denn da jetzt noch drauf?
Ich mein, das Ding ist halt...
Bullet Velocity ist schon nicht schlecht.
Komm, wir machen das nochmal drauf.
Slide of Hand haben wir doch drinne, oder?
Ich glaub, Slide of Hand
hab ich reingemacht.
Ich glaub, das ist ne Kack-Map.
Kappa! Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ghost Fanboy.
Welche Map ist denn das nochmal gewesen?
Denk, denk, denk...
Ach, die! Die geht!
Da muss man sich...
Da muss man sich in das...
Man muss nur durchkommen.
Man muss sich in das Haus campen.
Man muss sich...
Moment, haben wir eigentlich Hardcore? Ne, ne?
Man muss sich in das Haus campen.
Das ist wichtig.
Hier, in dem Haus muss man campen.
Beste Spot im ganzen Game.
Haus campen.
Ein nicer Haus Camper.
Ich hab zu wenig Schuss noch.
Juff.
Jutsch, Haus Camping.
Vollgas.
Das Game ist so ein
Drecks-Camp-Spiel.
Unglaublich.
Unglaublich, äh.
Be advised, UAV is bingo fuel.
RTB for resupply.
Äh.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ja, ja, ist gut. Tür zu.
Und Schuss. Tür auf.
Okay, Trick 17.
Nice, weggesprayt.
Hier campe ich immer an der Ecke.
Ich hab gedacht, das macht jetzt vielleicht auch einer.
Jawoll.
Ja!
Das hinten kann man nicht, ne?
Okay, wir müssen mal B wiederholen.
Der camped hier drin, der macht das so wie ich.
Ah, Flagge, Flagge.
Come on, bra.
Den die verfickte...
Hier movt sich ja mal wieder gar keiner.
Niemand bewegt sich.
Märtyrdom.
Ich fass es nicht.
Hat der wirklich Märtyrdom gespielt gerade?
Hab ich das richtig gesehen, ja?
Was für ein Camper, ey.
Achtung, jetzt machen wir noch mehr
Excellent-Camping.
Was
ein sinnloses Rummel-Camper.
Good.
Egal.
Ich mein, das Game will es von mir.
Oh, zwei Stück.
Das Game will es halt von mir.
Was willst du machen, ja?
Man kriegt ja auch fürs Capturen
nix mehr.
WTF?
Ich muss das drücken, nicht werfen.
Ich zeig euch mal beste Camp-Posi.
Hier.
Ah.
Der ist doch wirklich neben mir vorbeigelaufen jetzt.
By the way, ich glaub, ich mach mir noch ne Hardline-Klasse,
dann erreich ich auch...
Fuck. Mehr Killstreak.
So, man muss es hier nur ins
Warehouse schaffen, dann ist Easy Mode.
Habt ihr ja gesehen. Easy Mode. Warehouse.
Alter, überall
sitzt einer.
Ghost ist viel zu gut.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Ghost ist das Wichtigste.
Du kannst ja auch
normales Warzone nicht richtig
spielen ohne Ghost.
Also, ich mein, doch kannst du.
Das stimmt nicht. Es gibt genug, die spielen Overkill oder sowas.
Aber es ist schon deutlich
angenehmer mit Ghost.
Das Gesprähe
über die halbe Map.
Kann man nicht rüberspringen.
What the hell?
What?
Wo kam der Dude denn her jetzt?
Und was trifft mich hier gerade?
Und, und, und
warum haben wir das nicht eingenommen?
Und warum
kommen da jetzt 30 Millionen Gegner?
Zuerst Overkill, dann Ghost fürs Late Game. Ja.
Deswegen will ich mir auch zwei Klassen machen.
Deswegen will ich mir auch
zwei Klassen machen. Die Map ist übrigens ganz gut.
By the way.
Da kann man nämlich die
Laufwege der Gegner erahnen.
Und ihr wisst, ich find das gut, wenn
die Maps nicht zu chaotisch sind.
Die kommen jetzt von unten her.
What the fuck?
Was ist das da oben? Kann man da hoch?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Erinnere mich mal, please, nach der Runde,
dass ich die Killstreaks ein bisschen lauer mach.
Das Problem ist, es gibt
eigentlich gar keine richtig guten Killstreaks,
die ich haben will. Wie toll.
Wow, fuck. Wie toll ist da eins?
Das sind gute Killstreaks irgendwie,
der sinnvoll, sinnvoll
platziert ist. Der Rest ist irgendwie
zu hoch, wenn man run and gunnt.
Und die Predator ist halt in dem Spiel
richtig schlecht.
Ich wusste, in irgendeiner Ecke
kämpfst du.
Ich wusste, dass du in irgendeiner Ecke
sitzt. Ich wusste nicht, in welcher.
Und man sieht den ja auch so schlecht.
Man hätte aimen können, aber ich hab gedacht,
das ist nicht notwendig.
Aber trotzdem.
Und jetzt gibt's noch ein Assist.
Ist auch nix.
Nice.
Ah, easy.
Ah.
Jetzt wird mir wieder gesessen.
Warum soll ich mich bewegen?
Oh, wir haben Triple.
Wow, Triple Cap.
Triple Cap.
Gegner?
Oh shit.
Ach man, der Typ.
Der ist spezialisiert
auf das Gebäude. Ich seh da schon.
Warum sterben
die denn nicht? Ja, ich treff nicht
alles, aber umkippen dürfen sie trotzdem.
Trotzdem.
Oh, mein Ellenbogen tut weh, ey.
Alter, Scheibenwischer-Aim.
Ah.
Tut echt meinen Ellenbogen weh, der Sack.
Oh, da ist aber
einer scharf auf mich.
E-Sport ist kein Sport, Max holt sich sogar den Ellenbogen.
Verletze. Ja.
Es ist wirklich, mir tut richtig
der Ellenbogen weh. Ich glaube, ich muss da mal
ein Kissen oder so drunter legen.
Ich hab ja den,
den kennt ihr ja, den hab ich euch ja schon mal gezeigt.
Hier den.
So.
Den Stuhl.
Und er hat ansonsten eigentlich recht angenehme
Lehnen, ja.
Aber für
8 Stunden
ärmelloses Hemd
ist das
zu,
zu hart.
Richtig, es ist kein Gaming-Stuhl,
aber Gaming-Stühle sind auch
overrated. Ich muss übrigens mal gucken, dass ich keine Subs
übersehen hab.
Dergolive hat Resub 3 Monate, dankeschön.
Glaub hab ich schon vorgelesen, aber trotzdem.
Huge.
Naja, ist kein Hemd, ist ein T-Shirt halt. Kurzärmlich.
Au, au.
Die Killstreaks runterstellen, ja.
Oh ne, es kommt auch Asierkampf. Geh fort.
So, was, was, was können wir da überhaupt für, was für sinnvolle
Killstreaks gibt's da eigentlich?
Ähm.
Das, die,
die, die Predator ist halt
Rotz.
Die braucht viel zu lang.
So, der Clusterstrike macht keine Kills.
Der Precision Airstrike,
der geht sogar noch halbwegs.
Den muss man aber gut setzen.
Und außerdem rennen alle weg.
Mit dem killst du eigentlich auch sehr wenig.
So.
Ich glaube, ich mach wieder das da.
Das hatte ich nämlich auch die ganze Zeit vorher.
Heute hab ich umgestellt hier auf Choppergunner
und mal White Phosphorus ausprobiert.
Das ist übrigens richtig gut.
Das ist richtig nice.
Da gewinnt man die Runde fast sicher
und macht auch ganz gut Kills zwischendurch,
weil die Gegner so blöd sind und ins Feuer rennen.
Bisher hatte ich immer das hier als Loadout.
Das ist eigentlich echt das Beste, was man nehmen kann, glaube ich.
Weil,
tja,
was?
Installing Shader?
Okay.
Modern Warfare muss man nicht nachvollziehen.
Wir machen jetzt mal wirklich komplett den YOLO-Modus.
Alles.
Wir haben jetzt alles drin.
Mal gucken, was da jetzt kommt.
Wahrscheinlich ist gleich Ragequit-Time angesagt.
So.
Und wenn ich die MP7 auf Level 50 hab,
hab ich die vielleicht sogar schon auf Level 50?
Ha!
Dann spielen wir eine Runde Warzone.
Ne, spielen wir nicht, weil ich noch XP-Boost hab.
14 Minuten.
14 Minuten war schon Weapon-Boost.
Die nutzen wir noch aus.
Jetzt können wir auch den Suppressor dran machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Setup jetzt übelst kacke
mit dem Lauf.
Oh, ich hab die...
Ich hab den Suppressor an der...
Ähm...
Probieren wir mal.
TDM!
Oje, Leute.
TDM Warehouse.
Probier mal Nostock.
Mach ich. Mach ich.
Okay, hier. Keiner Bock.
Hier hat wirklich keiner Bock.
Hier hat absolut gar keiner Bock.
Oh!
Der Cleverino!
Huge IQ-Play.
Die Perk,
dass man im Rennen schießen kann,
die fand ich übelst geil in Black Ops 2,
war das, glaube.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Ich blicke nicht durch,
wo da was herkommt.
Okay. Der hat 7 Kills?
What the fuck? Wie hat er das denn gemacht?
Ich weiß ja nicht,
wie man hier laufen muss auf der Map.
Der sitzt wahrscheinlich
irgendwo.
Liegst du da dran und dann kannst du voll knicken.
Ah, ich hab eine Idee.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal machen?
Ähm...
Edit...
Quick-Fix.
Wir probieren es mal aus.
Äh...
Falsche.
Habe ich die falsche Klasse ausgewählt?
Nee.
Ach, M4 habe ich...
Ah...
Okay.
Leute, wir sind zu mobil.
Das funktioniert in dem Spiel nicht.
Ich muss jetzt wieder shimmeln.
Sonst wird das nichts.
Guckt es euch an.
What the fuck?
Von wo?
Meine Güte.
Oh, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, mehr sitzen, Max. Mehr sitzen.
Nicht zu viel bewegen.
Ich spiele das ja wie jedes andere Call of Duty.
Das geht ja.
Every empty Ecke.
Nee.
Das sah bei mir nicht so aus.
What the fuck?
Was war denn das wieder?
Haben die ersten Hits nicht gezählt?
Oder...
Was war denn das wieder da?
Mal gucken, von wo da was ist.
Stim?
Nee, der hat geleckt.
Sau.
Ein Wilson.
Jetzt sind sie natürlich auf eine komplett andere Seite.
Ich benutze... Ich muss den Stim benutzen, Alter.
Warum benutze ich den Stim nicht?
Crossfire. Sehr schön.
Guck mal, ich bin Zweiter, worum das dann?
Kann man hier hoch?
Von allen Seiten, ey!
Übrigens, das ist hier das Pro-Movement, das habe ich mir schon abgeguckt für Warzone.
Du musst sprinten, hinschmeißen, sprinten, hinschmeißen, sprinten, hinschmeißen, sprinten,
hinschmeißen, sprinten, hinschmeißen und dann sterben.
Da gehen sie, oh fuck.
Oh, last kill, komm, Kill-Camp.
Gib mir mal ne Kill-Camp, gib mir mal ne Kill-Camp, please.
Das muss doch die Kill-Camp gewesen sein.
Leute, ich habe Hunger, ich muss mal kurz Brötchen reinbeißen.
Jetzt, hier, Poggers.
Endlich mal ne Kill-Camp.
Ne, du musst den Slide glaube ich nicht canceln.
Du kannst Tactical Sprint, Slide und dann gleich wieder Tactical Sprint machen.
Oder ich habe es noch nicht ganz gecheckt.
Und das Schlimme ist,
14.9 ist ein guter Score in dem Spiel.
Au, Level 100.
Gibt 155.
Stimmt.
Was gibt es hier eigentlich kostenlos?
Oh je, die Map.
Die geht, die geht.
Ganz ehrlich, die hätten sich sparen können.
Dieses ganze Kill-Camp Scoreboard-Gezeige und die Intro-Flüge.
Einfach joinen, los.
Hier kommt jetzt einer, klar.
Okay.
Schimmeln angesagt.
Easy Schimm los.
Hallo, Gegner, please.
Gegner?
Hallo?
Du findest einen Gegner und zack, da bin ich natürlich schon klar.
Ah.
Ich weiß nicht, Run and Gun ist irgendwie so eine Sache.
Okay, Leute.
Es bleibt uns leider nichts.
Achso, Moment.
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Wir haben da Ghosts noch.
Bis denn, Yannick.
Danach spielen wir eine Runde Solo Warzone, wenn es vorbei ist.
Es kommt immer ganz entscheidend auf die Gegner an.
Ob man das, ob man da reinlaufen kann oder nicht.
Enemy near Main Street.
Aber die liegen so krass wieder.
Die liegen so krass wieder.
Du kommst überhaupt nirgendswohin.
Kill confirmed.
Enemy UAV overhead.
Who is this guy?
Oh, war das close.
Kill confirmed.
Wow.
Monka.
Kill confirmed.
Enemy at the barbary.
Enemy sentry on action.
Send a flyover.
Massive Monka S.
Enemy personal radar overhead.
This is Falcon 3-0.
Changing Max.
Your mother.
Wie ging das?
UAV is out of fuel.
Enemy UAV overhead.
Ah.
Ticken zu spät.
Ein Ticken zu spät.
Brauner Marok, danke für den Sub.
Hallo?
Gegner.
Gib mir Gegner.
Changing Max.
Keine Gegner.
Ich bin ja nicht aus dem Haus raus, Leute.
Das könnt ihr vergessen.
Da bin ich instant down, wenn ich aus dem Haus rausgehe.
Ich sag's euch.
Glaubt es mir.
Gehst du aus dem Haus raus, bist du tot.
Action.
Also das hier ist der...
Guck mal.
Das funktioniert.
Tactical Sprint.
Slide.
Ah.
Passt.
Slide.
Tactical Sprint.
Das ist so das Pro-Movement.
Oh.
Renettis.
Okay.
Leute, der will's nicht anders.
Der will's nicht anders.
Äh.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Er will's nicht anders.
Moment.
Hier geht's rein.
Okay.
Wo sind sie denn?
Ich brauch Gegner.
Wenn er Renettis will, kann er die haben.
Aber jetzt seh ich nix mehr.
Okay, der Typ, der Renetti-Dude ist weg.
Fuck.
Gegner.
Okay.
Dann müssen wir doch mit der M4 ran.
Erstmal schön die CSGO-UpAim-Taktik machen.
Nur das irgendwie nix da ist.
Ich will einen umrenettien.
Und wenn es das einzige ist, was ich die Runde mache.
Easy.
Ich charge da jetzt durch.
Ah.
Fuck.
Der muss renettien werden.
Jawoll.
Okay.
Wir können wieder ne ordentliche Waffe nehmen.
Es wäre richtig geil, wenn ich ein paar Gegner sehen würde.
Das wäre massiv Poggers.
Alle haben mir einfach die Tür in die Fresse gehauen.
Das C4 war absolut Big Brain Next Level, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ha, von drüben, von drüben werde ich gekillt.
Ne, den Aufsatz freischalten gibt es nicht mehr, ne.
Ok, wir spielen wieder was ordentliches.
Genug Cowboy Pistols.
Ok, wir gucken jetzt mal, dass wir gewinnen.
Wir gucken mal, dass wir gewinnen jetzt.
Über mir, oder?
Ok.
Alter, wie du überall abge-aimt wirst.
Das ist Core, ja.
Und übrigens, die sterben in Core tatsächlich so schnell mit der Waffe.
Also, das Ding ist krass.
Ist hier oben was?
Jetzt sehe ich das richtig.
Die Runde.
Guckt euch mal an, wie da geschimmelt wurde.
54 zu 56.
So, ich esse jetzt kurz mein Brötchen fertig.
Und dann gammele ich jetzt.
Gammel ich mal wirklich eine Runde Warzone und Solo rum.
Aber, ich sage euch, erwartet nichts, ne.
Warzone winnen oder anzappen?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich glaube, man kann gar nicht anzappen.
Ähm, so Max haste Bock.
Yo.
Stream so, aber gerade.
Chat-Leak.
Crufty, Twitch Prime.
Oh, ähm.
Was?
Was zum?
Ah, man sieht nichts.
Ja.
Man sieht nichts.
Oh, ne.
Die Map.
Och, please.
Das ist die Schlimmste.
Das ist wirklich das Allerschlimmste in diesem Spiel.
Die Map, Alter.
Die Map.
Shit, mate.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Wir müssen hier weg.
Alter.
Oh, oh, oh.
Diese Map.
Schlimm.
Ja, klar.
Ver-aimt.
Aber die Map ist so schlimm.
Das ist echt, ohne Scheiß, Leute, das ist die Schlimmste.
What?
Alter.
Bleib doch mal da.
Oh, Alter.
Oh.
Princess Princess.
Brother Princess.
Ja, bitte, bitte.
Hirsef representative 6-bit.
Danke,
Ja.
die map macht mich so fertig die sieht ja optisch sogar ganz gut aus aber die
spielt sich einfach shit wo ist denn hier überhaupt was es ist hier komplett
random auf den gegner force wie es hier läuft oder nicht es ist es ist einfach
kommt ich dachte da steht einer es ist komplett random da wie sie so war das
perfekt easy as fuck das macht mich fertig die
macht mich wirklich bringt mich an den rand der verzweiflung
das hat das ist wirklich da musst du schmerzes geld für bezahlen
da musst du echt schmerze das geld für bezahlen für die map stream standards
stimmt muss ich muss david die متten nicht verlockt
ok leute moment
jetzt bleibt hd xxhsh
hd xxhshsh
Snipes. Das ist ja wie toll. Ja, warte mal. XHD Snipes. I Snipes X360. Easy. Next Face Member hier.
Next. Ich sage, next, next. Wer ist denn gerade angesagter Sniper? You ain't Chris Baby. Wer ist
denn gerade, was ist denn gerade Sniper? Der Sniper-Gott. Face Wobblers. Alter, die Map. Okay, okay. I Snipes. I Scopes Wobblers.
What? Okay. Hier ist nix. I Scopes. Jetzt scope ich und es kommt nix. 360. Ich glaube, ich habe was zu essen neben mir stehen.
Ich habe nicht genug Platz, um Mauspad 360 zu machen. Achtung, Leute. Von hinten. Alter, das ist... Die Map macht mich so fertig. Warum bin ich erster mit sieben Kills? Das geht doch gar nicht.
Äh, weiter. Sorry. I Snipes HD. Die haben Bock.
Oh, jetzt wurde er gesniped. Max, nach der Runde latsch dich ein. Das wird dann... Ja, da haben wir doppelt Max am Start. Haben wir noch einen dritten? Und ihr müsst Ansagen machen, ne? Ich bin doch nicht so ein Warzone-Pro. Die Map ist wirklich legit Körperverletzung.
Legit Körperverletzung.
Legit. Legit Körperverletzung.
Wie Raz weiß. Wie Raz weiß, einfach.
Oh, und stirbt nicht.
Die Maxens, neue RTLz.
Jetzt ist er da hinten.
Können die nicht eine Metro-Map machen?
Okay, nicht einen Hit. Krass.
Mega-Aim.
Übermäßig haben wir den.
noch.
High IQ Aim war das eben wieder.
Oh, wir haben gar keine
Muni mehr.
Achtung, jetzt gehen wir da runter.
Wir haben uns gebasht.
Ah.
Oh.
Jetzt haben wir einen.
Hallo, du Wielstabestart.
Fahren wir mal eine Runde.
Hä? Fahren wir mal eine Runde.
What the hell?
Beste Pose für so ein Wilson gewesen.
Huge Wilson.
Gib Gas!
Gib Gas, aber ich secure das
in Hardpoint. Da können die nix
gegen machen.
Okay.
Dreimal Max per CSGO
stimmt, weil als wir CSGO gespielt haben,
haben wir Triple Max da.
Okay, Max, invitest du mich?
Soll ich dich entwalten?
Und ich muss mal in-game-Voice anmachen.
What? Was jetzt?
Hallo? Game?
Was? Was macht das Spiel für Dinger wieder?
Max, ich starte mal kurz neu.
Du hast Push-to-Talk an.
Ja, will ich auch.
Sonst kann ich nicht mit dem Chat labern.
Was mache ich während der Runde wahrscheinlich eh nicht.
Das ist alles, was ich sage. Hören die.
Leaked. Schon wieder.
Was ist jetzt schon wieder leaked?
Pack 1.
Okay, wir lassen das Game jetzt Shader installieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was es auf einmal
für Schmerzen hat.
Nee, das macht das Game nur einmal. Bei mir macht er das nie sonst.
So, Max, bin da.
Wie war das jetzt? Haben wir jetzt noch einen dritten
oder nicht?
Hallo, hallo.
Hallo.
Hörst du uns?
Ja, wir sind angeblich nur zwei, aber drei sind im Voice-Chat.
Perfekt.
Warum sind wir angeblich nur zwei?
Ach so, hier.
Weil das Game der Meinung ist,
wir sind nur zwei.
Ja, das Übliche.
Kann ich direkt suchen, oder?
Wir haben angeblich schon einen Flexi
9.6 oder sowas.
Ja, ja.
Ah, du bist ultra leise.
Ich verstehe dich kaum.
Echt? Aber Max, bei dir ist es normal, oder?
Ja, bei mir alles gut.
Ja.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Aber du kannst suchen. Also ihr müsst mir sagen, wo es lang geht.
Ich bin da noch ein bisschen
verplant.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Seid ihr schon die Experten?
Ich, ja, naja.
Also, ein paar Mal Win war schon drin.
Dementsprechend, sollte schon gehen.
Kriegt man hin.
Ist er bei mir?
Ne.
Strange, weil ich habe jetzt gerade alles hochgestellt.
Ja.
Kann ich nachher auch noch mitmachen.
Ich verstehe ihn ganz gut.
Also, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich eher Solos spielen
und jetzt halt eine
eine Runde Trios. Also ich wollte keine
Chat-Games machen.
Ja, du kannst suchen.
Ja, notfalls mache ich halt hier den
Dolmetscher sozusagen.
Ja.
Also Chat, die Pros,
die droppen immer Storage Town.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob wir Pro genug sind, Storage Town zu droppen.
Storage Town und Warehouse
droppen die immer. Also die, die
dann World Record Kills Gameplay
spielen und so.
Na, aber
ich glaube, wir sind nicht Pro
genug. Wo wollen wir denn droppen?
Oh, ich glaube, ich muss Voice Chat unbedingt lauter machen.
Leute, Chat,
versteht ihr die zwei überhaupt?
Klatsch.
Sag mal bitte was.
Hallo, hallo.
Ja, ich habe euch ein bisschen lauter gemacht, aber trotzdem, man
versteht es nicht wirklich. Aber es passt schon.
Mich auch mit, oder?
Doch, dich halbwegs.
Ach, ich war mal.
Ich war mal ein bisschen lauter.
Ja, halbwegs ist er.
Ja, so ist gut.
So ist gut.
In-Game viel zu laut.
Ah.
Natürlich In-Game viel zu laut, weil das Game sich wieder umgestellt hat.
Max, öffnen Sie bitte die Map.
Ja, wo wollen wir hin?
Da hier, wo wir markieren.
Grün?
Yes.
Okay.
Voll garantiert.
Let's land here.
So, wollen wir gleich mal.
So, wollen wir mal, ha?
Und auf geht's, Junge.
Oh, das ist ja fast Storage Town, wo wir droppen hier.
Das ist richtig, aber dann können wir uns von außen bis hierhin vorarbeiten.
Weil es Storage Town ist.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, Chat, ob das was wird.
Haben wir schon mal die Pro Fallschirm Strats am Start?
Eliminate all targets in the area.
Money, money, money.
Was ist denn das für ein Shotgun?
Das ging schnell.
Max, äh, hörst du mich noch?
Jo.
Ja, wunderbar, weil ich hab keinen hier Lautsprecher-Symbol mehr, wenn ich spreche, aber...
Schlecht.
Ne, ich hör dich aber noch.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Lieber eine Schleife, bevor ich die Kack-Shotgun mitnehme.
Äh, Storage Town ist schon was.
Kann man theoretisch rüber.
Ja.
Theoretisch, ja.
Wie schaut's denn bei dir mit dem Loot aus?
Geht halbwegs.
Könnten wir auch noch einen?
Ja, das klappt.
Gehen wir da mal noch zum Haken drüber und dann kommen wir.
Ja, komm.
Lass mal irgendwo nicht auf der Straße stehen bleiben.
I've got it.
Da kommen noch, da kommen noch mehr, da kommen noch mehr.
Enemy Vehicle.
Ja, direkt.
Ich komm mal rüber.
Wow.
I'm hit.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, Kollege.
Übelst räudige Waffe, alter.
Links ich seh da keine mehr.
Links war einer noch.
An der Richtung Tankstelle.
Aber es war glaub ich anderes Team.
Das ist ein Decoy, oder?
Das ist ein Decoy.
Klingt wie ein Decoy.
Storage Town ist was.
Ja.
Mitte am, am, am Wagen.
Am Train-Ding.
Boah, Jungs von hinten.
Fuck.
Was, von hinten?
Voll.
Irgendwo da oben am Berg, glaub ich.
Ja.
Kann mich einer retzen?
Mr. Kane, you're fine.
Merci.
Guck mal, ob das...
Nix wie weg, ja.
Lass mal weg hier.
Einer.
Wir müssen, wir müssen weg.
Ja, das...
Wir haben kaum Rüstung und nix.
Oder wie viel sind denn da oben?
Vielleicht können wir die pushen, aber ich glaub nicht, äh.
Ja, dann geh.
Geh.
Ich brauch unbedingt ne gescheite Waffe.
Warte, dann nimm du die P90.
Ja, passt.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Ich hab kein Geld.
Ich muss...
Ja, lass mal Geld zusammenschmeißen, dann können wir eine Drohne...
Ja.
Anachsen, und dann können wir eine Drohne kaufen.
jobshoot wir inhabited.
Push to talk einstellen, Walder.
Und, äh, hier Platten kann ich auch kaufen.
Okay.
So ich hab jetzt eingestellt...
Hörst du mich?
Ja.
Okay, nice.
Ich hab jetzt eingestellt, dass wir...
Gleich nochmal.
Dass ich nicht Push to talk drücken muss.
Okay, die wissen garantiert, wo wir sind.
Ja.
Ja, ja, push to talk ist eigentlich...
Hier ist ja nichts!
Hier ist ja gar nichts!
These sind ja absolut tote Hose.
Oder Ghosts?
Oder Ghost am Start?
Ja also...
Nee, jetzt noch nicht. Das ist zu früh.
Man weiß nie. Das ist nie zu früh für Ghosts, Alter.
Okay, also Plan. Wo gehen wir hin?
Tankstelle, okay. Dann holen wir uns das Auto da drüben und dann machen wir's.
Da oben kommt einer.
Der will da rein trocken wie da hinten. Egal, lassen wir ihn mal.
Habt ihr den Huge Snipe gesehen, Chat?
Money, money.
Sag mal, gibt's mal gescheite Waffe, ey.
Aber wirklich, viel ist ja nicht zu bieten.
Ist ja nicht drin, ey.
Wollen wir dann rüber zu den Häusern?
Wenn wir hier fertig sind?
Ich würde eher das Auto nehmen und den Ziegen runter.
Okay.
Das vorne hinterher.
Ja, komm, lass das Auto nehmen und dann fahren wir.
Lowdown können wir uns ja nicht leisten.
Was gibt denn das hier?
So spielen die Pros in Solos immer.
Die fahren die ganze Zeit rum, steigen casual aus und killen Leute.
Wir könnten mal ein paar Aufträge machen noch.
Der Sound, den haben sie auch in fünf Minuten aufgenommen hier.
Oh, wo, wo, wo, wo?
Ah, hier, direkt neben uns.
Darf ich?
Also ich mein, wow.
Alter, perfekt.
Top.
Ich boller's.
Das hat gut funktioniert.
Die Knight.
So, ich guck mal, ob ich sehe, wo ihr...
Ne, ihr seid noch gar nicht drin.
Bei mir ist keiner im Publikum.
Seid ihr gemeinsam?
Wir sind zusammen, ja.
Okay.
Die Nubs fahren das Auto, ja.
Äh.
Ah, jetzt.
Okay.
So, so, so.
Glocken lassen.
So, easy win.
Einfach Flagge.
Easy, genau.
So, jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Wo gehen wir hin?
Zum Loadout können wir nicht.
Dann ist es RIP.
Ich kann dir leider nichts...
Warte mal.
Ha.
Ich flieg mal dahin, wo ich markiert hab.
Geld.
Probier's mal.
Ich flieg dahin.
Korrekt.
Liegt da noch was.
Das ist am Hochhaus, ja.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, jetzt zumindest schon mal ne Waffe.
Mit wahnsinnig viel Schuss.
Doppelt Odin.
So war.
Jetzt wird's advanced.
Bist du raus?
Ah, die haben dich gekillt, oder?
Ich bin tot, ja.
Ich bin tot.
Sie war total weg.
Okay.
Jetzt bin ich allein.
Perfekt.
Hahaha.
Chat wollte mich eh solo spielen sehen.
Na dann.
Time to shine.
Ja, ich brauche mal irgendwas...
Hier ist ja auch nichts da!
Okay, zeig mal, wie sieht die Zone aus.
War ja irgendwie verbrannt, Junge.
Jetzt bekommen wir im Aspen irgendwie bisschen Loot.
Die haben gesagt, hier zum Markieren.
Was will ich denn machen?
Dann markiere ich mal...
Ich habe ihn gerade kritisiert
Ist ja gar nichts mehr
So also magst du doch beruhigt sagen wo ich hin soll ich machen soll
Oder sind wir voll mit drin
Da gibt es vielleicht jetzt mal ein bisschen
Aller Manni wo sieht man denn wo es aufträge gibt überhaupt
Was wo sind echt
Nicht gesehen auf dem Dach
Also platten habe ich jetzt genug markiere noch mal wo ich hin ach da ist ja nix an geld
Das geld
YouTube war niemals
Was haben wir da
Obst ich brutal wenig kohle ja
oder nur kohle
Oder lohnt sich das hier oben wahrscheinlich lohnt sich hier oben noch mal durchzulooten
Ich denke da ist gelootet aber du kannst mal gucken
Da ist gelootet
Ah Cash
Ah die Feuerwehr ok
Da ist aber auch bestimmt leer
Oder ist das überhaupt eine Feuerwehr
Wahrscheinlich aber gerade lag auch noch eine Kohle oben auf dem Dach
Obwohl gelootet war also
Ok
Wenn die Nowhands alles liegen lassen
Manni
Siehst du?
Ja
Aber da fehlt noch ein bisschen was
Aha
Tja und du
Mal Map gucken
Moment
Wir könnten hier außen weiterlaufen
Ja
Kommt die Dropansage eigentlich nur wenn er in der Nähe droppt oder immer wenn er droppt?
Wenn einer droppt ähm gute Frage
Nächste Frage
Äh wenn er in der Nähe droppt oder immer wenn er droppt?
Äh wenn einer
Gleich werde ich gesniped ja
Oh
Siehste
Ah ich doch
Aber ich hab genug
Ich kann hier schlecht fighten so
Manni
Oh fuck wie kommt man hier hoch
Ah
Bestimmt kam hier bestimmt
Nice ein Stunt übers
MLG legit
Richtig legit
Ok
Ich revidiere meine Aussagen
Wir hätten es fast geschafft zumindest einen wieder zu überleben
Naja das ist doof gelaufen
Ja das war Warmup
Genau Warmup
Aber jetzt halt hier
Ich such direkt wieder ne
Jaja
Alles drin außer Win
Ah ich hab heute schon gewonnen
Das reicht
Genug pro Tag
Das reicht zwar nicht für Twitch Rivals
Ja aber für mich reicht's
Kommt schon noch
Alter der Dude
Huge Sniping Skills
Warum war das kein Ratschlag
Bin ich zu dumm für
Oh
Ah
Ich gesniped
Ne ist eben auch
Das macht keinen großen Unterschied
Es müsste so ne so ne
Push to Mute Geschichte geben
Dass wenn ich was zum Chat sagen will
Dass ich mich muten kann
Der Chat will was sagen?
Ne wenn ich zum Chat was sagen will
Dass ich mich muten kann bei euch
Das wäre Poggers
Sag mal
Gehen die Schüsse grad durch?
Ja am Ende die letzten 5 Sekunden
Ah ok
Lass mal da rein fliegen
Ok
Alright Soldier
Mark a drop point for your team
You've got a drop point
You've got gas closing in fast
Get to the safe zone
Dollar cup
So
Ja hopp
Auf geht's
Jetzt sehe ich auch irgendwie so nen Trick
Wie man am schnellsten runter kommt
Also irgendwie erst so ne Kurve fliegen
Und dann irgendwas ziehen
Oder
Mir ist noch nichts auf
Ja direkt vor uns
Des
Hinter dir Max ist einer
Auf dem Dach
Alter
Wait
Objective updated
Cure that position
Da müssten noch mehr sein
Ja auf der
Da sind ziemlich viele getroppt
Top 1 von dir
Ja ich bin gleich da
Brauchen unbedingt Plates
Ich glaub die sind gequirlert
Ok
Ja da habe ich nichts dagegen
Kann ich ruhig sparen
Gibt's denn hier noch was?
Waren die hier schon überall drin?
Assault Raid
So jetzt können wir uns hier schön voll looten
Wollen wir hier oben den Auftrag dann machen?
Ups
Den
Ja wir haben gerade noch einen laufen aber
Achso stimmt
Kannst du machen wenn du magst
Man muss ein bisschen aufpassen
Ich weiß nicht ob da welche sind
Und den ja
Obacht gehen
Kommt man hier durch?
Ne
Na wir brauchen erstmal ordentliches Loot
Moving
Kann man sich daher weniger
Also es geht was
Ordentliches Assault Rifle P90
Paar Platten wär nicht schlecht
Ich bin eigentlich echt ganz zufrieden
FME
Guck mal hier
Eine Pogger Sniper und ein UAV
Die würde ich mir gönnen
Schnapp dir
Ja
Oder willst du diese?
Nö
Mach
Ich hätte hier ne MP7
Legendary
Ja die nenn ich
Gucken wir was das für eine ist
Äh
Na gut
Besser als nix
Assault Rifle
Ah guck mal ne M4
Die nenn ich
Huch
Hast du was versehen?
Ja trotzdem
Ich hab so komische
Odin
Oder wie auch immer
Die Odin
M4 beste
Äh
Und Jungs
Wir können unseren Loadout holen
Okay
Wende hier
Finde ich nicht
Wir laufen nach Richtung Buy Station und dann
Gönnen wir uns
Jo
Den packen wir nicht mehr bis zum Auftrag, ja?
Ich muss kurz umtragen
Dann können wir gleich noch den Auftrag nehmen
Wenn wir eh hier sind
Yes, Max du kannst die andere Schnipso haben wenn du möchtest
Nö
Hast schon
Also ich würd vorschlagen wir gehen jetzt mal zur Buy Station und dann holen wir uns erstmal Loadout
So wir müssen den Auftrag noch annehmen hier
Ah okay
Ja das ist vielleicht...
Bisschen besser
Aber du kannst die Bounty machen Max
Ja mein ich ja
Wo liegt denn das Teil?
Irgendwo
Auf beiden
Laut mir
Wahrscheinlich auf dem Dach
Kann man irgendwie hoch
Alter wenn ich die Kackhäuser wenigstens kennen würde in dem Game
Pass auf jetzt holen wir die Trick 17
Ähm
Ja
Bitte
Nö
Okay
Dann
Nicht
Aha
Warte die läuft
Warte
Ja
Warte die läuft
Oh
Da paper
Die Flint
Boor
Ich hab gleich andere
Jetzt den Reload
Oh
Boor
Bowl
doch immer einer geld ja gut bei aber
plate nicht erschlagen lassen
faktor für die ich will doch bloß mal
altes zeug wieder aufheben geht nicht
genau das ist das sind die schotter
wollte ich auch dabei haben wieder
achtung von hoch werden beschlossen
ich glaube ich habe eine markierte die
outplayen wir jetzt muss immer kurz
big brain play von außen links btf die
sind auf der mauer geil perfekt
das war auch richtig
billig
action eine stunde und meine güte
richtig reingeschissen wieder richtig
dumm aufgemacht von ihr er kommt als
erstes
die mitte rechts mit der rechts
ich muss erst mal rechnung steht an
der frau
ach scheiße rage quitter geber nicht
und sagt game scheiße und kein bock auf
den kack ich habe so verschissen aller
auch fakt die hören mich jetzt ja gar
nicht mehr wenn ich wenn ich mir jetzt
bitte ach scheiße jetzt ohne jetzt hat
ihr mich ja gar nicht werden ein game
boys ich habe auch nicht alles weiß
gedacht aber ich ärgere mich bei so
was immer aber nicht über meine
mitspieler oder so sondern einfach weil
ich keinen plan haben wie man das
richtig spielen muss wenn ich wenn ich
nicht irgendjemand dabei habe aktuell
der mich ein bisschen coach erklärt
wo es lang geht ich verkackt voll ich
habe den fluss von dem spielmodus noch
überhaupt nicht drin
die flur mal ein 21 uhr wird er da wir
müssen jetzt noch ein paar runden
ich muss ja so ein paar runden sinnloses
zeug spielen
ich muss jetzt etwas sinnloses spielen
irgendwas total sinnlos klicken dann
klicken
beste musik anmachen das ist voll das
überfordert mich übelst das game ist
ist neu und ich weiß ich was ich machen
soll
und wenn ich dann noch und dann auch
mit mit anderen leuten wo ich keine
genaue ansage kriegt was was ist
zwar die übelsten
warum ist das game wieder so laut stellt
sich das
Sag mal
What the hell
Das Game
Haben die Gegner wieder einen Chopper Gunner
Ach das ist unserer
Oh wir sind mal wo gut ist reingejoint
Wo ist der Typ
Achtung huge
Okay der Sapphire sucked
Oh ups
Ja der stellt sich bei jedem Neustart wieder zurück
Ich weiß gar nicht warum
Warum
Total bescheuert
Mega beknackt
Kann man auch mal bitte in eine Runde joinen
Die noch nicht schon angefangen hat
Das ist
Der buy to play
Multiplayer
Aber was ich halt nicht verstehe nach wie vor
Oh schau wieder Raster
Was ich nicht verstehe ist warum man kein Map Voting macht
Please warum
Ja muss Hardcore
Beste Sachen um Waffen zu anlocken
Ah
Wieso schon pre-naden
Oh betroffen sitzt er
Aha
Ja
Ja muss Hardcore
Ja gut
Exzellent
Puhh
Perfekt
Äh okay
Das sah so aus als lebte er
Sag mal kann das sein dass der
der Schalldämpfer auch den hip spread ein Bisschen
Verkackt
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Bam
Wobei geht er eigentlich
Ah
Ne ich wollte gerade sagen ich hab den Laser weg
Aber anscheinend habe ich den Laser nicht weg
By the way ich labere gar nicht übelst mein Team zu wegen Voice chat
Lol
Ich glaube das war die ganze Zeit Voice chat
chat an keck w warum ich das kommt wieder spiele eigentlich weil mir war
sonst trio übel spot macht wenn ich wenn ich halt jemand dabei habe der mich
erstens carried und wie das game erklären kann
wow ich muss das echt mal lernen ich habe noch nie eine battle royale game
gespielt da fakt der ist direkt hinter mir
gespawnt einfach so richtig aber schön c4 da meine ellenbogen übelst weh das
hatte ich schon ewig nicht mehr dass man ellenbogen wehtun
leck sie einfach ab ob es dann besser ist was ist denn jetzt gerade in ds
kriegt der ball hat so dass man schön meine
camp ecke beste huge camp ecke und irgendwie lässt sich keiner blicken
gerade und zwar team teammate ist hilft hüftgespräche ja man stirbt übelst wie
gesagt der sinn von von hardcore ist ja eigentlich auch dass man schnell stirbt
beziehungsweise gegner schnell sterben dass man halt mehr kills macht mehr
waffen leveln kann ich mache das ja nur zu waffen level ja
es geht mir voll auf den sack wie planlos ich den
battle royale spielen bin deswegen klein ich ja jetzt auch gerade ein
bisschen ich kriege ja sowas meistens halbwegs schnell hin
so halbwegs also ich brauche dann einen monat spielen dann geht es meistens
halbwegs aber aktuell bin ich voll planlos ich brauche ich bin wirklich
darauf angewiesen dass wenn man trios spielt dass ich in squadleader dabei
habt ihr was erklären kann kluscht kluscht ernsthaft das ist das ding war friendlyfire
hier lulwe da stehen sie in der ecke so ist das so ist hardcore gut
so ist hardcore natürlich top ein wilson gleich kommt noch der wilson rein was
sinden die gegner überhaupt so wilson komm her einsorry
prämie
hier ÔL
woheig
duار
wie
ist
hier
nm
Was ist das?
Ein Wilson.
Fährt rum.
Und Anti-Gegner.
Das Ding ist in Hardcore extrem OP.
Wie man sieht.
Das Ding ist komplett OP.
Richtig.
Aller 37 Kills.
Die Gegner kriegen gerade Massive auf den Sack.
Das ist schon nicht mal feierlich, wie die Gegner auf den Sack kriegen.
Noch Wilson.
Lol.
Geh doch nächste Wilson raus.
Brumm, brumm, brumm.
Hallo.
Keck.
Weh, Alter.
Was?
Das ist die totale Vernichtung gerade.
Guckt es euch mal an.
52 Kills.
Guck mal.
Massive Play of the Game.
Huge.
In eine Richtung geschossen.
Wie ist das geil?
Pog.
YouTube-Video sagste.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich low, oder?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Um YouTube-Video zu machen, müsst ihr erst mal captchern.
Aber gut.
Na ja.
Ich hab es im Stream.
Ich hab es im Stream, ja.
Ich muss jetzt erst noch mal guten Teamplayer machen.
So.
Ich muss mich erst mal entschuldigen für Rage Quitten.
Gehört sich nicht.
Oh, ne.
hab ich da Shipment gesehen?
Oh je, Leute.
Shipment. Please. Shipment.
Jetzt wird's schlimm. Jetzt wird's schlimm.
Wir können uns in Vitoil oder in Wilson
ercampen.
Das machen wir?
Ah, shit.
Ich hab ne Idee.
Ey, die beste Klasse für diesen
Shit ist doch
wirklich ohne Spaß,
Leute.
Die beste Klasse für den Mist
ist doch... Ach ne, man kann
keine Killstreaks ändern, oder?
Ah ne, brauchen wir ja auch nicht.
Warte mal.
Edit.
Scheißer Quickfix.
Wir wollen...
Hardline wollen wir haben.
Beste.
Wie der nämlich spawnen ist.
Wir spielen
Hardline. Da kriegen wir den ganzen Shit.
Da kriegen wir den ganzen Shit früher.
Okay, weil aktuell kriegen wir
gar nichts früher, weil wir instant sterben
beim Spawn.
Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Wie sind das...
Shipment, ey. Shipment.
Der Spawn
da einfach hin haben. Ihr habt das gesehen?
Also die Map ist absolut unspielbarer
Shit.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Die Map ist wirklich
absolut unspielbar.
Die Loadout-Shops-Geschichte
finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Nicht hinter mir spawnen.
Alter! Mann!
Game!
Ah, ja, ja.
Ey.
Sieht das nicht nach Spaß aus, Leute?
Oh, mächtig
Spaß.
Mächtig Spaß.
Was?
Oh, Gott.
Bitte kein Shipment jetzt.
Bless RNG, Chat. Bless RNG.
Ah, ich...
Mir dämmert gerade was, als wir eben
Warzone gespielt haben.
Die sind da von links gekommen.
Das war ein Auftrag-Auftrag.
Auf uns, gell?
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Das habe ich gar nicht realisiert.
Da stand ja links...
Das leuchtet mir jetzt erst ein.
Da stand links Auftrag, dass sie einen Auftrag auf uns haben.
Und dass drei von drei ist.
Also sprich, dass die eigentlich auch schon da sind.
Deswegen war es total bescheuert,
dass ich da links und rechts rumgehampelt bin.
Das hätte ich sehen können.
Da hätte ich gesehen, dass die Gegner irgendwo am Start sind.
Direkt neben uns.
Och, nee.
Schon wieder.
Schlepplichst nicht.
Oh, je, oh, je, oh, je.
Hups.
Was?
Es ist wieder Shipment.
Meine Güte.
Ich will kein Shipment spielen.
Ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Nee, nee, ich kann den Filter...
Nein.
Ist das die einzige Map in dem Spiel?
Ich kann den Filter nicht anpassen.
Das sind alle Maps in der Rotation.
Drinnen.
Unter anderem Shipment.
Also, das ist Shoot...
Shoothouse, Shipment, Rust.
Und was ist es noch?
Ra...
Okay, Rust.
Rust, Shoothouse, Shipment und was noch?
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Oder nur die drei?
Wahrscheinlich sogar nur die drei.
Hardcore Ground War...
Oh, nee.
Das Beste an dem Modus ist ja,
dass man die Waffen schön anlockt.
Schnell anlockt.
Das haben wir ja mehr oder weniger.
Shoot...
Shoothouse ist richtig gut.
Am liebsten würde ich 24-7 Shoothouse spielen.
Ohne Scheiß.
Shoothouse ist die beste Map in dem Spiel.
Vielleicht Gunrunner noch.
Da sitzt er in der Hänge und wartet auf mich.
Geconfirmed.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich Hardline ausgerüstet, by the way?
Habe ich jetzt Hardline ausgerüstet?
Ah, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, exquisite, big brain, excellent Hardline.
Jetzt, jetzt...
What?
Rust is cancer...
Es ist alles in der Spielmodus...
In dem Spielmodus...
In der Liste...
Cancer außer Shoothouse.
Und Shoothouse ist äußerst nice.
Ah, Mistakt, ich kann ihn sprayen.
Geh mal auf Moab.
Da ist die Moab!
Da ist die Moab.
What the fuck?
Wo sind die alle?
Okay.
Letzte Runde, 57 Kills.
57 Kills.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Mal gucken, wie das diesmal läuft.
Hä?
Ah, rekt.
Die, die Waffe, die Pistole ist so übelst OP.
So geil.
So nice.
What?
Äh, 2 vs 2, kann man gleich spielen.
Einmal ein anderer Kollege da ist, mit dem ich sonst immer spiele.
What?
Was habe ich denn gekillt?
What the fuck?
Woher weiß er das?
Geconfirmed.
Leute, wir brauchen doch nur 8 Kills.
Dann werden sie wieder gebasht.
Das Todes.
Alter, Alter.
Der, oh, wir sind auch so, wir sind nur 4.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Easy.
Okay, so lohnt sich Hardcore natürlich nicht.
Okay.
Camp Position activated.
Zack.
Next.
Geh los.
Oh, Mist.
Okay, er hat es durchschaut.
Kann man, kann man da oben hin?
Oh Gott, er kommt ja gerade in dem Moment da oben durchgestellt.
Wie kommt man da hin?
Bringt die Pistole.
Mit der Pistole macht das übelst Bock.
Wenn man trifft.
Die Pistole ist so krass.
Das ist so nice.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Aus der Hüfte über die ganze Map.
Habt ihr das gesehen mit der Pistole?
Wow.
Der macht das gleiche wie ich.
Guckt.
Habt ihr das?
Die Pistole.
Wow.
Die Pistole, da brauchst du eigentlich gar keine Waffe.
Habt ihr das gesehen, Alter?
Fuck.
Wir aimen jetzt hier einfach.
Easy.
Ich spiele jetzt einfach Pistole only.
Easy win.
Einfach Pistole only.
Ah, shit, veraimt.
Moin, Loki Turner.
Laserpistole.
Das Ding ist OP, oder?
Das Ding ist echt OP.
Der Typ da oben geht mir voll auf den Keks.
Volle Pulle.
Da stehen sie.
Na, ich dachte, wir können aus der Hüfte sprayen mit der OP-Pistole.
Aber ich hab hier sogar Stimms bei.
Es ist verdammt schwer, hier Killstreaks zu machen, Leute.
What the fuck?
Das ist ja...
Wisst ihr, ohne Scheiß, der Spielmodus mit einfach ein paar guten Maps.
Und der Multiplayer könnte so gut sein.
Ups.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Fuck.
Schuss, weg.
Der hat auch die Akimbo-Renate hier am Start.
Der ist Big Brain.
Okay, wo gehen wir hin?
Ohne Mist, der Spielmodus.
Oder halt die Playlist mit gescheiten Maps.
Mit ein paar gescheiten Maps.
Und alles wär geil.
Oh, NA.
What the hell?
Den hab ich übelst enttäuscht.
Der NA aimt gerade.
Hier spielen halt alle ihre Sachen frei.
Aber Rust ist halt echt Cancer.
Haha, wie der gesprayt wurde.
Mit der Pistole hätte es besser funktioniert.
Fliegt mal den Hardcore raus.
Nee, du stirbst einfach selbst.
Das haben die ziemlich gut gemacht.
Du stirbst einfach selbst, wenn du zu viel Teamkillst.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich...
Moment, Moment.
big brain gewinnen wir wenigstens wir verlieren wir verlieren wir verlieren sagt aber gut weil
diese runde sind keine 57 zu 9 drin aber trotzdem okay wie kommt man darauf vielleicht jetzt eine
gute map please ich dachte es war ich es war einer mit mit der gleichen waffe lieber max
du musst patrouillieren das lernt man doch im top 10 tipps videos vom kaboom verdammt stimmt
hätte ich mal dran gedacht und wie geil wäre das wenn das spiel so aufgebaut wäre dass man
sowas hier noch machen könnte das wäre echt poggers meine sätze werden auch immer immer
low brain ige oder das wäre echt poggers
chat finde ich auch dass das echt poggers wäre nein wir spielen was normales ich muss
mein hirn mal wieder einschalten das problem ist dass alles andere in hardcore halt noch
verkämpfter ist also spielen wir eine runde hier wieder hier rege ich mich zwar immer über die maps
auf aber ich finde hier lässt es lässt sich irgendwie noch am angenehmsten spielen demolition
müsste doch glaube auch ganz gut sein oder demolition ist doch die
geschichte mit die cs go light geschichte mit bomben legen aber unendlich respawns
wenn ich mich noch richtig erinnern kann den ganzen kram da haben wir letzten hatte ich
letztens ein ziemlich cooles ziemlich gutes crash gameplay ich glaube auch irgendwie 45 8 oder so
rast rast sag mal will mich das game eigentlich heute verarschen will mich das game rollen jetzt
kommt ernsthaft rast sprengkommando rast
okay leute wir gehen jetzt aufs dach wo sind sie was war die andere decken
erwischt hat rast als geht es als gäbe es auf der welt
als gebe es auf der welt nichts anderes mehr super passt ja kein auf er wurde
gespont wird
ich bin verletzt ich bin verletzt ich bin verletzt
Ich beschütze dich, ich beschütze dich.
Headshot.
Nope.
Jetzt kommen hier die Moves.
Fuck.
Du guckst in die eine Richtung.
Mein Gott, wo hast du so eine Kack-Map?
Okay, ich bleibe jetzt hier drinnen gecampt.
Ah, shit.
Heartbeat-Sensor sagt einfach gar nichts, obwohl die ganze Map voll ist.
Auch geil.
What?
Ah, mein Team hält nicht.
Aber du kannst hier echt krass spawn-trappen.
Immer noch, immer noch.
Immer noch.
Ja, ist echt so.
Theoretisch hättest du die einmal drinnen hier.
Wo ist denn der Typ?
Alter, ich war doch schon um die Ecke.
Gibt es noch andere MW2-Maps?
Ähm.
Eine gute Frage.
Gibt es noch...
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Oder?
Gibt es noch andere MW2-Maps?
Vakant ist Cod 4.
Vakant, oder wie auch immer man die ausspricht, ist Cod.
What?
Renetti hat er mich.
100 Pro.
Wart's mal ab.
Ja?
Nee.
WTF.
Ah, die Dudes, ja.
What?
Barro.
Rusts.
Ja, in Warsong gibt es jede Menge, das stimmt.
Ich mache mir die Klasse-Klein nochmal mit Hardline.
Gerade in so Spielmodi ist Hardline einfach gut.
Weil wenn die hier... Hier gewinnen die Killstreaks halt die Games auch.
What?
What the hell?
Ich habe einen Wielse am Start.
Wie toll.
Okay, Leute, jetzt kommt alles raus.
Scheiß drauf. Last-Den-Minute. Jetzt kommt alles raus.
Jetzt kommt alles raus. Gib alles.
Oh, hat mich zephiert.
Das hat er gut gemacht.
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur, ja?
Klar.
Wir kannten uns ja vorher schon.
Und wir kennen uns ja...
Ja, das ist immer noch so.
Man kennt sich halt. Man kennt sich.
Okay.
Die Runde ist immer wieder ganz gut abgegangen.
Wer hat gesagt, Rust ist eine gute Map für Sprengkommando?
Infinity Ward.
Und Infinity Ward hat sich sehr viele merkwürdige Sachen gedacht.
In diesem Game.
Wir wollen wieder Videos mit dem Friseur.
Der Friseur, der ist mittlerweile ultra-casual geworden.
Der spielt Mobile Games.
Und das war's.
Mobile Games.
What?
What the fuck?
Das Game.
Du weißt überhaupt nicht, von wo was kommt, ja?
Der ballert hier gleich voll rein.
Ich muss hier hinten halten, Alter.
Kommt nix.
Alter!
Das hatte ich überhaupt nicht vor.
Meine Güte, kann ich mal sterben?
WTF? Ich stand drei Milliarden Stunden im Gegnerspawn.
What the fuck?
Rust!
Please!
Deswegen habe ich ein großes Magazin drin, ne?
Oh, wie sie reinlaufen.
So macht Call of Duty doch Spaß.
Wow, wow.
Ah, fuck.
Da werden sie weggebashed, Alter.
Guckt sie euch an!
Da werden sie so geschreckt.
Hast du was mit Swift zu tun gehabt?
Nee.
Ich hab da nix mit gemacht.
Die werden so zerstört.
So muss das sein.
So mag ich das.
Oh, fuck.
Swift?
Ey, ja, was ich bisher gesehen hab, muss ich sagen,
hat's auch einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Warum kann Call of Duty nicht immer so sein?
Einfach, einfach schnelle, schnelle Action
mit ein bisschen,
mit teilweise ein bisschen sinnvoll laufen.
So macht es doch Spaß.
So macht es doch Spaß, ey.
Demolition, guter, guter Spielmodus.
Naja, eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich ist Demolition kein guter Spielmodus auf der Map.
Meinung zu Unreal Engine 5?
Richtig nice.
Okay, Leute.
Ich spiel ein paar Two-on-Two's.
Gleich.
Ups. Oh, fuck.
Eins versus eins.
Ih, Headquarters.
Headquarters?
Moment, warum?
Sag mal.
What the fuck?
Ich kann nix schreiben auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Ohne, dass das rumspackt.
Warum hab ich denn jetzt auf einmal Headquarters?
Hab ich nicht gesagt, ich will Demolition spielen?
Ach nee, ich hab mich verklickt.
Klar, ich hab nicht Demolition ausgewählt.
Erstmal.
Options, Audio.
Enabled.
Zack.
Lässt mich?
Ja, was?
Ja, lass mal ingame voice machen.
Ich hab kein TS installiert hier.
Und ähm...
Discord können wir dann nachmachen.
Discord können wir dann auf irgendeinen...
Wir können auf meinen Discord, da hab ich ja einen privaten Channel.
Da könnten wir rein.
Ich hab sonst auch nen Discord.
Ja, lass uns mal die Runde mit ingame voice machen.
Okay, ich mach dann auf automatisch.
Wir haben noch 14 Minuten, haben wir noch XP-Boost.
Jawoll.
So, Chat. Jetzt kommen die
Two-on-Two Kings.
Und äh...
No-Loss heute.
No-Loss-Stream.
Wenn du willst, kannst du machen.
Dann kann ich dich nachher hosten.
Ich mach mal kurz bisschen lauter.
Ich mach mal Licht an.
Wobei, eigentlich nicht.
Oh, Bazaar. Schöne Map.
T-Fuck.
Ach, du bist gerade ja live. Grüße an alle.
Hi.
Ja.
X-Screen-Line, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
So.
Die Gegner hören uns jetzt nicht, oder?
Also...
Äh, doch, wenn wir sterben, hören die uns.
Aber wir sterben ja nicht.
Nee. Aber nur kurz, oder?
Okay, ich spiel jetzt
und mach danach den Stream.
Ja.
Ich push mal rechts rum.
Crossbow, beste Waffe.
Können wir da überrennen, oder was?
Oh, fuck, ich bin down.
Excellent.
Da haben wir wieder
die Pros am Start.
Und ich hab nicht Ironsight gemacht, weil ich Battlefield-Kack-Noob bin.
Nice, easy win.
Easy, easy.
Ja, gleich, 0 HD holt gleich auf.
Dann mit 0 HD
zu 0 4K, dann ist vorbei.
So, jetzt jumpshotten wir sie.
So, einer links.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Ah, veraimt.
Einer ist rechts, ja.
Okay, ich brauch gescheite Waffe.
Schön den Kopf geballert.
So, was haben wir denn da jetzt?
Salt Rifle, Kurzvariante.
Einer ist rechts.
Nee, doch jetzt.
Mein Gott, Alter!
Warum treff ich grad nix?
Du machst das schon.
Guck mal hier, 4-0.
0-3.
Cool, der Chat, der...
Der ist links, links, links.
Ah, da ist der.
Mit dem Equip. Ach, die Kost.
Ah, da.
Er hat 0 HP.
Ja.
In den Arsch geschossen.
Guck mal unsere Damage an, bitte.
Einmal nur kurz fürs Protokoll.
26. Fuck.
So, einen hab ich.
Links.
Oh, fuck. Ich flash ihn.
Hab ihn nicht gesehen, aber ich glaub er ist da.
Ja. Ist weg.
Achso, ich war komplett blind, ja.
Ich seh's einfach mal reingehalten, ne.
Jetzt werd ich hier schon geflamed,
weil ich nicht den Chat lese während der Runde, Alter.
Mein Gott, ich schieß zu schnell
mit den Kackpistols, ey.
Besser zielen.
Chat-Aufwärmrunde.
Ich hab 7 Ampere, 100, das ist schwer.
Ah.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt.
Meine Meinung zu Valorant.
Mehr CS als Overwatch.
Und zugucken tu ich ganz gern,
gespielt hab ich's noch nicht.
Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich hab's gespielt, Jo.
Der rechts hat dick Hit.
Ja, der links, ich bin rot.
Links ist halt auch low.
Ja, du machst das schon.
Ja.
Oh, je.
Der Rotzeit ist halt ziemlich schwer.
Ja, ich merk's.
Wenn einer Count wird, ist Valorant.
Ich hab noch einen.
Oh.
Links ist low.
Okay.
Easy Clap, genau.
Ass Little Bitcher.
Was?
Was ist denn das für ein hässliches Ding?
Einer spielt rechts.
Ich geb ihm...
Er hat 20 HP.
Daumen Shotgang, quasi.
Der Letzte hat 20 HP.
Den hast du.
Nein.
Ich hab nicht mitgekriegt,
dass der rübergekommen ist.
Aber als ob du da One-Hit bist.
Von der Range.
Die Dinger sind sau inkonsistent.
Manchmal brauchst du zwei Schuss.
Ich hab ihm Hit gegeben, aber er...
Ich hab rechts nen Laser gesehen.
Ich glaub, es campt einer rechts.
Kann sein.
Ich komm jetzt zu dir.
Einer kommt links von uns.
Einer ist rumgeflankt zu uns hinten.
Fuck, Alter. Die sind nicht schlecht.
5-5.
Letzte Runde.
Team Einkaufen gegen T-Fuck.
Zeig mal.
Stimmt.
Okay, jetzt muss man...
Okay, was gibt's jetzt?
Egal. Das ist unsere Runde.
Hab ihn.
Wo ist der andere?
Andere ist rechts hinten.
Ist geflasht.
Nein.
Nice.
Alter, 11. Der Carry ist hart, ey.
Da brennt er.
Easy clap. Easy clap.
Eat ass, bitch.
Way too easy.
Okay, wollen wir kurz abbrechen?
Und Discord anmachen?
Jawoll.
Oh, wir haben schon nächstes Game.
Wollen wir die noch machen oder raus?
Lass kurz raus.
Das hört sich besser an, glaub ich.
Dann mach ich auch kurz meine Sachen.
Oh, fuck.
Ich hoffe, ich hab nicht den falschen Channel auf.
Wir haben so einen Channel,
da spammen die Leute irgendwelche komischen
Hentai-Bildchen rein.
Das ist schlecht, wenn ich den jetzt auf hab im Stream.
Okay, Moment, Moment.
Ich bin in... welchem Kanal muss ich denn?
Okay.
Nee, wir sind...
Ich überleg gerade,
wo sind wir denn?
Bist du General in Voice Chat?
Oder ist das jemand anderes?
Ich bin gerade im Stream.
Ach so, sorry.
Danach aber gerne.
Wir können nachher in Führer Warsong spielen.
Ja, um wie viel Uhr circa?
Ich schreib dir, ich weiß noch nicht.
Vielleicht so eine halbe Stunde.
Alles klar, cool.
Komm, äh, äh,
Linus, wir gehen wieder raus.
Mhm.
Okay.
Meine L-Kumpels,
die wissen nichts.
Bist du das im
General?
Ja, ja, ich bin im Discord schon bei dir.
Äh, zieh, dann zieh ich dich...
Ja, ja, ich zieh, ich zieh...
Was, im Lava stellst?
Ah, da.
Ich zieh dich mal hoch, ich zieh dich mal kurz hoch.
Jawohl, ich zieh dich.
Äh, wie gehen das jetzt gescheit?
Wie kann ich dich jetzt moven, äh?
Ah, jetzt. Oder?
Hä?
Okay, wie fandst du das?
Ich hab keine Permission.
Ja, ja, ich move dich rein.
Passt doch.
Nee, ich kann nicht reden.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, jetzt darfst du.
Hallo?
Gut, dann machen wir jetzt mal aus, ingame.
Jawoll, jawoll, so.
Perfekt.
Excellent.
Okay, kannst suchen.
Ich mach dich jetzt noch ein bisschen lauter hier.
So, jetzt bin ich da.
Ich mach mal noch mein ingame aus.
Ja, Discord Overlay, das ist ja voll pro hier.
1337.
Extrem Elite.
Hab ich jetzt ausgemacht?
Push to talk, jawoll.
Ich baller mal schnell meinen Stream noch an.
Ich hab deinen Stream gar nicht auf.
Ja,
muss ja auch nicht, außer dass es mehr laggt.
Bei dir dann...
Ich brauch halt einen Nachteil, sonst haben die Gegner keine Chance, was?
Ich seh's schon, ja.
Wenn ich Stream an hab, dann wird das ganze vielleicht
10% schlechter.
Ähm, encodest du mit
einer Grafikkarte, oder machst du über CPU?
Ähm, wahrscheinlich
wäre Grafikkarte sinnvoller, oder?
Ja, ich habs auch grade über CPU.
Ich müsste eigentlich auch auf Grafikkarte mal umstellen fürs spielen.
Doof Frage,
Weißt du ganz schnell, wie man das macht?
Was? Grafikkarte? Encoding?
Nee, du musst in den Settings auf NVN umstellen.
Aber lass das mal.
Hat aber gut funktioniert, gestern.
Ich habe jetzt auch seit heute 50 MB statt 25 Upload.
Was das Ganze auch noch einfacher macht.
Vodafone.
Vodalow.
Ich rede angeblich ingame. Warum das?
Ich habe so ausgeschaltet.
Ja, weil du Open Mic hattest.
Hatte ich.
Ist das ein Bug?
Ich habe meinen Stream jetzt auch mal an.
Pog.
PogChamp meinst du?
Ja.
Ich verlinke dich mal kurz im Chat.
Und falls einer aus deiner Position
sehen will.
Sportstream geht erst ab Partner.
Aber dafür brauche ich noch ein paar mehr Subs.
Einer reicht nicht, oder wie?
Oh, Alter.
Nein, so meine ich das nicht.
Jetzt hatte ich jetzt 2 MB für die übelste Flamme.
Ein Partner reicht nicht.
Also es reicht nicht.
Ich dachte gerade.
Ja gut, bei dem anderen weiß ich ja nicht, wie viel es sind.
So, vielleicht 2.
Ich dachte gerade, jetzt kommt der Full Front,
weil es zu viel COD spielt.
Ne, ne.
Oh, Gunfight. Endlich gute Map dafür.
Sepp Muller.
Ist doch Hill geworden.
Ich gehe mal raus. Ich hasse Hill.
Du auch.
I. Ja.
Hill ist die größte Kack-Map.
Die schlimmste Tour-Map überhaupt.
So, mal gucken.
Pine.
Ja, wird
erinnert sich eh, ja.
Shipment.
Ey, Shipment hat mich heute fertig gemacht.
Ich habe Waffen gelevelt on Stream, ey.
Ich habe für den Stream noch nicht meine Ding geändert.
Den Filter habe ich noch nicht reingemacht.
Weil ich vorher noch nicht die Zeit dafür hatte.
Das heißt, wenn Mittelpunkt schlecht ist, dann tut es mir leid.
Ne, ne, es passt.
Oder Leute, versteht man alles gut?
Chat.
Null Zuschauer, deswegen
wirkt hier niemand.
Aber für die,
was alles für die Wort.
So, ich, ich, ich bleibe mal links drauf.
Ich gehe direkt hoch in der ersten Runde.
Okay, ich, ich, ich halte mal links und dann gehe ich weiter vor.
Okay, links kommt nix.
Jemand in der Mitte, einer oben.
Okay, die haben es abgeähmt.
Einer hüpft hoch, einer auch hoch.
Ich glaube, ich war hinter dir.
Und eine andere war.
Fuck, ich wollte um die Ecke laufen, voll dämlich hängen geblieben.
Naja.
Da ist er.
Die haben einfach das abgeähmt.
Leute, ist es zu laut oder passt die Discord-Lautstärke?
Ich habe es nicht eingestellt.
Sorry, Jungs.
Links, links, links.
Einer wieder oben.
Oh, der eine ist links.
Linke Seite, außen.
Bei ihnen im Spawn.
Oh, Decoy.
Big Brain.
Shit.
Die wollen es wissen.
da aber wieder pro pro pro ja leute die übelst geübt haben schon einer kommt
links bin geflasht nein ich hab da ist im sparen bei uns ich habe gar die waffe
geswitcht auf schottland was ich soll ein bisschen lauter machen
chat okay das gewinn war noch ich muss jetzt aber was killen für drei kilometer
so ich bleibe links drauf also die haben irgendwas also ich sehe links
was ist das denn
einer ist dauernd
da ist im small ring glaube ich ja der hat es im container unter dir
ja
der hat sich auch gedacht der fahrt
run
Das ist ja ne übelst reutige Waffe hier, oder?
Revolvo.
Siehst du links was?
Shit.
Ah, mit meinen eigenen Waffen.
Fuck.
Ah, stehen wir mal getroffen.
Aber neues Headset kommt ja.
Ich hab's ja bestellt, hast du ja wohl gesehen.
Dann wird alles wieder gut.
Das ist, da hast du viel Spaß mit.
Ich glaub's auch.
Ich glaub, dass dieses Geld es wert war.
Ich lauf mal vor.
Einer down mit dem Spawn.
Lulladee wieder am Carryen.
Fast schon auf 4k hoch.
Fußbässe.
Das Ding shaket aber richtig.
Das hat doch aber auch nen Flashy-Skin.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Erwartet's.
Er steht hinten im Spawn.
Fuck.
Oh, das war so close.
Ich hab den auch 2-3 mal getroffen.
Das war ein Treffer oder so, der noch gefehlt hat.
Ich komm noch nicht ganz auf diese Mikrolex klar durchs Stream.
Ich muss echt auf die Kraka umstellen.
Was'n das?
What the fuck?
Was'n das für'n Ding?
Nee, nie.
Willst du auf Grafikkarte umstellen?
Ja.
Okay, dann mach ich's mal ganz kurz.
Das bringt richtig was.
Einstellen und Ausgabe.
Kodiere Software N-Weg.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Ich sag's dir gleich.
Geh mal kurz aus der Que raus.
Du musst eh den Stream neu starten.
Hab ich schon gemacht.
Ich glaub ich hab's.
Kodiere auf N-Weg.
Ja, aber ich glaube da war noch irgendwas.
Warte mal. Output?
Ah, ich kann das nicht nachgucken.
Software oder Hardware hab ich.
Und wo kannst du N-V-Eng auswählen?
Bei Hardware.
Ja, dann ist das das Richtige.
Du musst bloß gucken, dass du Bitrate und so ordentlich dann hochstellst.
Bitrate hab ich auf Max.
Ah nee, 320.
Okay, ich versuch's mal so.
Moment, wie viel Bitrate hast du denn?
320 steht da.
Was? Nee.
Also Bitrate hab ich beim Video 5100.
Das kannst du machen, ja.
Ja, ich versuch's jetzt mal.
Das ist okay.
Ihr könnt mir, wenn irgendjemand zuschaut,
könnt ihr mir gerne sagen kurz, ob das funktioniert.
Nur als Hilfe.
Ihr müsst doch nicht dableiben, keine Angst.
X-Screen Lion,
ich stream nicht zu festen Zeiten,
aber in letzter Zeit relativ häufig tatsächlich.
Also ich such noch mal.
Ich hab aber keine festen Zeiten.
Es sieht Stand jetzt richtig gut aus
mit den Lags.
Okay.
Achso, schön.
Ja, aber ich warte erst mal, bis es in dem geht,
bevor ich schaue.
Weißt du noch, wie er mit Vodafone
vorgestern, wo es erstmal
Packet-Loss hatte?
Erster Tag neue Leitung und direkt hat's
nicht funktioniert, danke.
Pine, willst du spielen?
Ah ja, lass, komm.
Gegen chinesische Zeichen.
Gegen chinesische Zeichen und Playstation-Controller, auf geht's.
Oh.
Maus auf Playstation, hi.
Startet das jetzt?
Sollte, jetzt launchen.
Ne, die haben keinen Bock mehr.
Die haben LulHD gesehen
und haben gedacht...
Die wussten gleich, die haben KeckW.
Was sagst du,
LulW oder KeckW, was besser?
Ich sag LulW.
Ja, ich auch. Gut, sind wir uns einig.
Chat, seh dir mal.
LulW für immer.
LulW ist das Beste.
KeckW irgendwie, ich find LulW geht leichter über die Zunge.
Das stimmt, ja.
Oh, gegen
Lackpain.
Lackpain und Abtun.
Sag mal, wir haben echt zu viel gewonnen, oder?
Wir kriegen jetzt nur die mit doppeltem Clan-Tag
und übelste Pronames.
Aber wir sind halt
einfach zu gut.
Wir haben ja auch verdammt
oft gewonnen, die letzten
Tage, ne?
Oh, es fühlt sich eindeutig
besser an, als...
Man merkt's leicht, dass Stream an ist.
Aber ich hab auf einmal auch doppelt so viel
FPS.
Einer ist glaub ich rechts.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Ja, oha!
Ach man, einer links im Spawn hinten.
Er ist runtergegangen.
Ich seh niemand. Warte, wenn mich schon jemand reingekommt.
So.
Okay, jetzt bin ich voll da.
So kann man ja spielen.
Warum hat mir das niemand früher gesagt?
Niemand sagt mir das.
Könnt ihr mal bei ihm gucken. Oh, oh, oh.
Nice.
Könnt ihr mal bei ihm gucken, ob's wenigstens okay aussieht jetzt.
Also, Ton wird
gefixt in ein bis drei Tagen.
Beziehungsweise relativ bald.
Aber sollte
eigentlich so gehen, oder?
Ich hab auch 60 FPS umgestellt.
Oh, fuck, ich hab fett hit.
Linke Seite, Spawn ist einer.
Nice, einer is hot.
Ich flash mal rüber.
Ah, fuck,
nix gesehen. Wat? Ab jetzt, jetzt wird's...
Der Gaming-Stuhl richtig platziert.
Plationiert.
Ich muss dieses
komische Visier auch mal umschalten.
Ah ne, wir haben ja ne neue Waffe.
Die 21 Schuss
9mm Pistola.
Einer, einer ist noch links hinten.
Einer, ich hab da.
Ich flash mal rüber. Oh Gott.
Ich hab einen Flash gehettet.
Na, eine kommt im Spawn.
Ich hab richtig schlecht gespielt. Einer unter dir.
Links von dir.
Das geht so nicht.
Die machen das clever.
Aber ich bin gerade auch gefühlt
richtig lost.
Ja, erst mal warm werden.
Die erste Runde war richtig gut.
Aber
sobald's human ist, hat man so Vorvögel.
Ja, rechts, rechts, rechts
einer hier im... Alter.
Die gehen ab.
Die gehen voll ab.
Aio.
Ähm...
Okay, ordentliche Waffe.
Ich aim mal rechts ab.
Der kommt dann bestimmt wieder lang.
Einer ist in der Mitte.
Mitte oben glaub ich.
Tot.
Wenn wir ein bisschen schimmeln,
dann haben wir die.
Ja, ich bleib hinten.
Bleib mal bei dir einfach.
Ich guck mal links.
Okay.
Gut.
Nice.
Okay, ich peak jetzt gleich mal hier aus dem Spawn raus.
Mal gucken.
Ich glaub, ich hab mein Audio auch bisschen laut.
Einer hat gut Hit.
Ah, LOLHD.
LOLHD, einfach der beste Teammate, den's gibt.
Der zeigt nur rot an,
wenn man Headshot-Kill macht, oder?
Weil das davor waren auch welche.
Sonst hätte es irgendwie auf keinen Sinn ergeben.
Das ist wie im Battlefield.
Der Kill hat eine andere Farbe.
Einer links in der Mitte.
Fuck.
Der hat einen Hit, der kommt vorgepusht in unseren Spawn.
Hau ihn.
Anderer hat auch Low.
Der ist in unseren Spawn.
Shit.
So langsam wird's aber echt schwierig, ja.
Hab keine Ahnung.
Sobald der Stream angeht, kommen Götter.
Ja, ist echt so, ne?
Okay, okay.
Okay, ich glaub, der eine pusht rechts lang.
Einer oben. Hab ihn.
Ist der oben oder unten?
Unten rechts im Container.
Was ist das für eine Waffe? Der kommt jetzt durch.
Der ist voll mit der Waffe, ey.
Holy crap, was macht der denn?
Hä?
Jetzt hab ich ihn verloren. Das ist natürlich schlecht.
Ah, shit.
Ich hab zweimal voll vorbeigeschossen,
weil ich gedacht hab, das Ding schießt schneller,
als es letztendlich geschossen hat.
Aber wie kam er da so schnell raus
und nach oben?
Hm.
Okay, Shotgun.
Brauchen wir.
Und Pistole.
Hoch mit raus.
Das ist richtig scheiße.
Shit.
Einer war hinten rechts.
Einer ist unten.
Was für hinten rechts?
Egal, aufwärmen, aufwärmen.
Echt zu.
Hat niemand gesehen, tut eh keiner zu.
Scheiße.
Äh, you know what?
Brexit is good.
Jetzt werden sie geflamed.
Man kann die immer triggern.
Ich hör die gar nicht.
Ich hab das aus.
Ich will das Gelaber gar nicht hören.
Er hat gesagt, you know what, you guys are shit.
Brexit was good.
Ähm.
Lohnt sich XP-Boost
bei 2-on-2? Nee, oder?
Also, theoretisch lohnt sich das
überall, aber...
Nee, mach schon einen anderen.
Ich hab halt noch eins, vier...
Wieder Playstation.
Ich hab halt elf Stück.
Deswegen.
Ja, weil ich...
Man gewöhnt sich an diese leichten
Lags beim Spielen.
Das ist nicht krass, aber...
Sollte aber eigentlich spätestens, wenn...
Äh, hast du OBS offen oder minimiert?
Ja, hab ich offen. Soll ich minimieren?
Mach mal minimiert, ja.
Dann seh ich halt
100% nicht...
Kann aber echt sein.
Weil dann seh ich halt, boah, wenn das das jetzt ist...
Dann ist das einfach.
Ich hab keinen Chat auf und sowas.
Außer auf dem Handy links neben mir.
Deswegen, falls jemand was schreibt...
Hi.
So. Komm, ich push jetzt mal rechts oben durch.
Oder willst du?
Du hast recht.
Es gibt gar keinen Lack mehr, seitdem es zu ist.
Und uns?
Boah.
Komm mal zurück. Da ist einer drin.
Ich muss gucken, dass der andere nicht von hinten kommt.
Down.
Wo ist der andere? Hat der im Spawn gestanden?
Nein.
Ähm, weiß nicht, aber...
Ja, doch.
Ja, gut.
Hey, aber wenn OBS minimiert ist, ist alles weg.
Dann ist es doch nice.
Dann kannst du jetzt hardcore carryen.
Das wird gemacht, Chef.
Boah, ich werd von zwei Seiten...
Nein!
Alter, warum sacke ich gerade so?
Ist ja hardcore, ey.
Kein LOL-HD.
Vor allem kein 4K.
Der hat er schon.
Der andere ist voll.
Ah.
Ist das Auto in Luft geflogen?
Top-Kick.
Ui.
Das hat er aber gut gemacht.
Nice, Nate.
Das ist dieser Sniper.
Egal.
Also links sehe ich nichts.
Zack.
Ja, mein Health ist schön.
Letzte.
Ich glaube, der ist rechts hier drinnen bei mir.
Ich höre den.
Oben oder unten?
Der kommt, glaube ich, gerade hoch.
Tatsächlich, ich hole ihn dir.
Jawoll, oh.
Schöne Bait und Switch.
Das haben wir schön abgesprochen.
Echt schöner Bait und Switch.
Ich muss mehr ein undseits machen.
Ich habe echt so dieses Battlefield-Ding.
Hüfte-Pistole.
Rechts ist einer im Spawn hinten.
Einer ist oben.
Ich komme mal mit zu dir hoch.
Wollen wir mal aimen, dass keiner rüberkommt.
Oh, ich habe mir gerade so einen Healthshot reingezogen.
Aber unten ist er.
Wo gehst du denn hin?
Kumpel.
Oh, oh, der andere ist auch noch hinten.
Habt ihr noch einen Healthshot rein?
Ja, ja.
Ich gehe unten an die Tür.
Ich weiß nicht, wo er ist.
Oben, bei ihm im Spawn.
Ich nehme einen.
Oder lass mal einen.
Okay.
Ui.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wo er abgedampft ist.
Flitz, flitz, flitz.
Ja, ja, ja.
Hast ja recht.
Ist der Burst?
Ja.
Einer geht links oben und einer geht rechts.
Wow.
Across-Map headshotted.
Einer rechts hinten bei dem Spawn.
Einer ist links hochgegangen.
Nice.
Hey.
Ich habe ihn einfach fast across the map gefroren.
Nice.
Ich liebe dieses Spiel.
Aber die Waffe ist echt richtig krass.
Ich habe ihn gefroren knifed einfach.
Oh, einer im Spawn.
Scheiße.
Ich gehe oben ans Fenster.
Ja, ich habe 50 HP.
Einer hat Hit auf der linken Seite außen.
Okay.
Ich habe ihn immer getroffen diesmal.
Einen habe ich.
Schön, ich habe Low HP.
Er kommt hier unten, glaube ich.
Ja.
Nice.
Hast du gerade nah gekämpft?
Nein, nein.
Ah, Shotgun.
Bam.
Also, wenn das kein One-It ist, was dann?
Well played, dudes.
Ne, einer noch.
Ich halte den trotzdem schon mal.
Die spielen es echt nicht schlecht.
Fühlt sich nicht an wie 5-2.
Die sind, glaube ich, alle beide links gegangen.
Links? Was ist denn das für ein blauer Laser?
Noch nie gesehen. Irgend so ein Skin.
Ach, das sind Tracer.
Oh mein Gott.
Wo war er?
Links oben im Haus.
Kannst auch Shift drücken, dann hast du Iron Scythe.
Aber lohnt sich nicht so.
Er hat 30 HP.
Du hast schon einen Molotov.
Viel zu hoch.
Er weiß jetzt, wo du hingehst.
Der letzte sollte an der Flagge jetzt sein.
Ungefähr.
Aber kein Safe-Cross.
Wenn er jetzt...
Da hast du gerade einen Hitmarker bekommen, oder?
Hol es dir.
Hol es dir, die Flagge.
Ich habe einen Hitmarker bekommen.
Ich wusste aber, ein Nullwurer ist...
Ja, beim Auto war der wahrscheinlich.
Win. So muss das sein.
GG.
420 Damage.
Oh, das ist ja was.
Hättest du jetzt, wenn du noch 69 Damage hättest, hätten wir die ganzen
Beam-Damage-Zahlen durch.
Dann hätten wir aber nicht gewonnen.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Ja, 669
wäre auch okay.
Oh, Shipman ist heute...
Es klebt an mir.
Ja, ich sehe es, wie Hill an dir klebt.
Oh.
Sollen wir?
Sind das die gleichen von eben?
Ja.
Oh man.
Chat, das ist die größte
Ice-Map in diesem Spielmodus.
Der eine ist raus.
Ich glaube eher, dass er noch connected ist.
Die müssen ja zusammen gesucht haben.
Der wird jetzt ja nicht sein Mate einfach lassen, oder?
Oder doch?
Nein.
Ich dachte schon. Drauf.
Einer meiner war einfach volle Kanne drauf,
aber zählt nicht.
Einer hat Hit.
Einer ist hinter mir irgendwo.
Jawohl.
Der andere war, glaube ich, hinter mir her.
Alter, ich komm nicht klar. Der ist ganz rechts außen.
Ganz rechts außen war der.
Da, da wo du hinguckst.
Ja, da. Irgendwo da.
Nice.
Ich hab den anderen einfach geschlagen,
als er auf dem Boden lag.
Komm, wir pushen da jetzt mal durch.
Rechts, rechts ist einer.
Hier steht auch einer in der Mitte.
Hat dick, hat gut Hit.
Ich seh ihn nicht.
Am Turm, am Turm war der.
Ich bin im Sworn.
Ah ja, ich seh ihn. Einer dürfte down sein.
Ja.
Schön.
Pass mal auf.
Hüfte.
Aber aus der Entfernung geht das, oder?
Gegen gute Gegner nicht.
Deine beste Waffe.
Was ist das denn für ein Shotgun?
Sieht so richtig aus.
Ist bei dem Spawn-Hitten am gut Hit.
Ja, okay.
Der eine hat mich gepre-aimt.
Da konnte ich leider nichts machen.
Wow.
Machst du.
Beide One-Hit.
So hat das sein HP.
Fuck.
Nochmal?
Gleiche.
Was ist das für ein Shotgun?
Ist die auf Long-Range?
Ich seh nix.
Werden wahrscheinlich im Spawn campen, weil wir immer drauf gerannt sind.
Ich werf mal, ich werf mal ganz hinten den Spawn.
Ne?
Nix erwischt?
Ich seh absolut niemand.
Steht mich mal hin.
Auch nicht.
Ich guck mal nach links, also.
Ah, ich seh einen links laufen.
Links im Wald.
Ich push mal links rüber.
Nice, ich hab ihn gesehen, wie er umgekippt ist.
Der andere ist hinter mir.
Der war direkt hinter mir.
Ach, meine Fresse.
Warum bin ich so scheiße grad?
Warum kämpfe ich überhaupt gegen den in dieser scheiß Pose hier?
Richtig bescheuert.
Er ist hinterm Felsen.
Da kann ich ja nicht großartig was machen.
Einsicht ist der erste Weg zur besseren Runde, sagt meine Mutter immer.
Einer an dem...
Ich flash mal rüber.
Ich hab schon einen richtig dicken Hit drin.
Ja, ich auch.
Aber der andere hat 50 HP minus.
Hab ihn.
Eine...
Oh.
Was machst du da?
Oh, doch.
Weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Auch nicht.
Ich schleich mal ein bisschen.
50 HP.
Hast du geflasht?
Ne.
Wow.
Der ist von links gekommen, der Molotow.
Von links angeflogen.
Da, wo der Turm ist.
Von unserem Spawnhaus links.
Am Turm, ja.
Turm ist das einzige, was man sich da merken kann.
Ich hab gerade die Offenbarung,
wie es einfach gut läuft.
Beide rechts.
Hab keine Chance gegen zwei.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
was meine Shortcuts zum Distributen sind.
Beide waren vorher da rechts, ja.
Rechts vielleicht schon, ja.
Schön.
Du hast mehr HP, du hast mehr HP.
Aber oben der über...
Fuck, man.
Wenn du angeschossen wirst,
dass du nicht wie so ein aufgescheuchtes Reh
einfach in Schusslinie weg rennst.
Direkt hinlegen oder weg.
Irgendwie so zur Seite.
Da hat der volles Schussfeld.
Scheiße.
Easy.
Ah, helpst dem.
Bist du, guckst du links?
Einer läuft links. Ich habe ihn links lang laufen sehen.
Ich seh ihn nicht links.
Ich seh halt echt niemand.
Einer ist im Spawn hinten.
Linke Seite von dir.
Ja, scheiße.
Hol ihn dir.
Jawoll.
Oh Gott, warum sehe ich so eine Scheiße nicht?
Vielleicht bin ich zu lang schon on, ey.
Ich bin fast sechs Stunden on wieder.
Echt?
Ja, ja.
Wer hält das denn sechs Stunden aus?
Wir haben auch einen Granat.
Wir haben auch einen Noobtube.
Ey, wir gewinnen jetzt erst mal.
Klar, only wins.
Ich nade ihn mal tot.
Okay, hab nicht geglaubt.
Ah, da.
Wo ist denn der?
Im Spawn?
Hinter dem Truck, im Spawn.
Sehe aber nicht, wo er ist.
Er wirft was.
Okay, hinter dem Truck gucke ich jetzt.
Ah, ich seh ihn.
Okay, nice. Den haben wir.
Jetzt guck mal an, wie ich ihn ein bisschen disrespected habe.
Den Arsch.
Okay, okay.
Ich geh mal wieder ganz rechts.
Und zack, und zack.
Ja, rechts.
Rechts ist er.
Einer.
Der hat aber auch schon einen Hit drin.
Oh.
Genau, der hat schon einen Treffer drin.
Äh.
Minus 30 ist halt Schmutz.
Haha.
Oh man.
Da wird hardcarried.
Das hat er sich auch noch vorgestellt.
Ja, ich höre immer diese Kommunikation von ihm.
Ich höre immer diese Kommunikation von ihm.
Ja, der hat schon einen, der hat schon einen.
Matchpoint.
Das sind Direktolen.
Links könnte dumm sein, aber lass mal da smoken.
Da kommen die Foreigners schon.
Ich smoke mal da ab, vielleicht können wir dann hoch gehen.
Ich versuch's einfach mal.
Was soll's.
Ich renn einfach mal durch den Spawn.
Ich guck nicht, ob die da sind.
Ich hab rechts geguckt.
Ich bin mit dem Spawn. Hinter ihm.
Hinter ihm.
Wo der andere ist.
Links, links, am Wall.
Ich wollte ihn mit dem Foreigner verwerfen, weil ich zu arrogant bin, aber du da den machtest.
Ah, war echt arrogant.
Hui.
Well played dudes, this time really.
Wächst.
Ne, ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das 6 Stunden aushält.
Chat, keine Ahnung, wie hab ich das gemacht?
Es waren ein paar richtig coole, normale Multiplayer-Games dabei.
Sollen wir weiterspielen?
Ja, ja. Wir können ruhig noch ein bisschen...
Ja, so eine halbe Stunde oder so
krieg ich noch hin.
Also, man muss ja sagen,
Rust, was war das?
Ich glaub Rust Demolition
Hardcore, oder was war das?
Ich krieg's immer zusammen. Das war übelst
übelst krass.
Wie toll, Doppel
Doppel Wilson am Start
und innerhalb von irgendwie einer halben Minute
Fitch Kills.
Das war unnormal.
Warum ist eigentlich nur mit Shoot House nur eine gescheite Map
in dieser Rotation?
Ja, klar.
Ich hab gerade nur ganz kurz mein Relive gecheckt.
Was?
Ist das ein Ball Action?
Ja, ja, klar.
Links guckt einer.
Aber wo?
Jetzt zwei...
Da.
Da kommt er, gehüpft.
Okay, das weiß ich, ob wir das gleich nochmal machen können.
Ich guck mal rechts wieder.
Ja, ja, rechts guckt einer.
Links bestimmt dann auch wieder.
Weiß nicht.
Ich aim die Mitte.
Was haben wir denn? Flash?
Flamer?
Bei uns ist auf der linken Seite war was.
Bei uns im Spawn.
Der ist schon da?
Ja.
Der hat richtig Hit, einen Pistolentreffer noch.
Aber sicher noch den Headshot hinterher hauen.
Muss.
Okay, was haben wir denn?
Ich stell mich mal aufs Waschbecken.
Ob ich da irgendwo einen kommen sehe
auf der linken Seite oder so.
Ah, da einer ist in der Mitte.
Was haben wir denn da?
What habe ich denn gerade für Hits bekommen?
Ich habe 8 humanos.
Rechts hat einer.
Fuck, fuck, fuck!
Shit!
Wir haben echt zu viel gewonnen.
Vereine viel schwerer.
Oder ich kriege heute nichts mehr gebacken.
Eins von beiden.
Die haben nicht grad falsche Reste, aber die sind nicht gut.
Ich stelle mich mal wieder aufs Waschbecken, das war glaube ich nicht schlecht.
Die sind echt nicht so gut.
Wenn du mir sagst, wer es ist, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ne, ich weiß nicht.
Ah, Mitte, Mitte spawnen.
Bei denen.
Oha.
Links im Spawn.
Fuck, rechts, rechte Seite bei ihnen im Spawn.
Ey, mit mir kannst du ja nichts mehr anfangen.
Da oben ist er.
Ah, schön.
Oh.
Gut.
Kann er mal sterben?
Oh, ich hatte 5er B, gell.
Ey, ich glaube, aber du hast richtig nice geownt.
Weg mit dem Dreck.
Okay, Out of shotgun.
Einer hat einen Hit, in der Mitte.
Er kommt close to us.
Ich glaube es nicht, ey.
Ich glaube, ich muss aufhören.
Nice, du machst das.
Easy.
Ich muss, ich muss.
Ich kann direkt sterben.
Das ist kein Problem.
Easy win.
Ne, aber mit mir kannst du gerade echt nichts mehr anfangen.
Ich stehe da, gucke um die Ecke, bam, tot.
Ohne, dass ich irgendwie checken würde, was passiert.
Und die Leute schauen nicht mal in einem guten Gameplay zu, das ist echt traurig.
Der rechts hat ganz gute Hits.
In der Mitte war einer.
Oh, fuck.
Einer steht noch in der Mitte.
Hat er auch wieder Hit drinne?
Ah, close von dem Spawn.
Andere Seite.
Chat, give energy.
Wir müssen diese Scheiße noch gewinnen.
Sonst kann ich nicht richtig pennen nachher.
Ist das Auto?
Ja, das Noobtube.
Mach dann Raketenwerfer.
Und bumm.
Ein Gott, ich krieg nichts gebacken.
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Boah, ist die schlecht.
Oh, nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, fuck.
Wie hat jemand geholt diesen?
Der Chat, der Chat, gift energy.
Jetzt, jetzt müssen wir gewinnen.
Ich hab dann immer noch keine einzige Nachricht in meinem Chat heute.
Chat, das kann doch nicht sein.
Nein.
Ist ja egal.
Okay, ich, ich, ich guck links.
Ist nix da.
Ah, ist unten.
Okay, einer ist weg.
Aber einer war rechts noch im Spawn.
Einer ist in der Mitte, einer ist in der Mitte.
Hab ich ihn gerade rausgucken sehen.
Das war nicht die Mitte, der war rechts.
Dann ist er wieder rüber.
Jawoll.
Dafür hast du es gut gemacht.
Uff.
Wie heißt der Kanal von dem Dude?
Hier, so.
Wettretz, so wie ingame.
Von dem Dude, ey.
Wie wimmst der Dude?
Einer hat links Hit, ich aber auch.
Ja, du...
Oha, die haben...
Oh, nein, nein, nein.
Einer ist rechts im...
Einer ist los.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Lahm ist, aber ich glaub, das ist ein...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Lahm ist, aber ich glaub, dass es Follow ist.
Danke.
Jetzt habe ich gerade absolut keinen Stoff gehabt.
Ich tue es jetzt aus.
Rechts.
Ah, fuck, 1.
Kumpel.
1, 1.
Da ist er.
Rechts.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Oh, Gott.
Ich selekte dich, danke.
Ich kann mich hier nicht muten, sorry, sonst würde ich mich von dir bewegen.
Du bist der Mensch, der mich bewegen lässt.
Ja, gleich.
Vielleicht mag ich mich muten.
Nee, nee.
Passt schon.
Können93 paar Follows da lassen.
Irgendeiner muss mich ja carried, gerade.
Ich hatte 69 Follows.
Einer war rechts.
Wollte ich gar nicht, wollte nur Abos.
Ist einer links.
So cocky sind wir dann auch nicht.
Oh, einer in der Mitte.
Oh Gott.
Ok, einer hat gut Granaten.
Hit.
Ich k oyster diese Pistols auf diese Distanz.
Die sind so unreliable.
Könnte er links kommen?
Ja, ja, ja...
20 AP.
Oh Gott.
20 gespalten.
Ah, hier ist ja embedded Teile По.
ặ года, also.
War nicht bis jetzt, dass ich ...
Da kann man jetzt aber aus der Hüfte schießen beim Slidern.
Sliderino.
Stell dir das mal in echt vor, du runzt so über den Boden und dann schiebst du dich
vor Arm.
Vor allem noch den Gangster-Style, nicht irgendwie nach oben, sondern so, weißt du, schräg.
Wir haben gewonnen, ich hab gar nicht aufgepasst.
Wie viel haben wir denn jetzt?
22, 36.
Komm, eins können wir noch spielen, das müssen wir jetzt auch gewinnen, Chat.
Ich penn.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Auch wenn heute, ich hab versucht, noch mit zwei anderen Kollegen Battle Royale zu spielen,
ey.
Voll verschissen.
Brauchst halt gute Kollegen.
Nee, ich glaub, die sind gar nicht so übel, aber ich hab das Problem, ich hab noch so
keinen Plan von dem Spielmodus, wenn ich keinen dabei hab, der ein bisschen Ansage macht,
wohin und was wir jetzt als nächstes machen, ich renne voll planlos rum, deswegen klappt
das ja auch so ganz gut.
Weißt du, wenn du sagst, hier, wir gehen jetzt da rein, dann machen wir jetzt hier
erstmal nichts.
Das kommt halt vom CS-Richtspiel, da kann man gut carry'n.
Da kann man gut call'n.
Das funktioniert.
Hast du gerade Urlaub, oder warum streamst du so viel?
Tja.
Oh, ich muss ja morgen arbeiten.
Fuck.
Ja, ich muss dann, ich muss dann echt pennen gleich.
Oh, Rust.
Beste.
Elf Zuschauer, hi.
Wenn ich 75 Zuschauer nicht hab, dann können wir einen Squad-Stream machen, weil dann bin
ich Spaten.
Aber, da muss noch eindeutig mehr Content kommen.
Willst du danach weiter streamen, oder ist dann Schluss?
Ja, ich glaub, ich spiel was.
Und danach noch bisschen.
Und dann, dann raiden wir dich danach.
So, mal gucken, wo sind sie?
Einer.
Oh, ich bin einfach destakt.
Oben vielleicht?
Ne, ich bin aufm, aufm Rohr.
Aufm Rohr oben bin ich.
So, magst du das nachladen?
Ja.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Ah, es wird...
Er ist hinten.
Äh, in...
Was ist denn das?
Der Durchgang zur...
Ich töt ihn einfach, dann soll ich dir wohl über...
Ja.
Wow, ach hier hinten.
Am rot, am roten Container.
Das ist echt ne Frau.
Ich wollte eigentlich Takedown machen, aber dann dachte ich so...
Gehört sich nicht.
Gehört зовут denkt bei Frauen.
Wir werden mal links gucken, ob da was kommt.
Okay, ich seh nichts.
Ah, ich sehe einen hinten.
Ich geh mal links durch wieder.
Oh, hier.
Der ist gehittet oben, sagt die, hi, heirate mich, was, ähm, einer ist über mir, eventuell,
ich hab's nicht gehört, oah, es gibt auch noch Schaden, oh fuck, wo ist er, irgendwo
oben, oder, weiß ich nicht, wir können einfach einen nehmen, klar, oh, ich wurde von links
gehittert irgendwo, was ist links, äh, ja, ja, am, am, am Durchslide, Durchslide-Ding,
ich nehm einen, pass mal auf, Hüften, Hüftegeballer, ich wollte ihn schlagen, aber ich hatte keine
Ding mehr, ich schreib mal high rein, oh, beste, beste, Waffe, ich guck links, ob was
kommt, ich seh nix, ah, einer ist hier oben auf dem Dich, ich geh mal rauf, ich geh mal
rauf, oh, einer rennt auf der B-Flagge gerade, okay, ey, ich, ich kann's vergessen, ich
krieg heute nix mehr gebacken,
ich krieg heute nix mehr hin, ey, ich treff nix, vergiss es, ja, nach sechs Stunden klappt's
aber nicht mehr, also, ich kann an mich glauben, aber, ey, ich treff nix mehr, es ist der Wahnsinn,
mir tun übelst die Ellenbogen weh, seitdem ich wieder so viel spiele, ganz merkwürdig,
ja, easy, easy win, was heißt hier 0 W,
ich seh nix, ich seh gar keinen, ich renn mal zu denen ins Spawn, ich mach's, oh, down,
hier ist einer oben, oben in der Mitte, in der Mitte ist er drin, in diesem Gerüst,
unten, unten im Gerüst irgendwo, what, what, wo ist der denn so schnell hin, der ist, der
ist, glaub bei uns hinten im Spawn, irgendwo da, egal, wie ist der denn so schnell da hingekommen,
ich schreibe mal sorry für erschrecken der hat richtig die golden dragon arca sowjet
geil die sieht ja mal brutal geil aus warum hab ich denn diesen stil nicht ich würde den direkt
kaufen wo ach schön im container in der mitte lulwe schreibt schmerzt den chat
die hat er sogar ein messer vorne dran ist das nur ist das nur show oder macht es dann
wirklich worden aber die goldene arca mit granatwerfer und mit trommel okay
so lade ich eigentlich nach bei 1000 schuss und ich bin dämlich runtergesprungen das ist
natürlich schlecht halt einfach drauf bin runter gesprungen und habe lehrt hast du
für fallschirm gedrückt
was irgendwie nicht so ganz funktioniert
sagt du bist ganz stumm du kannst mich mal callouts geben
ach sind das deutsche
der ist oben in der mitte
so
hat spaß gemacht ich muss sagen ich sage jetzt mal was es ist halt auch schwer wenn
du nicht kalt man call doch mal nächstes mal jetzt vielleicht doch nicht die die die
trennen sich gleich an installen was auch immer weißt ja nicht ja toxic chat aller
nicht toxic chat top toxic weiß
aber nicht toxic chat toxic voice
toxic voice
tofu
so
ich war also so
bent 97
ne ich ist meine meinung
es sei nicht gemeint
未acung
ich dachte er als dachte er beschwert sich
nein
selbst đâu
Taschen
man
holteırım
ja
so
eine sauerei
acht jahre
es ist ja geil das sie nawet secrets calls
das attitude weil ich fand es lustig
das auch cool
aufschlagen
Achso, ja, wir können auch aufbrechen.
Ne, lass kommen, den machen wir noch. Bazaar ist eine gute Map.
Ich brauch auch so... Wo hast du das gemeindet oder hast du irgendwelche extra Tees für deine schönen Gifs, die immer reinfliegen?
Das ist was, was ich selbst programmiert habe. Das ist ein Webinterface auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Da kann man das einfach anklicken.
Scheiße.
Big Brain.
Oh, jetzt kommt...
Einer ist links rum.
Wow.
Oh, einer ist oben.
Und ich wurde gehittet.
Du weißt, was heißt, wenn wir verlieren, was?
Dann?
Kann ich nicht ins Bett oder was?
Ja.
Du hättest uns einfach dabei lassen sollen.
Ne, ne, ne, easy, chat, energy, energy, energy.
Energy, energy.
Jetzt hol ich dich.
Wem?
Beide rechts.
Ich werf mal die mit der Nade ab.
Haben Hits.
Die sind noch geflasht.
Oh, einer ist down, einer ist noch hinten im Spawn bei denen.
Ich hab halt...
Du hast mehr.
Was?
Ich hab's gesehen, du warst direkt drauf.
Aber diese Diesel ist halt einfach auch scheiße.
Räudische Waffe.
Wann hab ich denn in die Wand geguckt? Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Also ich hab's bei dir auch so gesehen, deshalb warst voll drauf.
0 zu 2. Nie mehr wieder werde ich dieses Spiel spielen.
Boah, beide wieder oben bei mir.
Hol sie dir.
Der hat 20 AP.
Mach keinen Scheiß.
Ich warte jetzt, ich mach's jetzt einfach safe.
Er denkt, dass du da hinlaufen wirst.
Heißt, ich mach was anderes.
Er sieht auch deinen grünen Laser so.
Du hast doch noch eine Zweitwaffe für 20 AP.
Die Frage wird oben sein, vergiss nicht.
Jawoll, 0AD hat das immer.
Gott, Griff.
Ich mein, Max und Moritz muss ja ein gutes Team sein.
Ach, du hast Moritz?
Ja, klar.
Das ist ja nice.
Das passt richtig gut.
Okay, rechts ist nix.
Einer oben, einer kommt mit Shotgun.
Halt, beide, beide.
Ah, der kommt her.
Achtung, du musst zurecht hin.
Der hat Hit.
Jawoll.
Lil W, PogChamp.
Bumm.
Stabile Uhr.
Ist die iced out?
Das ist die Default-Uhr.
Es gibt keine Default-Uhr.
Echt nicht?
Nee.
Okay, einer war links.
Einer ist oben in der Mitte.
Der kommt zu dir.
Der kommt zu dir gepusht.
Ich bin bei dir.
Ach so, ich dachte, du bist rechts.
Ich war rechts.
Ich hab einfach mit C4 wieder 40 Schaden.
Lustig.
Ey, danke für diesen Tipp mit OBS minimieren.
Das ist zwar so simpel, aber...
Holy shit.
Es läuft, als wenn ich nicht streame.
Ich seh nix, ne?
Ich tu nur so, als bin ich kackenob und...
Wow.
Da ist C4 hinter geflogen gekommen.
Ich hab mega die Hits bekommen.
Ach man, links tut einer spawnen.
Hol ihn dir.
Oh, huge play.
Porras, ey.
Wie hab ich 400 Schaden und einen Kill?
Das ist ne gute Frage.
Ey, wie in Warzone.
4000 Schaden und 5 Kills oder so.
Der Tipp mit OBS war einfach minimieren.
Du musst alle dein Internet fixieren.
Hinten ist einer.
Bei dir kommt einer.
Okay, passt.
Ah, noch oben bei dir.
Der hat fett Hit.
Der ist noch drin.
Der guckt in deine Richtung.
Nice.
So, zwei Runden noch.
Er sagt allen Leuten, die müssen Internet fixen.
Aber die haben einfach 160er Ping.
Ich tu nur so, als halte ich da rein.
Ich hab nämlich nix gesehen.
Ich komm mal zu dir rüber.
Hab ich einen Hit bekommen links?
Hab ich einen Hit bekommen?
Ich hab einen jetzt schon so früh geimt und...
Das könnte sein, dass der auch uns komplett geflankt hat, ne?
Das glaub ich nämlich auch.
Okay.
Jawoll.
Muss ja...
So kanns auch gehen.
Moist.
No, yo host, I see Pings.
Switching sides.
Okay.
Match 1.
Ich schreib eins zurück, was ihn nervt.
QQ.
Okay, was ist das für ein Ding?
QQ?
Nein.
Heulen.
Achso.
Oh, ich hab nen Hit.
Der ist links im Spawn.
Ah, ich hab's.
Warte.
Er schießt halt vor.
Wo?
Der andere geht.
The fuck?
Zwei gegen eins für die letzte Runde.
Ach, der ist geleaved?
Ja, ja.
Warum?
Ist der blöd?
Ja, weil der dachte, es ist vorbei.
Tja.
Siehste?
Lass ihn mal zusammen peeken.
Komm.
Er kann uns nicht beide holen.
Ah, der rennt rechts hoch.
Er rennt rechts hoch.
Hier oben ist er.
Ich dachte, du hast ihn schon.
Alter.
What the hell?
Wir verlieren jetzt nicht gegen einen.
Komm.
So.
Also.
Wir gehen nach dem.
Mal gucken, was für ne Waffe kommt.
Gib mir ne.
Egal.
Lass zusammenlaufen.
Hat gar keine Chance.
Hier oben.
Wir dürfen nicht zusammen peeken.
Einfach.
Wir dürfen das machen, was die...
Ja.
Er ist nicht bei uns.
Dann schaffts auf der anderen Seite.
Kein Hit.
Ah, hier.
Er ist oben.
Oha.
Was er trifft.
Wo ist er?
Bei ihm ist...
Da.
Er ist bei sich hochgegangen.
Er ist oben.
Er hat 20 HP.
Der ist einfach so.
Der kommt runtergehüpft in seinen Spawn.
Unten.
Rechts.
Jawoll.
Da.
Links.
Oder rechts.
Ich glaub eher links.
Jawoll.
Der hat 20 HP.
Muss hinter dem Ding sein.
Alter.
Wir haben das jetzt verloren.
Gegen einen.
Ja.
So.
Sollst du mal.
Der hat Chat keine Energy gegeben.
Der Chat...
Erstens hat der Chat keine Energy gegeben.
Und zweitens habe ich ihn nicht getroffen.
Was macht der?
15.000 Schaden.
Hi.
RIP.
Wie kann man das verlieren?
Der WTF?
Was haben wir da jetzt?
Verkackt, Alter.
Was haben wir?
22 Schuhe.
Wir müssen noch eins spielen.
Wir müssen noch gewinnen.
Oder wollen wir Schluss machen?
Doch.
Ich werd auch danach noch eine Runde Warzone spielen, weil ich es manchmal nicht mehr
versprochen hab.
Ja.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch eine Runde.
Das geht bis 23 Uhr.
Dann hoste ich dich.
Oder ich raide dich.
Oder was auch immer.
Und dann bleibt jeder einzelne da, bis ich schlafe.
Genau.
Wir können ja immer abwechselnd 6 Stunden streamen.
Da kann immer einer 6 Stunden schlafen.
Beste Idee.
Und wann gehen wir arbeiten?
Ist overrated.
Overrated.
Ja.
Wir können auch mal einmal 6 Stunden arbeiten.
Oder arbeitest eh nicht mehr als 6 Stunden.
Du meinst einfach einchecken?
Homeoffice startet und dann...
Stempeln und dann...
Nee, nee, nee, sowas wollen wir nicht.
Natürlich nicht.
Nein.
Das würden wir nie machen.
Arbeiten.
Lull W.
Der Chat.
Das Ding ist, wenn der Chat 10 mal mehr wär, dann müsste man nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich glaub wir hätten das eben ein bisschen defensiver spielen müssen, weil was hat er
gerade gemacht.
spielen müssen weil was hat er machen sollen großartig spätestens wenn die
flacke kommt hat man gewonnen die frau hat mich angenommen juhu erst mal
vorgas und einer push in der mitte links glaube oder einer polter kommt mitte
mitte mitte hat hit ja auf dem ding oben drauf
okay ich verstehe diese mechanik nicht wie er schneller schießen kann obwohl er
erst leidet wo ist er denn ich weiß nicht ich treffe nichts mehr
es ist wirklich schlimm aber ich habe echt zu lange gespielt da kann man hoch
jaha chat anscheinend über die einer über die eine schneller als man überhaupt
mit maus schießen
da bestimmt hier den trigger bot geht das näher oder das sagst du kannst so
schnell wie du drücken kannst kann schießen
was ist denn das alter ich hab voll reingedrückt mit dem fucking controller
das rechts ja chat da kann man das ich habe das auch noch nie gesehen dass man
da hoch kann aber anscheinend macht er das gerne hier
hey muss das drehen
vielleicht kann ich glaube ich lade die gleich mal ein und das wird lustig
dann gucken ob die dann mit echten callern besser spielt ist der andere der andere ist in der mitte
hüft aber mit der kannst du aus der hüfte schießen damit triffst du alles naja das war klug
farmers das ist die beste ist das burst ist das burst müsste einer ist hier mitte oben
rechts von dir
ziel bitte dann trifft
das macht dich so viel besser wenn du nämlich anfängst an zu zielen dann triffst du nämlich alles
easy clap
1 x
1 auf rechts
1 ist rechts am start
ist rechts am start
1 auf rechts
Ich höre links was laufen.
Oh, rechte Seite.
Ey, was geht ab?
Der war links hinten, als er mich gekillt hat.
Also, ja.
Ich habe mehr HP.
Nice.
Reaktion 1,0.
Ich frage mich gerade,
was bei denen abgeht.
Was ist denn das?
Hot Nugget.
Ja.
Racer ist durchgepusht.
Nein, Mann.
Ich habe blauer P.
Oder nicht, doch.
Er hat einen Schuss schon.
Oben, erst bei der Treppe bei sich.
Als 55.
Links, links, links, links, unten.
Durchs Geländer.
Der ist halt in den Kopf gegangen,
weil er dich getroffen hat und du Aim-Punch-Shot hast.
Aber der hatte schon Damage von dir.
Wahrscheinlich wäre er auch so gestorben.
Der ist einfach noch hinten im Spawn drin, oben.
Ja, ja.
Brenne.
Ich habe nur noch 20 HP.
Der eine ist immer noch im Spawn hinten.
Ich mag dieses Hot Nugget einfach absolut nicht.
Ich mag es nicht.
What the fuck?
Du triffst...
Sind die beide da hinten?
Nimm mal auf die Flagge einfach.
Versuch es.
Der eine ist in der Flagge.
Das ist aber eine Kack-Pistole.
Ja, die Deagle ist einfach verunstaltet worden.
Oh, meins.
Das ist der Single-Schuss, ne?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und dazu noch eine Deagle mit Autismus.
Der eine ist hier runtergerüfft.
Der peekt in der Mitte.
Ah, wen?
Den Linken.
Nee, links ist auch noch einer.
Der ist der Letzte.
Ich habe ihn getroffen mit dem Termit.
Er kommt hier rechts.
Er kommt hier rechts außen.
Er hat schon einen Hit.
Wie machen die das mit der Deagle?
20 HP.
Er kann schneller schießen mit der Deagle.
Er kann viel schneller schießen als du, aber...
Easy. Easy.
Klepp.
Ins Fuß geschossen.
Das Fuß.
Oder eigentlich zwischen die Füße, aber...
Zum Glück hat er schon einen Hit drin.
Jetzt müssen wir...
Okay, ist das wieder das Gleiche? Ja, ne?
Ja, das Gleiche.
Ich bin rechts drauf.
Ich glaube, die sind beide rechts.
Habe ich... Ich glaube.
Ich glaube so.
Einer down.
Der eine ist noch oben.
Er hat einen Hit.
Ja, ja.
Nice.
Weg von hier.
Einfach schießen auf Mausrad?
Das geht?
Sagt der Chat gerade.
Ja, das geht, aber...
Ey, you know what? You lost, so STFU.
Sind sie am Flamen?
Bitte beherrsch dich. Deine Mutter mag das auch nicht. So.
Deswegen habe ich Voicechat aus.
Er sagt, du deutscher Wurensohn.
Solche Worte.
Anzeige ist raus.
Aber ohne Witz. Aber dir wird immer abgelehnt.
Aber schießen auf dem Mausrad?
Wie will man den Maus gescheit bewegen?
Dann Gunfight.
Ach, die spielt echt Gunfight.
Aber spielt die mit jemandem zusammen?
Oh, okay.
Wir raiden dich jetzt.
Ich mache jetzt...
Ich lade jetzt meine Kollegen ein.
Slash Raid.
Also Chat.
Fokus.
Max muss jetzt ins Bett.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Also.
Jung und frisch.
Genau.
Dann hau noch ein paar Wins raus.
Bis...
Bis dann.
Ich mache Discord aus.
Jawohl.
Bis dann. Tschüss.
Also Chat.
Wir raiden ihn jetzt mal.
War echt ganz schönes Geschwitze am Schluss.
Aber was willst du machen?
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis dann.
See you.